supreme court
has ruled in favor of churches in
california
there are more lockdowns on the way joe
biden's advisor
dr osterholm says we need a six-week
hard national lockdown
but it seems like in many different
circumstances the supreme court is
saying
you can't do it there have been already
several rulings of the past year
stopping many of these lockdowns we just
saw the supreme court ruling in new york
but it seems like we're still going to
be going through this back and forth of
those who think we should and those who
think we shouldn't but i bring this up
because there is something else behind
all of this and it's called
the great reset the world economic forum
said that covet is an
opportunity to reset global capitalism
so that
global stakeholders have a better you
know i don't know responsibility
towards the planet and the new york
times the bbc many outlets said this is
a conspiracy
conspiracy theory they call it the great
con the great recent conspiracy theory
well what they add is that the theory is
there is a plan to reset global
capitalism
but kovid was a hoax that's not
necessarily what the great reset is and
so when you google it's really funny
you'll see the world economic forum
saying the great reset opportunity and
then next to it the new york times
saying it's a conspiracy theory
well regardless of the conspiracy stuff
i can say fine to the new york times
but the hill has recently published an
op-ed john kerry reveals biden's
devotion to radical great reset movement
and we can see in statements made by
john kerry who's going to be
representing the biden administration in
terms of climate change that they want
to take advantage of
kovid to move into a kind of lockdown
that would help alleviate the problems
of climate change
considering what we've already seen i
can only imagine people will lose their
minds and things will get really really
bad so we're going to break all this
down and talk about this news
as well some other news pertaining to
kyle rittenhouse and it all it works out
really well because today we are joined
by the one and only destiny
hey what's up thanks for having me here
and uh how i'll just let you describe
yourself to a quick intro because i
don't want to you know yeah so i do
politics and gaming on which camera
looks at me who do i look at that one
right that guy okay i do politics and
gaming on twitch and youtube
i go by destiny there uh i don't know
how i would characterize myself
politically probably
center left to far left or if you're a
communist on far right
and yeah otherwise yeah we just run down
i'm a huge ride and forbidden supporter
um are you really oh yeah millions right
love them i heard here i'm described as
obama 2.0
very much in favor of that so i'm
excited for four years
of biden maybe eight years maybe he'll
go for a second term we'll see otherwise
maybe kamala harris will step in
for the second term and oh man how
exciting would that be most progressive
the voting record in the senate yeah i
think people uh they always assume that
like
it's going to be some kind of internet
bloodsport we clearly disagree and a lot
of stuff it's going to be a fun
conversation i think you know we'll have
some back and forth it'll be great
i think you were mentioning you know all
that stuff because were you you were
looking at me as you were saying
obama 2.0 and all that stuff oh yeah
yeah it'll be fun yeah yeah yeah right
on right on yeah we were testing the
limiters before they're screaming seeing
how loud we can go in the mic
yeah yeah we should be good to go yeah
we we we have this thing where i can
we can both scream at full volume and it
automatically limits so that you don't
blow your ears
okay you guys are welcome ian's hanging
out so this would be this would be
really interesting too
and of course lydia is producing i am
producing and uh make sure you smash
that like button subscribe to
notification bell we are live monday
friday at 8pm
well let's just uh jump to the first
story and we'll uh we'll talk about
john kerry reveals biden's devotion to
radical great reset movement
from the hill this to me is really funny
because they say the great race is
conspiracy theory but it's actually what
they've been calling it for some time
the hill says in june elites at an
important
at important international institutions
such as the world economic forum
and the united nations launched a
far-reaching campaign to reset the
global economy
the plan involves dramatically
increasing the power of government
through expansive new social programs
like the green new deal and using vast
regulatory schemes and government
programs
to coerce corporations into supporting
left-wing causes obviously this is uh
i think it's a it's a biased view of
what they're saying but to be fair
the world economic forum has pushed a
lot of left-wing causes as they
reference the great reset
it goes on to say the two justifications
for the proposal
which has been aptly named by its
supporters the great reset are the covet
19 pandemic the short-term justification
and the so-called climate crisis clause
caused by global warming the long-term
justification
according to the great reset supporters
the plan would fundamentally transform
much of society
as world economic forum head klaus
schwab wrote back in june quote
the world must act jointly and swiftly
to revamp all aspects of our societies
and economies
from education to social contracts and
working conditions every country from
the united states to china
must participate and every industry from
oil and gas to tech
must be transformed in short we need a
great reset
of capitalism they going to say
internationally the great reset has
already been backed by influential
leaders
activists academics and institutions in
addition to the world economic forum and
the united nations the great reset
movement counts among its international
among its there's a missing word i
suppose the international monetary fund
heads of state greenpeace and ceos and
resident
presidents of large corporations and
financial institutions such as microsoft
and mastercard
but in america most policymakers
including president-elect joe biden have
been relatively quiet about the great
reset
leaving many to speculate what a biden
administration would do to support or
oppose this radical plan
they go on to say that at a panel
discussion about the great reset hosted
by the world economic forum in
mid-november
former secretary of state john kerry
biden's would-be special presidential
envoy for climate
firmly declared that the biden
administration will support the great
reset
and that the great reset quote will
happen with greater speed and with
greater intensity
than a lot of people might imagine when
asked by panel host borge brend
whether the world economic forum and
other and other great research
supporters are expecting too much too
soon from the new president
or is he going to deliver the first day
on this
on these topics kerry responded the
answer to your question is
no you're not expecting too much and yes
the great reset will happen
and i think it will happen with greater
speed and with greater intensity
than a lot of people might imagine in
effect the citizens of the united states
have just done a great reset
we've done a great reset and it was a
record level of voting
kerry later argued that the great reset
is necessary to slow the climate crisis
and that quote i know joe biden believes
it's not enough to just rejoin the para
paris climate accords for the united
states it's not enough for us
to just do the minimum of what paris
requires
so i'm not going to read literally every
you know the last bit of this it's
clearly an opinion piece but it's
talking about something that's
actually happening lockdowns
i'm gonna ask you uh destiny your
opinion because you were mentioning
before that you're for them
well oh we can check with the great we
said we're gonna talk about lockdowns
well we're we're talking about the great
reset for sure
i mean unless you want to respond to
that first oh that all sounded really
cool
i guess um the idea that uh we have an
opportunity to reorganize things
based around like some kind of like
ongoing crisis that might expose
uh you know weak parts of our economy or
weak parts of you know healthcare
infrastructure or whatever like i think
the idea of
capitalizing on those types of disasters
and
moving new programs forward i think is
really good i think it's like pretty
standard business practice too
right like nobody files bankruptcy and
comes back the exact same way right
usually it's an opportunity to
restructure your business to get rid of
stuff that doesn't work to
improve on stuff that does work like i
don't see the horrible part about that
but more specifically lockdown sir
yeah so i guess the general idea is that
when they're talking about lockdowns
they're not talking about covet they're
talking about the great reset and
climate change
and that's that's the gist of what i get
from john kerry's statements
initially they said the great reset you
know of global capitalism whatever would
be due to
due to covet it's a great opportunity to
do it but then clearly what their real
concern is
climate change i just because you
take an opportunity to um so i think it
was chicago i think was one of the
cities that had like massive fires that
like ravaged the city and they used the
opportunity to rebuild a lot of the
city's infrastructure
i don't think people were ever claiming
they set the fires just to rebuild the
city
i don't think um i don't think anybody
would claim that we want to lock down
the country just to further climate
change
there might be a way to make a stop
climate change or to further climate
change anticlimactic engineering yeah um
that might be an argument that one could
make in another world where we aren't
topping ourselves
every single day with record numbers of
infections and deaths like if we were
australia or
new zealand and we were doing lockdowns
continually then maybe like oh hold on
there's an agenda here
um but i mean like we're losing twin
towers worth of people every day
the idea that this is just a conspiracy
to pass climate change agenda stuff
seems like a hard sell to me i don't
think it's that it's a conspiracy i
think it's that they're exploiting a
crisis
i think that's good shouldn't we do that
not necessarily
isn't it isn't a crisis like one of your
best opportunities to like restructure
like
like i give with the example of like a
like a failing business like if
something really horrible happens
generally horrible things happen because
they expose some type of flaw or defect
in what you do like isn't that the time
for change especially because that's
when you're going to get the most like
activism behind it don't people have
rights though
like don't you have a right to make
choices for yourself live your life
something especially with the with the
constitution
so that's a very vague sense i mean like
do i have the right to go out and get
drunk and drive
you don't okay so we have some rights
right yes
we're not infringing on the rights of
others so whether that's crashing in a
drunk driving accident or infecting
somebody with sars kobe 2 right it's
probably
depends on what right we're talking
about i would imagine yeah so if if you
don't want to
get sick then shouldn't you stay home
if you don't want a drunk driver to hit
you should you just never drive well
that's different that's someone someone
who might be sick and doesn't know and
is living their life under emergency
circumstances like i have to make money
and feed my family
there's no circumstance where you have
to be drunk and drive if there's no
circumstance we have to be outside and
standing right next to people without a
mask or whatever
we're not talking about that we're
talking well i mean if you want to
criticize the black lives matter
protests and you know the the biden's
you know the big biden rallies or
whatever they just did when biden won
then yeah there's no reason for those
people to be doing that stuff you know
you can simultaneously criticize them
and the anti-lockdown people too as well
right that's not like
like i can criticize both to be to my
knowledge a lot of the people were in
those protests were wearing masks
though i mean from what i said well in
the in the biden one they were taking
their masks off and drinking and sharing
drinks was like one of the big videos
that came around
that's pretty dumb for sure for sure but
i'm just more fundamentally i'm just
saying that like um
the to to come up with the like don't we
have rights well yeah i mean of course
we do
but i mean we learned this growing up
with more rights also comes more
responsibility you know like
so yeah i think that the drunk driving
thing doesn't work
like there's a guy in staten island he
got arrested trying to run his bar he
has to
otherwise he becomes homeless and he
can't feed his family and then what did
they beg the government for help the
government's not giving it to him and
you can blame mitch mcconnell or nancy
pelosi no we could blame mitch mcconnell
pelosi sent him
like trillions of dollars of bills are
dying on his desk but we still had we
saw a democrat saying it was pelosi's
fault you had wolf blitzer criticizing
pelosi so i think it's fair to point the
finger at both
we we can we're pointing a very short
dwarven finger at one and we're pointing
like the
the nose of pinocchio at the other um in
terms of people fighting over
specifically you know what is pelosi
pushing for what is she not pushing for
um there can be back and forth over that
the fact of the matter is there was some
like 2.5 trillion dollar bill that was
left in mcconnell's desk when he moon
walked out of the senate after they
confirmed acb
so i mean like the blame is not even
remotely close to equal there
the house passed legislation the senate
let it die that's true you can't you
can't both sides that one i don't think
but
well i think that's whether or not it's
me trying to do it i'm this is what
people are doing right well so wolf
blitzer might have specifically
criticized like hey pelosi
he cited what he cited ro khanna he was
citing democrats who were calling out
pelosi
and pelosi didn't want to answer the
question so
look if like obviously if you're on the
right the right's going to say see
the issue with the heroes act was that
they wanted fun like you know they were
stuffing things in it that didn't make
sense and the republicans did the same
thing they wanted money for an fbi
building
i don't want i don't want to go off on
the on the you know democrat first
republican sure well it's important
because i don't
obviously it's a huge diehard biden fan
i'm going to fight viciously back
against idea that both sides messed up
the fact of the matter is is that if i
go into the senate
um they did not give us legislation for
any type of growing virus release and
pelosi did she delivered we have that
legislation that's sitting on the floor
of the
senate and it's never going to be called
for a vote well so i want to keep it to
yeah
the lockdown rights the great reset
stuff yeah so
the government is clearly not providing
for people regardless regardless of
whose fault it is you can say it's
republicans fault then absolutely sure
what is a working class you know man or
woman to do
when they're told and specifically in
staten island the issue was that
this bar wasn't allowed to serve people
but two blocks away everything was
normal
they said this specific zone has been
locked down so the guy said
i have nothing left i have nothing left
to lose the money that did go out
overwhelmingly went to massive
corporations the lockdown is
overwhelmingly
uh um uh overwhelming overwhelmingly
benefiting the money should go to
massive corporations right
no why not it should go to the people
who can then buy resources to go to the
businesses to make sure they can cover
their costs and their taxes okay so
the ppp loans uh yeah i wish i remember
what every we're just saying for
but the ppp loans were loans given to
corporations that allow them to cover up
to 2.5 months of employment expenses
right when they paid employees if they
did that then the loan was going to be
forgiven
we still haven't gotten the paperwork
for what that forgiveness looks like but
that's the point so if i have one
corporation that hires
10 000 people and another company that
hires 10 people well of course more
money is going to go to the corporation
because there's more role to cover right
but it's not the corporation
what i meant was not that a small
business with 10 employees
was getting money what i meant was when
the lockdown happens the money ends up
in the hands of the ultra wealthy
the stores that are allowed to remain
open tend to be the big box stores and
that's why we saw the massive profits
the massive uh spiking and stock value
for these big companies notably amazon
the working-class people got 1200 bucks
yeah stock
but if you if you i'm just talking very
specifically um because it's very
important
to understand each of these policies so
the ppp only works for you
if you pay out employees so i got a ppp
loan the way that that works the way the
paperwork details is that when i get
that money i can claim up to two and a
half times the expenses of all of my
employees
and the only money that's forgiven for
me is what i pay out to my employees so
for me personally there were like two
people that i kept on payroll just
because oh well the government's gonna
pay for it yeah screw it i'll take the
ppp money and then i'll continue to pay
him out because it'll be forgiven i only
kept those two people on payroll because
the government gave me that ppp money
any corporation isn't to pocket the
money it gets paid out to employees did
they give you money to pay your rent pay
your taxes
pay your costs replace perishable goods
no it's just to cover the cost of
employing the employees so discover
everything yeah what happens the
lockdown is
massive businesses the likes of
mcdonald's starbucks they can shut down
and they can roll oh and they can
observe oh 100 percent
small businesses are being destroyed so
that's the question i said don't people
have rights
when the when these people we've see we
see now there's a west michigan story
going viral
where a guy there's a news report going
on a guy walks out of his restaurant
and he yells to the the news reporter
he's like is this you talking about me
and he said they've taken everything the
money is going to the their friends it's
going to special interests
these the bail that came out people did
get a stimulus
and then money did go to small
businesses but if the small businesses
are shut down and can't sell things what
happens the restaurant their perishable
goods gone they can't reopen
so in new jersey a third of small
businesses have been destroyed sure and
i've heard similar in new york
restaurants and everything like a lot of
places that are closing are never coming
back probably so try it's a tragedy of
course yeah
so in i guess to keep it in context of
the great reset
talking about exploiting a crisis to
make some change
is also destroying the lives of people
resulting in spikes in suicide spikes in
crime
i don't think we're locking down though
for the great reset i think we're
locking down because record numbers of
people getting infected and dying from
the coronavirus if we can do something
on the backs of that
i don't think that would be the worst
thing in the world maybe part of that
great reset
and i'm almost positive without knowing
the intricacies i'm pretty sure that
part of that great reset is probably
going to be like more stimulus for small
business owners is going to be covering
healthcare for people
it's going to be more types of like uh
checks or disbursements during like
times of crisis that's probably going to
be baked into that great reset as well
because
as you accurately pointed out the the
relief that we got so far even the ppp
loans were a joke and what is that
one twelve hundred dollar check i think
went out to every american yep that's
like
it would have almost been better to send
nothing because that twelve hundred
dollars like a slap on the face like
what's wrong
did you know that twenty three point six
percent of all us dollars ever created
was created this year
um i was not aware of that that's crazy
right
that's gonna sound too crazy it sounds
like probably the fed is doing what it
can to
um the fed's primary job is to reduce
inflation and to curb unemployment
uh which is funny because trump always
takes credit for low black unemployment
even though that's squarely in the job
of the federal reserve which has no
oversight from the president
but the federal reserve probably sees
that we are spiking unemployment
as long as we're not raising in
inflation which we haven't been their
goal would probably be some form of qe
quantitative easing or
super low interest rates whatever so
yeah that makes sense i think
first of all i'd say i agree with you on
a lot of these things and also
if if you if your perspective is
the lockdowns are strictly because of we
have this pandemic
that's an opinion i guess you know you
can you'll argue that you're correct
i think when you look at certain
jurisdictions and you look at the world
health organization saying it's a very
very last resort it should be avoided
and it can be
and they do it anyway it sounds to me
like well
they've said it they want to exploit
covet 19 it's their opportunity
to enact this policy and they they
didn't say it was because of covenant 19
they said it was because of climate
change
so do you know should i just disregard
the world health organization's
warning about lockdown i don't know
among major countries because i know
there are some smallers but among every
country we're 11th right now and per
capita death and we lead the world in
an absolute death i don't know what last
resort sounds like to you but that
sounds like we're pretty close to like
last resort there
but so the people who like this is the
big challenge
our economy is is what do we drop like
30 percent or like 30 something percent
this year
potentially yeah people are we're facing
mass evictions
massive unemployment yep the reason i
pointed out the printing of money is
that that is absolutely not a solution
in any capacity
it's a it's a desperate last resort
where they're just like
money printer gober desperately trying
to keep the machine churning in some
capacity
but if people ultimately stop doing
things that give them the money value
then ultimately we just we're headed
towards some kind of really serious
economic collapse especially
with so if something i'm not going to
disagree with you here and
we talked a little bit about the
software the problem is is that right
now we have the worst of both worlds
and that we are doing half-assed
lockdowns that are locking down just
enough to absolutely destroy
small businesses and and and average
workers but we're not locking down
enough to prevent the spread of the
disease so what we're getting is the
disease is spreading almost uninhibited
it almost feels like it's uninhibited
i'm sure it has been to some extent and
then we're seeing all these businesses
closed down and
because we're doing it in such a in such
a laxative manner
like nothing is actually moving in a
positive direction we haven't eliminated
the virus on any part of the u.s we're
still in like
that map this isn't like purple
spreading in almost every i think in
every single state
and then people are suffering severe
economic harm as well right now whatever
we're doing
i like if you were to ask me like well
should we just not lock down anything
whatever if it was between
just doing no lockdowns and doing what
we're doing now i might even say like
okay yeah
like whatever i think that's i think
that's it actually sure the the
guy at the restaurant that i mentioned
in michigan he straight up said if the
government gave me enough money to to
keep everything moving
i'd happily walk away for two months
yeah for sure i think it really just
comes down to
if we're gonna shut down businesses we
have to support them through the
shutdown you can't just
expect people to stay home and have you
know you know we don't expect american
airlines or walmart or any other massive
corporation have six months of savings
um and these people are doing revenue in
the 9 10 11 digits like
why do you expect you know frank that
owns a bar down the street you know like
small business owners aren't making
tens of millions of dollars a year off
of their business you know these people
aren't going to have the savings to
get through six months of not operating
their business it's a tough problem
um i think you have a lot of people on
the right saying protect the vulnerable
social distance wear masks but reopen
things
and then many on the left i suppose you
know in your instance
lock everything down hard but cover the
cost to make sure people make it through
this
well the thing that sucks is it feels
like and this has been
i'm gonna i so look forward i've i wanna
feel like this argument is never gonna
come back again but i know it will
undervide him
republicans always cry about deficit
spending but for some reason when their
deficit spending for their pet projects
it seems like it's okay
i don't understand why we got trillions
of dollars of tax cuts from trump that
he celebrated about it
you know growing the economy which
congratulations every time you have the
death don't tax yeah
and massive debt he campaigned biggest
budget deficits under trump of all time
some of the biggest budget your deficits
of all time
and i think the thing that leaves people
frustrated is it's like i don't
understand why you can't help
us why can't you give us money if you
are spending so much on the war machine
which was supposed to go away
or on you know large businesses tax cuts
and everything like
seriously that's the frustrating part
trump campaigned against the deficit and
the debt
and and here we are and there was there
was an interview with ted cruz where he
was like you know
well trump didn't campaign against that
they're like he did he did explicitly
yeah i think that's an
indication of like you know political
parties
will say one thing but as soon as they
get power you know what i mean like
everybody wants free speech when they're
in the minority position and then once
they're in the dominant position they're
like no no we gotta we gotta clamp
things down maybe you want
i mean yeah i mean a man carrying over
400 400 million dollars of personally
guaranteed debt probably isn't gonna be
the best person to responsibly manage a
country's budget either but
yeah but see that's that that's a
framing thing you're right there right
yes so it's a framing i'm framing that a
man that has a massive amount of
personal debt that he's personally
guaranteed that's
what his assets probably enough to cover
it but probably not another 3.2 billion
but i i think there was a it was either
wall street journal uh one that went
over that yeah
but anytime you're having to start to
sell off things that you own to cover
that you bring together it's probably
not a good feeling you can do it yeah
yeah uh forbes i think put trump at 3.2
billion with with liabilities of like
400 million something like that yeah so
yeah
you know i don't want to i don't want to
go off on a news thing sure yeah it
doesn't
i it's frustrating to center back it's
frustrating to
me and a lot of other people um on the
left and i imagine on the right as well
that constantly hear about how we can't
just spend all this money on
you but right could do massive tax cuts
and we could spend a lot of money on
overseas wars and that just seems
very wrong yup yeah man the war you
get me going on the war thing absolutely
spending money doing nation building in
foreign countries when we could be
fixing the pipes in flint and helping
people in this country that's the
interesting thing i think you know
ultimately what it comes down to with
the lockdown debate is i think if we
work out all of those issues what's left
is
will the two-month mass printing of
money have a serious detrimental effect
on the economy the savings
and the uh you know retirements of
american people
will it be a bad thing for them you know
or
if we that's basically it right so
conservatives would say we can't just
print money we can't just do that we
can't just lock everything down and
freeze it
especially at this point considering
it's been a year now when businesses
have been destroyed
and i guess the leftist position is you
can and you have to
um yeah i guess it monetary policies are
very complicated um i know that there's
always the uh
inflation boogeyman that is looming
behind every politically expedient
argument but it seems like we haven't
seen that massive uninflation yet
we've been running historically low uh
federal funds rates for long times now
it just isn't there i know that
there's at least five libertarians right
now in chat screaming that we need to go
back to the gold standard and we're
printing money in a different bed
do you see that that trump i think was
trump he tried to pointing a woman to
the federal reserve who wants to be on
the go wants to put us back on the gold
standard that's
very funny um i thought it was hilarious
yeah but absolutely delusional
um but yeah no i mean um we need to get
ron paul in here you can have an
argument about
what's delusional about the oh oh wait
are you asking me or would ron paul ask
me that no no no like ron paul would
clearly be like you're right you're
crazy
of course yeah man i was a huge run paul
supporter when i was back in college
really yeah
what the heck so so let's let's let's do
this let's we'll uh
look man i think i think we agree that
we we have to go one way or the other
we're sitting on the fence
we either need to jump into the we're
gonna lock down for two months
everybody's getting some kind of handout
or we need to go into like okay we're
gonna severely lax all the lockdown
stuff and we're just gonna see who dies
but like we have to keep people's lives
running
because there is damage uh there is
collateral damage to a lockdown that
people are suicidal accept more even
more so this is
not having your business not being able
to write anything mental health issues
like yeah actually yeah there's a really
well-known twitch streamer that killed
himself
most likely because of the lockdowns um
a friend of mine that traveled a ton and
that was like his way of getting out i
know there are a lot of people like that
maybe that not necessarily kill
themselves but like severely like
negatively impacted in terms of mental
health related to that so yeah wow man
i've heard a lot of stories there was a
there's this dude that i know
his son committed suicide he was
tweeting about it and said
having having a young kid who's locked
up and
with or even with with resources guys
wealthy dude that's just it destroys
their mind
you know not to mention that like i
can't imagine my so i'm very like i have
a nine-year-old son um
because of how they because he lives in
a wealthy school district because i'm
wealthy
um they have long distance learning with
like ipads and stuff
and even for them even for that
technologically very literate school
district
i get the emails every day i don't know
if other parents have this issue it's
like hey guys if you got logged out of
the ipads you know like this is how you
get back in or like it just seems to be
like such a nightmare for everybody
i can't imagine the poorest schools that
can afford that type of technology that
i don't i don't know what those people
are
out of school for like a year some
people didn't get to have their senior
prom some people didn't get to do their
graduation
like i would have cheered for all that
i'm you know i when i was when i was
younger i would have as well
very naughty establishment well i just
want to say i'm gonna play video games
but most people probably wanted to see
their friends and socialize and do stuff
yeah yep
well so that's a good argument why there
shouldn't be luck tones for the sake of
mental health and everyone and
actually or a good argument for why we
should have had very strict lockdowns
for two months and then maybe
started to do like much more control
reopenings like then in australia new
zealand or south korea
so then the problem isn't so much a
conspiracy as it is two factions
fighting and getting a half-assed
response instead of one solid response
to either
the problem is that literally every
single thing in the united states is so
unbelievably politicized that you can't
do
anything without somebody looking at you
like you have a political agenda behind
it and part of the reason is because of
stuff like
talking about the great reset like that
on its face if you were to say like
hey if you are doing like a massive
restructuring do you think you should
take that opportunity to optimize like
part of your workflow
every reasonable person you're like yeah
probably yeah but like when it's phrased
and that like
do you think that people are pushing for
extra coronavirus lockdowns just so they
can shove aoc into every person's home
forcing you to get on your knees and
worship the green new deals like
well okay like i feel like the framing
of that is a little bit disingenuous and
it further serves like that hardcore
hyper partisan politicization
of american politics the world economic
forum put out a video that said in 2030
you will own nothing and you will be
happy
so when they say the world economic
forum do you mean like one person who
works in one subsection that does
youtube videos published it
it was published on all social platforms
they wrote they were a big long article
about it
and then they later clarified when there
was a backlash that it wasn't intended
to say this is what we want to happen
but what we think
may happen so the issue the issue is if
you if you
launch a campaign around this you
include within it
like critical theory intersectionality
and stuff and then you say you will own
nothing and you will be happy
and then people like trudeau who say
we're going to have a reset people like
john kerry
are advocating for locking everything
down which is destroying ownership sure
it's like people yeah not that it's a
grand conspiracy where they all got
together and said we want to destroy
ownership
but that they think it's a good thing
they like it they've advocated for it
and now the policies they're bringing
about are bringing about what they want
sure so you can argue yeah i understand
the problem is that like
i can't argue against a story i can only
argue against particular policies
um so like if we are concocting this
grand narrative behind the schemes that
we're trying to get rid of ownership of
everything and blah blah blah
and like this like well i mean like we
have like a bunch of discrete facts and
we could connect them in that way if we
want to but i don't know if that's the
most perfect way to do it
and even on its face um i i could even
defend that statement on its face that
actually a lot of people are in support
of that that you will own nothing and be
happy
so as a gamer um something that's been
very interesting to me is most people
today
use things like steam as a platform you
don't own any of the i don't know if
you're familiar with steam course yeah
absolutely you don't own any of those
right if valve goes bankrupt you've lost
everything
sure but but the convenience that it
provides is you know on another level
and that's why people like it or you
don't own any of your music you listen
to it on spotify you listen to it on
itunes we don't have the
um the vinyls we don't have the cds we
don't have any of that anymore so like
i'm not now i'm not defending the idea
that we should own nothing okay i'm an
ardent capitalist i like owning things
um i for i have all of my music is
backed up on flak files on my hard
drives that i keep it up because i like
that
however i don't think that these ideas
are necessarily as crazy as we make them
out to be because we give the least
charitable reading of it and then run
with the biggest conspiracy behind it
instead of like what's like a more
nuanced like approach in the middle for
like what do they probably mean
what are the goods and pro what are the
pros and cons and like how can we you
know work with this i guess
i think i think conspiracy implies that
it's a secret of some sort
we'll just call it yeah that's not for
me to say sure when i say conspiracy
the plan sure yeah i understand when i
say conspiracy i don't mean like a crazy
you know lunatic when i say conspiracy i
mean like a planned thing that multiple
people are working on to bring about
some kind of change it's like a
conspiracy
um but it just has a very negative
connotation so i understand yeah yeah
there's a group of people they have
international interests they think we
should use the
coveted lockdown to reset global
capitalism
and then there's people who don't trust
the policies they're putting out when
the world health organization themselves
i have the quote
sure let's see if i can uh full
lockdowns should be a very very last
resort and can
be avoided world health organizations
europe chief says so this was in october
that when when when you see the story
and it was it was basically carried over
i'm using cnbc
people are wondering why then they're
pushing for all these lockdowns i don't
know we i don't think they've even
pushed for full lockdowns anywhere in
the us have we uh no
we haven't so we haven't even done a
full location what do you mean by full
lockdown well
what do they mean by full lockdown i
imagine that the who probably doesn't
mean when they say like full lockdown
i doubt they mean like outdoor seating
at all hours of the day at most
restaurants
yeah when they say full lockdown they're
probably saying like closed because i've
been in california for a couple years
now i don't think we've full locked down
anything you can go to any questions a
couple years but over the past years
like you can still go out to restaurants
you're just outdoor seating or you're
sitting in every other place
california says don't leave your home
past 10 o'clock i think just recently
they did that i think newsom said on
monday i think they just said like no
more gatherings of 10 or more people
yeah but this is the i think this is the
first time california's went this far
but even at that i'm pretty sure
restaurants are still open like i
literally ordered din tai fung like the
day before we we left like we we went to
the uh restaurant and picked it up
there's still people eating out there
and everything so
it's interesting too yeah because well
it's the constitution there's only so
much they can do to enforce this stuff
you look at europe and they had
they had this video go viral of a woman
who brought her mom to uh
a mental health facility and they
detained her taste her
she's screaming and then naturally
people are like this is messed up
i mean actually you made it sound like
you disagreed with australia and new
zealand's approach to things because
australia's been super draconian
i don't necessarily disagree um i just i
wish that we had a more
three-dimensional view of what it means
to have the right to do something
because the way that when i grew up the
way that i was taught is that when you
get more rights being an adult is
awesome but there
is more responsibility that comes along
with that there's no you're never given
a right to do something
that doesn't carry a greater burden of
responsibility behind it like that's
always the case
um and a lot of the times when i talk
it's so weird when republicans talk
about rights
usually they're talking about
restricting rights i notice that anytime
a republican talks about states rights
what they're actually talking about is
taking rights away from you
they want to like curb like abortion um
or they want to restrict access to like
funding for like planned parenthood
they usually or they want to make it
harder to vote for whatever reason voter
id or if you don't agree with that make
it harder whatever but it feels like
when people talk about like states
rights
um what they they uh or make it illegal
for like gay people to get right they're
talking about like taking rights away
from people which is
old examples well now they are because
the supreme court
said but i mean there was that famous um
who was the woman that uh mike huckabee
supported
who was saying like i'm not gonna marry
you know these gay people even if they
wouldn't work
yeah yeah yeah so these are thankfully
some of these are older examples sure
um but even with even regarding things
like um uh like uh what do you call the
city sanctuary cities right people like
the states shouldn't have the right to
do that we need to take this back or we
need to like
it it feels a lot a lot of the times
like when people talk about states
rights
it feels like they're actually talking
about taking rights away from people
which is it's only a couple of examples
where just security
well like i mean what is security about
the restriction of a right in exchange
for what's the quote like
somebody that demands uh security in
exchange for their freedom will get and
deserve neither
well we'll get night we'll lose we'll
we'll get neither and lose both yeah
sure
well so but the argument it really is
yeah it comes down to uh
freedom versus security and at a certain
point you do need security
it's just a question of where the
balance is right for sure so it's crazy
to me that like people will look at like
illegal immigrants and be like we need
to we need to ship 13 million people out
of here because a few people every year
get killed by
ms-13 or we need to get them all out of
here and then we look at like
3 000 people a day dying from the
coronavirus
and it's like well do we really need the
weather they're very very different
they're very different the issue of
illegal immigration has a lot to do with
the economy as well
just way more than just it has to do
with the the security of uh
of our elections the security of our
physical you know safety
and it has to do with the uh jobs market
so elections physical safety and jobs
market the
is hardcore affecting all of those right
but the election and all the millions
you can't
you can't deport the chronovirus and so
the conservatives tend to say
we should protect the vulnerable we
should have social distancing wear masks
and we can keep the economy running and
schools seem to be safe
and then the left senses say tends to
say lock it all down provide stimulus
and and support
so i i i hear what you're saying you
know early on because we'd go through
this already
like i guess the thing that makes me sad
is that like i grew up my so half my
family's cuban my mom
and dad were both air force they're ride
or die for trump
at like to the end of the earth um and
my mom is an incredibly
nationalistic very proud american loves
this country would would
if the air force called her back in
today she would you know strap up in her
little flight suit and go and fly to
wherever they want
i know she would um and it hurts when i
grew up hearing about all these amazing
things that america was capable of that
america had accomplished um and we did
the silent generation world war two i
thought we did a lot of amazing stuff
and then when it comes to controlling a
coronavirus
individually we can't take
responsibilities we can't just wear a
mask and stay away from people
apparently that's really controversial
we sucked at getting testing out because
trump didn't take it seriously he didn't
push for anywhere near as much as he
showed up
we weren't able to enact any of the
other measures that other countries that
was a complicated point though but
we'll come back i don't believe it was
complicated i understand that we can say
that like well some tests are put out
and they failed
i think that in the united states
regardless of what some people say i
think that this country possesses the
greatest technological innovation in the
world if we wanted to get tests out and
if the political
will was behind it we would have had
that out way earlier because south korea
had the same
first a reported case as us and they
have like i think they have like 240
deaths from the coronavirus why couldn't
that have been us in south korea's
this entire little like a like a metric
that's why it's easier for them
that's harder no no new york i was
wondering why new york city got so
crucial
tightly packed together everybody's in
all the international travel and
everything look how many different
states with different jurisdictions with
different governors
all protected by the 10th amendment
trump can only do so much
and when you have new york uh city
having their their health actors come
down and say everything's fine go
outside
you have people in california nancy
pelosi doing the same thing
there's an argument of who took things
more seriously than and who didn't but
ultimately what it comes down to is
trump doesn't have uh
vosh argued trump should use constitute
the constitutional war powers to just
assume control and then force things so
firstly
that would be insane and imagine if
trump would be using
like executive powers in times of
national security to do insane stuff
like
tariffing china we're sending troops
down to build the wall
i mean he's already done this these
weren't even national emergencies
no i'm not in favor of trump it's well
it's yeah because he shouldn't have done
it there but you could make an argument
that he might do it here maybe he should
if there was ever an argument to
exercise these powers he would probably
be in protecting like
a 911s were the people dying every
single day in the united states i don't
know if like tariffing china is the same
level of national security
and that's why it's not a big deal what
do you mean well trump putting a tariff
on china people say for the most part
like okay we'll see how that plays out
well no
a lot of people were very upset because
he did this unilaterally any any
exercise executive branch powers to do
it under like threat of like war or
whatever like which is a little bit
insane so i'm just saying i don't agree
with washi's argument
uh but like if you're going to argue in
favor of trump abusing the executive
like he has so far
it seems strange to make the argument
that he shouldn't do it here has he
abused the executive
i think that saying that we need to go
the the border wall to the south is some
like
horrible national emergency that he
needs to send people down to like build
part of his wall or whatever or saying
that we need to
have a national emergency tariff i think
that's very strange i think that's an
abuse of power
and then more importantly back to what
you said before trump can only do so
much trump actually can do
so much because he is so unbelievably
popular in the republican party
trump still has like a well like a 93 94
percent approval rating
if trump went around yeah if trump went
around and told the governors listen up
guys
we're gonna close down for a couple
months because it's your patriotic duty
blah blah blah you better believe that
any republican governor or anybody
that's in any plus trump district is
going to be in lockstep behind them
because they don't want to lose
re-elections
in terms of securing the border that is
the power bestowed upon the president
if he's going to say the united states
government we need to protect our
borders we do if he's going to do
trade negotiations it's something order
policy and border legislation though
that's clearly in the realm of like
congressional authority this is stuff
that should be passed through
congress this went through a series of
checks and balances congress fought with
trump they refused to give him the
budget he wants
the supreme court sided with trump
exactly he does have very broad powers
but like spiritually speaking right i
don't think we would want biden or obama
to come in
and say like oh well i'm going to open
all the borders because i think it's
good for national security right
i personally i would say like this feels
like something that should probably go
through congress you know
i didn't like daca under obama not
because i didn't like the policy
but because it's like okay well we can't
get anything done through congress so
now we're going to like
kind of broaden our executive powers and
write immigration and we see how
horrible that is because anything that
can be done
via executive action can be undone via
executive action they can't
trump tried to undo it the supreme court
said no well i think um
so technically it's true but weren't
there parts of daca that i think were
rescinded i
i don't know if that's still being
fought in an ongoing manner but i know
that they they basically shot them down
on several
instances complicated things go back and
forth um but um
yeah like executive order is just a
really bad there are parts of our
government that people complain about so
the supreme court is one of them and the
executive is one of them and they say
that the power has expanded so much in
these areas but i think the reason why
it appears
just because congress has been so unable
to do anything that that's the only
place that we can get any meaningful
action out of so let's talk about uh
biden and trump then we'll expand upon
this
you're you're super excited for biden uh
yes
oh yeah why um for every so
one i think that we will finally
hopefully have some
cohesive idea of how we're supposed to
deal with the coronavirus as a country
from somebody that is not
insane when it comes to talking about
virus-related stuff
so no weird stuff about bleach or uv
lights no pushing weird medications like
hydroxychloroquine that he didn't take
when he was sick
no he was reported that he took it uh no
he said he took it as a problem oh
right before he got sick when he
actually got sick he got the good stuff
he didn't get that weird stuff that he
was selling all the suckers on tv that
worship and support him uh well but
hydroxyl
hydroxychloroquine has been used for
decades it is considered not for covet
19. for sure for sure
so there were preliminary studies this
is the craziest thing about the news
cycle and how they deal with trump
there was actually tech crunch and
several uh european outlets that
reported
a promising study showing
hydroxychloroquine azithromycin
you know with zinc in combination with
showing uh that the severity was
reducing
they actually replicated this in other
studies trump comes out and just starts
repeating it and then also the media
flipped on it
so we've installed we even saw lefties
write about this saying
it is the weirdest thing the moment
trump says something about a news report
the media changes the narratives it's a
bad thing because the problem is it's
not trump's job to be saying these
things if a random techcrunch article
wants to come out and say hey there was
some retrospective analysis done
on hydroxychloric when and antibiotics
like a cytomycin no no no it was
literally a study on covid
and they found that the severity was
dramatically all of the prospective
studies done on hydroxychloroquine have
shown that it is
nothing it does not help with the
serrated disease there have been some
retrospectives that when compared
against different standards of care like
maybe
but the reason why i became popular
initially was because that scientists in
um france the doctor uh
raoul came out with his like n equals 12
study that i think he dropped one person
from that died and after like one
weekend he was like hey we published the
results
and then like that was it there was
there was a ton of past research that
said for coronavirus
and and for like czars coveted one
hedgehog chloroquine was effective in
reducing severity
sure this probably led the scientists to
say let's try it out which is fine
covered two good there were promising
results early on
but as soon as trump said it the media
went nuts that's the crazy thing trump's
because trump doesn't like him
and it's not his job so here's part of
the problem when trump comes out and
says it
when trump comes out and says something
that hasn't been thoroughly vetted by
the medical community and isn't
recommended by somebody who would be
more in line to recommend that like say
somebody like fauci
right when trump comes out and says it
it changes the worldwide discourse
when it comes to these drugs so there
was a really good article published in
nature about some research scientists
that complained
about how hard it was when they were
trying to run trials on other drugs so
dexamethasone and rendezvous or other
drugs
nobody wants to be in the loser trials
everybody wants to be in the hydroxyl
that's what trump was talking about what
nobody wants to risk being in the dummy
trial for some
loser drug when trump is on tv talking
about how he's taking hydroxyl going
every day
like it's not his job to do that he's
absolutely responsible for him
on tv talking about that i disagree i
mean he's going to talk about what he
says in the news
i'm not going to blame him is he like a
muppet he sees something and he says
something this is like the most powerful
man in the world i think that we can be
a little bit everybody
trump is not everybody trump is the
president of the united states
and and he did he gave a speech where he
said we're doing a great job
we're seeing some promising studies out
of france there's a hydroxychloroquine
that they're talking about
should he not tell people that we're
making developments and there's some
promising
you know medications the problem is that
even if i was to grant you that it
stands in stark contrast to the reasons
why he gave for never talking about the
coronavirus initially
right like he's saying that like oh well
he kept all this stuff secret because i
don't want to start a panel
but now he's out here talking about all
these potential miracle drugs and
everything like
i i just i think that he's very
irresponsible like i even get nervous
talking about like certain medications
on my stream because i don't want people
to run out
and i know i have that power and i'm not
the president of the united states right
i always just say
ask your doctor doctor knows best for
you which is great and if trump said
that you're like hey there are drugs out
there that might be trying to talk to a
doctor but that's not what he was saying
he was talking about oh we got
hydroxychlorogen this great new miracle
drug and i think it's going to be the
next
do you remember who are you do you
remember what the white house said on
school closures
the science is on our side and anderson
cooper i think had something effective
he just
doesn't care about your children at all
i think jennifer rubin said he wants
your kids to die or something like that
this was actually what kelly mcinerney
brought up in a press reference mind you
that's one
so i i remember that narrative when
trump uh and and
the white house came out and said
schools should stay open
well now we're finding out that even
fauci is saying yep but so much later
that we've caused irreparable damage
to many people's lives and families and
there's been suicides
when trump was actually right the whole
time too was that irresponsible when
they said that
people can say different people can say
the same thing for very different
reasons
like it's very obvious that trump is
pushing to open schools because he's
desperate to get back to some level of
normalcy for the election because
whether you agree or disagree with trump
this election to a large extent was
probably a referendum on how he dealt
with the coronavirus
and getting people back in schools and
getting people working because a lot of
people don't know this
um schools are can be two very important
things for families one it's how your
kid can eat sometimes depending on how
poor you are and two
um it lets mom and dad go and work they
care because yeah you know because
daycare is unbelievably expensive oh my
goodness
so public schools allows yeah the
economy to keep moving yeah but the
problem is is that when you're pushing
for things on only a political basis
and it doesn't seem like you're laying
out like good comprehensive plans
for like um so for instance like fouchy
and um i think he was even on the white
house setup site
have like these plans for like slowly
reopening based on the number of
reported cases daily averages moving
blah blah blah like if that was the type
of thing that was being said
then i could have been more empathetic i
was like okay cool it seems like trump
just wants to reopen things in a
responsible way but instead it's like
we got to open all the schools you gotta
get them back we gotta get back to
normal it was like probably not like the
most science-driven
answer he was given i mean it's an it's
an opinion
the people who like trump are gonna say
trump cares about me and he's fighting
for my family the people who don't are
gonna say he only cares about this why
didn't trump pressure
mcconnell to release any stimulus if he
cares about our family so much
maybe he doesn't think stimulus is the
right way to help families and he
thought that
it would be devastating to the economy
to just print money and the best way to
do it was to release the lockdowns which
is what
i thought it wasn't devastating to the
economy to just cut taxes for like all
the wealthy businesses or
to authorize the ppp loans that was good
for the economy
like like people think that the heroes
are the wrong story you know i
understand
it's strange that he thought that these
were such positive measures but he
couldn't pressure mcconnell to release
any kind of stimulus to the average
american person
i think he said that the stimulus will
be the vaccine and we need to reopen
because people should be working
so it's just there's i don't think
there's mustache twirling
villainy i think i don't think that's my
stature i think it's just selfish and
stupid
but the problem is we are months and
months into this and we got no
other stimulus he is our leader where
was it how do you feel about fauci
saying
early on that he was doing the best
possible that no one could do better
every time somebody contradicts trump
they get immediately fired
look at the um i think it was the cyber
security head of the dhs that came out
and said well this election was actually
pretty secure and trump
instantly fired him so it's not
surprising to me that fouchy man that's
been working in government for what like
30 or 40 years or something that he came
out he's like oh yeah i think trump
he's been defining him for months he has
been defying a bit that's there's a very
careful line you have to skirt if you've
ever worked a corporate job and you've
got an
idiot manager you know like you don't go
out and say like why are you doing this
it's stupid it's more like
maybe i kind of i think you're doing a
great i could [ __ ] sure yeah well if
you don't want to get fired it's more
like you're doing an amazing job
i think we could do a little bit better
here right so you think you think fauci
lied to the american people to save his
own job
i think that fauci was saying things in
the most diplomatic manner possible
because he wanted to serve the american
people and i get immediately fired by
trump
which he would saying trump did the best
possible job and no one could do better
is a big difference from
we're trying as hard as we can i don't
know if he said no one could do better i
would be better i'd be curious the exact
quote is but even so i don't think
that's very relevant to policy going
forward whether or not fauci says that
trump did a good or bad job i don't know
if it's fauci's job in government
to be second guessing the president in
his past decisions
it's a faulty's job to give us the best
leadership going forward and i know that
there have been times where fauci and
you just said it right has been at ends
with the president and him
like promoting certain drugs or him
talking about certain things whether the
chronovirus professional i disagree here
or whatever
and even i'm pretty sure there were a
few months where we didn't see fouche
anymore because of his like behind the
scenes fighting with trump
but yeah i don't think they're just
saying well fouchy said trump is doing a
good job like wow you think
like trump the guy that fires literally
every single person in government that's
not immediately agreeing with them like
it doesn't surprise me that he was like
a little bit careful when he would
publicly address trump so on that note
the cyber security guy that trump just
fired would it not have been in his best
interest to say this was the most secure
election we've ever had
that's literally him saying i did a good
job don't fire me
um but it's that type of thing is it's
very hard
um so like there's like two schools of
thought in terms like how to change a
system
do you go full renegade and say this
sucks this is over
fire me i don't care or do you kind of
like suck it up
work from the inside you know like okay
well sure this sucks but like if
as long as i like keep my you know mouth
shut i can actually enact change on the
inside
like um when the dhs guy came out and
said what he said i think that he
probably felt an obligation to the
american people to let them know the
government doesn't stand behind trump
and his like
election fraud claims so i feel like
that doesn't surprise you so
so i'll read a little bit he said
without you said
we've never had a threat like this and
the coordinated response has been
there are a number of adjectives to
describe it impressive i think is one of
them
i mean we're talking about all hands on
deck is that i as one of many people in
the team
i'm not the only person since the
beginning that we've recognized what
this was
i have been devoting almost almost full
time on this almost all
almost full time i'm down at the white
house virtually every day with a task
force i'm connected by phone throughout
the day
and into the night and when i say night
i'm talking 12 1 2
in the morning not just one so i can't
imagine that under any circumstance that
anybody could be doing more i mean
obviously we're fighting a formidable
enemy
this virus this virus is a serious issue
here take a look at what's under china
and you know yeah
yeah he he goes into really long i don't
want to read the full uh
it's a really long paragraph sure it
just sounds like he's like as the as
who's kind of become the face of this
virus he's like championing yeah we're
doing everything we can the government
which is kind of what i would expect
them to do is to be like a cheerleader
for the government i don't want to come
out and like
these guys suck are coordinated federal
responsible but non-existent
trump is a horrible leader like i don't
think that would be his job and he'll
probably send a bad message to the
american people as well
if you know the critic criticism of
trump is that he
was downplaying this early on to avoid a
panic and that was a bad thing
then isn't there responsibility on
fouchy the problem with tru
if you want to say that you're
downplaying something to avoid panic
that's fine but the problem was is that
while he was downplaying it there
weren't steps being taken behind the
scenes to prepare us for what was coming
it seemed less like downplaying it to
avoid a panic and more pretending it
didn't exist and hope didn't come to
american shores
because there's a darren's been publicly
saying like okay guys listen i don't
think this is going to be a big deal
and then behind the scenes you're like
okay listen we need to get testing on
board we need to make sure that we have
some form of contact tracing we need to
like communicate with governors make
sure we
like there would be that but instead it
was just like well look we locked down
travel from china lol
and then in a month and a half we did
nothing oh what would look we locked
down travel from uh
um from europe lol and like that's it
like i i don't think that he was just
trying to avoid a panic because there
was nothing going on behind the scenes
in that gap of the china and european
travel ban to show that he was taking it
seriously it seemed he just didn't think
it was a real thing
let's talk about biden sure what do you
uh what do you like about button
um so one thing was the top down um
hopefully some
sort of top-down level uh response we
get for related to the coronavirus
um that respects rulings and everything
i know i don't know if we've talked
about it yet on air but the
supreme court decided yeah religious
freedoms which is probably fine i can
understand that really from the supreme
court
um i would hope that churches would
individually say like okay well maybe
we'll you know suspend sessions but i
can understand that um but some top-down
coordinated response from
um the government really the coronavirus
um number two
and three are close gonna be intertwined
is gonna be like the economy broadly and
healthcare broadly
um i'm very interested to see what sort
of economic policies
we're going to see from biden especially
in regards to his strong support of
unions
and especially in regards to i don't
personally like the policy but pushing
for 15 an hour minimum wage i'm very
curious to see like where that ends up
interesting bad news
why do you say that so he wants to
combine that with a high corporate tax
yes
that's bad and he's also been as part of
the obama administration very much in
favor of free trade agreements
i love free trade agreements well so you
know what the combination of those three
things will get you
corporations facing high wage costs and
high taxes will just move their their
factories and their their
businesses over well that's part of what
you have baked into any multilateral
trade agreement though is the idea that
um
so um nobody talks about this on the
right or the left one of the nice things
about free trade agreements or
multilateral trade agreements is that
obviously what you just said can happen
okay you um if you're gonna
make it so that i can export my supply
chain to a place like vietnam well
i'm just going to make all my stuff over
there because i can pay those workers
way less however generally as part of
negotiating these free trade agreements
you usually demand
some sorry some labor standards um on
the uh
side of other countries in order to
bring them onto a more level playing
field so that you're not exporting um
all of those jobs so two really good
examples of this is one is that the um
uh i can't remember the united states
mexico um usmca yeah
usmca the united states mexico
agreement yeah um so part of this
agreement that trump champions all the
time was um
i think they demanded like uh an
increase in wages for mexican workers
that worked in certain factories
to to try to dissuade people from
exporting too many jobs over there
and then another good example is part of
the negotiations for the trans-pacific
partnership
uh obviously dead now but part of those
were historic labor reforms in vietnam
that would have bolstered a lot of the
labor rights in that country and a lot
of those just completely went away
as a result of the tpp negotiations
falling through it's good good for
vietnam that's not good for american
workers
um well if you force them to pay their
workers more it is good for american
workers because
the increased liberalization of trade
means we have another trading partner
that we can buy and sell stuff from but
the fact you have to pay their workers
more means we're not just shipping all
of those jobs overseas because they
still have some minimum level of wages
that they have to pay to discourage that
there there may be those negotiations on
labor rights but
the cost is still remarkably cheaper to
have our factories all throughout
southeast asia than here in the united
states and we've
we've seen that we've seen the fact that
we don't produce our own medicine
anymore sure
i mean this this is one of those like
insanely multifaceted things that i
agree with you in practice it becomes a
lot easier to spread
supply chains throughout the world
because it's cheaper in certain areas to
manufacture it that's not always a bad
thing
but it's also a thing that we could
combat if we would have more honest
conversations about
like what is a multilateral free trade
agreement supposed to accomplish so for
instance the paris climate accords
so very common criticism that nobody on
the left talks about um is that these
things seem to give a lot of low weight
to developing nations
like why would i join any type of uh
pollution you know restriction thing
that's going to let china and india
compete uninhibited with now my shackled
economy they can't pollute
like this is insane um so like but but
the only way
that we can address those types of
concerns have to come through
multilateral trade agreements that's it
there's no other way to do it china is
way too big as a country
a few tariffs or a couple sanctions
aren't going to do anything to them they
have access to the rest of the world
market um you have to get together with
a bunch of countries to set these
standards it didn't it didn't work
we we thought that these are the the
trade with china
was going to normalize china and make
them freer and better and they went the
other direction
well so there this has been something
i've heard about this since the 90s
this has always been like the china
conspiracy people are always saying i
say people are always saying that like
when china when the middle class booms
when they increase their trade like
they're going to become more liberal the
people are going to demand political
freedoms
doesn't seem to have happened but i
don't think we necessarily need those
things to happen i think we can
acknowledge that china exists as this
kind of like
you know authoritarian behemoth that is
going to do what it's going to do but
the only way that we can accurately deal
with that
is to partner with other countries in
order to enforce like the kinds of
restrictions that we want on them we
can't do it on our own
like we've seen trump try to do it with
terrorists doesn't really work that well
he keeps saying over and over again we
brought them to the table but like not
really
the big things that we were pushing for
related to like intellectual property
rights i think we didn't see any
progress there whatsoever china
continues its belt road initiative all
throughout europe and asia and
everything like it's
either either there i think there's two
outcomes in this
this this china uh issue full-scale
warfare
or capitulation okay how i'm gonna
suggest kindly a third option what if
instead of every single time something
bad happens in the world and we all hide
from each other and get scared and
locked down
what if we continue to reach out be the
world leader that we used to be
in the whole nato world and everything
where we tell other countries like hey
let's all work together on this common
idea and then we pressure china that way
couldn't that be like a better way to do
things
but hasn't that been exactly what
they've been trying to do that's not
been working
well i mean there have been a few key
events especially recently that have
kind of pushed people into
a a lot more kind of a scary area where
they're worried about working people so
the 2013 syrian refugee crisis for
instance
caused a whole wave of governments in
europe to
have thanks obama um to some extent yeah
um although bush got us largely involved
with the middle east but syria was obama
yeah all of it oh it's complicated
uh well i'm sorry you're right it was a
cia no
that's too communist uh no no i mean
like the existence of like
the existence of like isis that exists
in syria and gains power in syria like
like a lot of that came from the
destabilization that started in iraq and
a lot of that came from
you know bush that got us into iraq i'm
not saying that obama has absolved this
i think that obama could have done a
better job foreign policy ways but it's
hard
it's very difficult and nobody has
gotten that right do you know do you
know about the qatar turkey pipeline
um i believe i've heard of this but talk
about it the reason why the u.s got
involved in syria well because the idea
was to get syria locked down so that
they could run that pipeline from from
yeah all through i've seriously heard
this from people yeah
but it's it's true 2009 um i think it
was
actually no maybe it was uh yeah 2009.
the guardian reported this that in 2009
u.s intelligence said we will have a
ground incursion in syria because they
have refused to give us access to build
the pipeline
saying that they would not go against
their ally russia
what russia and syria were then planning
on doing was using iran to tap the same
well and run that pipeline into europe
strengthening the russian gas monopoly
in europe so the u.s had had planned for
years before we actually ended up on the
ground
and then funneling weapons to rebel
groups
eventually built they eventually came
together and we got isis
that that is a story that one could tell
but i don't think that everything that
happened in syria was just a result of
the united states wanting to
like secure an area of that pipeline
that might have been like a nice side
objective that maybe could have come
about i know that the united states
probably wanted to see assad gone
and if that was gone it wouldn't
surprise me if we wanted somebody loyal
to america or american interest in there
and if that did happen let me
the guardian reported that in 2009 the
u.s wanted to be in syria
they needed an opportunity to do it when
the arab spring happened the united
states said now's our chance
provided weapons and resources to the
rebels eventually put u.s soldiers on
the ground
now we're involved in that and the same
look that's why you know getting into
the biden discussion about war and
conflict
bringing up the syrian refugee crisis
was a product of
yes bush totally and obama ramped things
up
um in regards to the syrian stuff yeah
for sure um in regards to
another reason why i say foreign policy
is complicated is like a lot of people
are critical about obama and the um
and all of the drone strikes and the
killings was it an american citizen i
think we killed in yemen
i think i think obama killed four
american citizens yeah i know there was
one that was like super ultra heated
16 16 year old in yemen yes yes obama
signed off on blowing up a civilian
restaurant in a country we aren't at war
with
and when they when they asked him why
did you kill why did you sign off on
killing the 16 year old
they said we were trying to target
somebody else a terrorist leader
oops when people followed up saying why
did you
authorize a drone strike on a civilian
restaurant in a country we aren't at war
with
it's just womp sure all those same drone
strikes and all those same bombings have
only increased under trump though
not in the past few years but yes
absolutely in the past few years no they
ran
they've actually been going down quite a
bit they might have gone down where they
started the administration but in the
four years we've had trump in his first
four years he has done more drone
strikes and more foreign bombing than
either obama or blackstone correct and
hiring bolton was the stupidest thing
the man because i don't have troops in
afghanistan we still have troops any
russia but he's trying to take him out
in syria what do you mean he's trying to
he's been trying to get rid of him for a
long time because did you know that
there was a white house there was a
federal official who lied about the
amount of troops we had in syria to
trick trump into keeping them there
and that when trump said he was ordering
the troops to withdraw from afghanistan
both democrats and republicans got
together and blocked him in congress
trump fired the pentagon civilian
leadership and this was reported by the
ap
in an effort to get loyalists who would
finally pull our troops out of these
countries
this is one of those things where i wish
i knew more information about it but i
am i
completely do not agree that that is
even remotely possible you are telling
me that the president of the united
states that was able to get the supreme
court to say well i can tariff china for
national security reasons couldn't
control where we were deploying or
withdrawing troops from
um that sounds unbelievable especially
unilaterally approving strikes on like
sulimani and like iraqi airports and
stuff
i know it's messed up stuff i find it
very hard to believe it wasn't
surprising if trump was using this as an
excuse
but i mean even if this was true like
you've got a guy that says he's a
business leader that's supposed to be on
top of handling all this stuff who like
one guy lies to him and now he has no
control over his military he's the
commander-in-chief it's literally the
primary job of the president they're
they're
they're there are a lot of people in
government who are doing everything in
their power to obstruct trump
most of them are trump appointees yeah i
know that's it's one of these trump's
hired a bunch of dumb people so
like one man
one point is it no longer the deep
state's fault when the deep state is 50
trump appointees maybe trump is just
highly incompetent look at the rulings
that we're getting right now on the
election fraud struck these
these are trump federal judiciary
appointees that are coming back and
saying like
listen man you are insane these
affidavits are crazy there's there's
there's no joke at this like there's no
i'm i can't believe the defense i'm
seeing for for what's going on in in in
these trump lawsuits
trump put out this 46 minute video and i
listened to it and i i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna mince words
trump did not present his case well they
i listen they talk through the same like
i think i it was a 46 minute on facebook
i think i watched the same video usually
there's talk through the same like seven
affidavits every single time
there's there's legitimate there's
there's way more affidavits
there's way more articulate individuals
presenting evidence and for some reason
the trump team is not bringing it
together well
maybe it's not as legitimate as some
alternative media suggests it might be
no i think i think the issue is when you
hear trump do a 46 minute video
and he can't actually calmly cite matt
brainard
and he points to a picture and says look
at that how does that make sense i'm
like
you're not giving me an articulate
breakdown of why the issue is why is it
that in
all of these federal cases where these
are being brought and the breaches are
actually
no the trump campaign has three oh maybe
the trump campaign personally
you can't you can't tell me that some
random people following a lawsuit is
reflected by trump
you can't tell me that an affidavit
alone is like valid evidence that like
something horrible has happened
it is testimony as evidence
well okay well in that case there's a 13
year old that has an affidavit out there
meaning they've signed it
penalty approach that trump raped her
that was retracted though sure
but a lot of these affidavits are also
under scrutiny as well
but i'm just saying that like just
because there's an affidavit doesn't
mean that this absolutely happened so
for instance sure when giuliani brought
the um
miss johnson what was the name of the
indian lady um that testified for so
long i don't know in front of michigan
um it was like johannes or johnson or
something uh but like she came and she
gave a lot of the exact same testimony
that had already been stricken down in
court
so for instance she talked about being
like the tfe voting center and she was
like the election officials told me not
to verify signatures and i don't know
why they were doing that
when the judge went through it he was
like well that's because that wasn't
your job they were verified but they've
got to let me answer your question what
what's the
what's the point of a of an observer
what is the point of an observer yeah
i i it super depends on on every
individual area i would imagine
so uh broadly speaking probably to
observe like to observe what
um the the matching of signatures on
ballots or whatever
so opening and closing although would
you agree with the judge who
shot down trump's this actual trump
lawsuit saying that so long as an
observer is somewhere in the building it
counts as legal
observation it probably depends on the
precedent set by previous by prior cases
doesn't that sound bad faith like what
sounds bad faith to me is that all of
this stuff was brought up after it was
shown that trump had lost the election
where were all of these complaints on
election night
like complaints that the that that
observers weren't allowed in
complaining about the dominion voting
systems they were they were all over
twitter they absolutely were not
yeah there were a few randoms let me
just cite chamberlain who was on the
ground walking going throughout philly's
a lawyer taking posting in photos and
videos
people were complaining about being
booted but you got to understand a lot
of these people aren't on social media
they don't know what to do it's not
about just being on social media because
part of the reasons why these federal
judges are throwing these cases out so
specifically regard to the indian lady
um because on election night none of
these people were actually complaining
it wasn't until
giuliani went around so listening to
affidavits days later or weeks later
asking people actually asking for asking
like yeah are you a witness do you have
evidence yes i do please come forward
that sounds like the normal thing you
have to do doesn't it sound a little bit
strange
imagine if the judge was
imagine if a judge said we're not going
to use this witness testimony because
the witness to the murder only came
forward a month later after cop found
him
that's that's ridiculous it was it was
more like all this widespread wrongdoing
was apparently being observed
nobody but they weren't why didn't they
go through any of the proper channels to
report any of this like what probably
you they did i think they just don't
know this like matt brainerd
specifically said he gave his
information to
district attorneys i might not know this
but none of the federal judges that have
reviewed these cases apparently know
this either because that is one of the
most concerns
why these get shot down it absolutely is
what you so do you know what the basis
of the pennsylvania lawsuit was
uh which one trump's got one
pennsylvania what is the basis for that
one
that vote observers weren't allowed to
actually observe the ballot process the
counting process
okay the court ruled that so long as an
observer was somewhere present in the
building
whether they were allowed to actually
observe as meaningless because the
election code doesn't specify distance
that is one of the most insane things
i've ever heard come out of a person's
mouth
we know why vote observers exist because
we have photos from bush v gore of
people
staring side by side up at the ballot
arguing over whether or not it was bush
or gore
wasn't one of the pennsylvania cases
that they won the small one wasn't
one of the cases they won was when the
somebody related to the pennsylvania
election stuff said that we were going
to allow people to vote up to a certain
length in time
or it was something where like what they
had said wasn't necessarily bad
but the judge came out and said listen
even though that's not really bad it's
not in your it's not the proof of your
job to do that you're not allowed to do
that and i think that was the one case
that they won and i think that was in
pennsylvania i don't think it was a
trump campaign
that might not have been their lawsuit
that was the one one lawsuit in
pennsylvania for a small handleball
but like if the code doesn't specify it
or if it's explicitly not specified
then i mean like what case do you have
what standing do you have there then
also
judges interpret the law right so when
the law says
as per election code observers shall be
there to observe
the vote tabulating process we know that
the spirit of that law the reason why we
have it is so that you can have
scrutineers
making sure someone isn't going trump
trump trump
so no no no that was biden but they put
people way far back behind plexiglas
walls
and the trump campaign said why were we
not allowed to observe why would they
challenge any of these laws before
election night
because the law there's no ruling on it
first of all do you understand what
injury and fact is
that you need some uh there has to be
damage order for them to bring so when
the trump campaign did sue beforehand
the supreme court reserved their right
to judge uh to issue later on
they sued over mail-in voting and the
court this is not this is a totally
unrelated thing now
there's a bunch of different lawsuits
there's a bunch of different sure but
now we're talking about i'm talking very
specifically about we can talk about the
demanding of those or more specifically
we're dominion voting systems
sure you're about the observer stuff
right if this all was codified in state
law
and the law is there and we've helped
you our elections we just had
suggestions two years ago
why didn't nobody challenge it i'll
explain it you can't sue on the basis of
clarifying what the law really means
until you have injury it doesn't have to
be suing believe it or not there are
other ways in this country to change
laws there are legislations both in the
state and the federal level they can
change these laws
you don't need the suited changes if we
pass a law saying you have a right to
observe as i count votes right
do you reasonably believe you have a
right to look at me and the votes
why why did anyone think a judge was
going to say no nope it didn't specify
that you had to actually see the vote
so long as you're in the building come
on man that's unreasonable
you're saying come on okay trump for
months because they knew that they were
going to get destroyed on the mail-in
ballots
trump for months was calling out the
maryland ballots and guess what
he was doing that far before any
lawsuits had to be followed two years
far before
any injury occurred okay they were
calling these out why didn't they call
out anything related to voting observers
the reason why is because they know it's
all bs no they know that this fraud
didn't happen
1 million because uh because if i was
somebody that had a massive vested
interest in making sure that these
elections weren't going to be rigged i
wouldn't be calling this out
after joe biden hold on it's probably
something that you would have brought up
beforehand
you can't be serious that you think it
is reasonable that so long as an
observer is somewhere in the building
that counts as observing the vote
counting process you can't be serious
that you think that the only reason that
they would challenge this is because
like well now they've lost the election
and now this is the first time they've
noticed it these laws have been in place
in some ways for decades
and in previous elections people were
allowed to actually look at the ballots
no one knew that this time that the
these precincts specifically pits
and allegheny county and pennsylvania
were going to bar observers and they'd
have to sue over it
okay they didn't last time why would
they know big for a big timple
prediction not taking a comics do you
think they're going to win any of these
lawsuits
in a meaningful way not like there were
four ballots in a mail-in thing or not
do you think that they're actually
absolutely not why not first of all when
a judge says
did you have observers in the building
and the republican says
the amount of observers in the building
was a non-zero number
but we were not given meaningful access
to the votes and the judge says well
according to the election code
it doesn't specify the distance by which
you can observe therefore
you have no you have no grounds to sue
that is
clearly bad faith if trump is going to
lose
it's going to be for two reasons many of
these judges and one judge even said
this
if you think i will he said you can't
expect me to rule in such a way that
would disenfranchise millions of voters
that's
that's absurd i can't do that that's not
all he said
no no i'm just i'm bringing up that
point specifically there was a very
important second part to that and he
said i can't do that with no evidence
he said that one would think that
somebody was coming to me to
disenfranchise even one vote that they
would be coming with a very strong case
of lots of evidence
but let alone millions of votes to bring
such a shoddy case built on poor legal
arguments with no evidence or shoddy
evidence that he that was the full quote
for that
so the point i'm saying is there's an
unwillingness to take such a
massive and unprecedented move in a
court
without evidence there's there is
evidence there isn't though just because
a judge said
without evidence doesn't mean there's no
evidence not just one judge but people
have gone through
so many of these affidavits here's did
you are we talking about trump's
lawsuits or random
i guess i'm not i don't know one million
percent of the distinction between only
trump's lawsuit
and all of the other ones that have been
brought up people people have been
rooting and cheering for sydney powell
and look at what tucker carl
what happened with tucker carlson when
he was like where's the evidence they
ripped him apart they left fox news
and now many trump supporters are going
after sydney powell because they're
saying she's actually a democrat trying
to undermine the republican party of
course it's the craziest thing because
anybody that's not locked up with daddy
trump is immediately castigated
well for sure but people are so
adamantly behind sydney powell and lynn
wood
it's it's crazy like when when i tweet i
tweeted that it sounds like
sidney powell's getting her information
from conspiracy forms oh people start
tweeting me like crazy and
they've been making fun of me like oh
how dare you now what trump she's
contradicting trump
like that stuff i keep saying it over
and over again you come out and want to
claim that
this company was founded in venezuela
smartmatic and then sequoia and all this
stuff
may be true that's totally fine but bro
you need extraordinary evidence for
extraordinary claims
when we're talking about a judge in
pennsylvania and the lawsuit wasn't
about fraud
it's another thing that the left keeps
doing trump has specific lawsuits
pertaining to the
validity of mail-in voting and absentee
voting deadlines etc
so in these court cases the judge will
ask for a simple clarification are you
alleging fraud no your honor we're not
i'll take a clip of that and say aha
this proves it trump is saying there's
no fraud and the lawsuit isn't claiming
it
yeah he didn't sue over fraud because
that requires
long-standing understanding was that the
confusion then was because some of these
judges were trying to figure out what
standing they even had then to be there
because because initially it felt like
the thing that i feel when i read the
differences between what's what's being
reported in these court cases versus
what giuliani comes up and says giuliani
sounds like he's alleging some massive
election fraud absolutely but then when
it comes to them talking in front of a
it's like the meme with the the little
dog and then the like the shredded dog
and the shredded dog is like giuliani in
front of the cameras alleging fraud
election conspiracy and then when he
gets in front of a church he's like okay
i'm not saying fraud but like i don't
think this lady
was allowed to be in an area where she
was supposed to be and it's over like
the smallest militia ever
and they don't even have good evidence
what they're doing i think i think it's
fair to say
that the trump the trump campaign is not
delivering in terms of the legal process
by which they go after fraud 100
i also think it's fair to say that the
legal strategy over challenging
voting systems and ballots is a legal
strategy and that's i
wish that that strategy if it's
something that they so deeply cared
about
i wish that they would have done that
prior to the actual election no but you
don't understand man
how could they have known that the
observers wouldn't have been allowed
maybe they could have specified it in
the code
it seems like trump has every other
conspiracy theory in his head about how
he's going to be disenfranchised you
don't think having people observing the
vote would have been like
and if the law existed though they had
them they didn't specify
the difference and i don't even know
what that is and also i'm giving you a
lot here because i haven't read the
exact verbiage because i'm willing to
bet that when i go back home and i
actually read through the case it's
going to be more than just like they had
to be anywhere in the building
but literally my guess is going to be
that it's probably been consistent with
state laws over all prior elections and
it hasn't been a big deal before but now
people are just really mad
because of the massive increase in in
voters for democrats on the mainland
ballots
and that's why everybody's losing their
mind over it let me ask you should we
have
scrutineers people who look at the
ballots as they're being counted from
both parties or even a third party
i don't know how these lectures are
generally rendered that sounds normally
what they do yeah it sounds like it'd be
is it okay that this time they didn't do
that i don't know if that's the case i
don't think in the majority of places
that is the case where it wasn't
no no no no no specifically the
pennsylvania suit yes specifically in
some philly and elegance
so you have these videos coming out
where people are standing 100 feet away
with binoculars
and they're like i literally can't see
anything one of the most important
lessons i've learned in my life is to
never believe anything i've ever seen in
a twitter video
just so many things i don't know what
what the video what time is it i don't
know
multiple scores somebody else that i'd
heard just recently say something about
like um
like all of these uh votes are being
reported by machine like you don't see
people walking around voting
we did literally on election night you
saw people like delivering votes and
stuff to
county houses and stuff or bringing from
other counties like like when it comes
to videos i don't trust any of that on
the internet without like a greater
story or context around it because
anybody can take one video of any sworn
effort
sure swarm it up so sworn affidavits in
combination with the videos
is interesting and and i'm saying we
can't see
we can't actually observe the votes so a
big portion of what julian is bringing
forward right now in
in michigan and his other places is that
all of these
a lot of these people who are coming
forward saying they're not allowed to
actually observe the vote count
so when you have unprecedented rule
changes no excuse mail in voting which
in the instant pennsylvania now
a judge recently issued an opinion
citing that it seems very likely
the the plaintiffs will win on the
merits that this is unconstitutional
the supreme court shut it down on a
narrow ruling that it was too late to
to sue on this you know even though they
just should have brought it out
they just found out about the law they
just found out about the acceptance of
late melon voting
that it was in violation of the
constitution why they didn't see it
initially
you know what it sounds like it sounds
like they lost and now they're going
back and trying it certainly does
okay i absolutely agree with you which
makes it hard to believe in good faith
but but that's not how that's not the
legal system would work well according
to some of these judges that's
explicitly how the legal so for instance
some of these rulings
explicitly will say the fact that she
didn't follow any of the chain of
command or the fact that this person
didn't report any of this on election
night is very damaging to their
credibility why would it matter
if the lawsuit was now or later when
they weren't asking to do anything to
this current election
what the reason why it matters is
because if these things are happening
and they're only being reported
retroactively it seems like it's in a
way it wouldn't happen if i didn't lose
it it wouldn't happen
winning rather than to any actual but if
it wouldn't have an impact on the
election then it's irrelevant
what do you mean the lawsuit wasn't
asking to do anything to the current
election they asked the courts to issue
their advice on relief meaning
perhaps in the future we won't do no
excuse mail in voting the supreme court
said
it's too late to sue for this dismissed
with with
with prejudice meaning these people
can't bring these cases up uh ever again
what's interesting is that the lower
court ruling was that it would have been
detrimental
to several of the plaintiffs who
actually won their elections mike kelly
won
and then sued saying we didn't realize
that the republicans passed an
unconstitutional law
and the the judge actually issued an
opinion saying as this would be you not
realize somebody passed the law
they realized the law was passed but
many people didn't know
that it was unconstitutional what
changed did they read a tweet or
whatever they write the constitution
no after election they didn't do that
when the law is being passed isn't that
part of like your
job as a legislator i'd be willing to
bet there was somebody who was looking
at
what's going on what can we do and the
motivation was very much
trump is losing this however the lawsuit
wasn't brought by trump it was brought
actually by a guy who
won and several other people as well as
a guy who lost so it was a mixed bag
and they weren't asking for the election
to be thrown out they were asking for
the courts to advise
on what relief could be sean parnell sat
here just you know a couple a week ago
and he said
i don't want anyone to be
disenfranchised i don't want uh i'm not
saying this vote
has to be thrown out this election has
to be thrown out we all thought this was
constitutional i'm just asking for maybe
the court will advise us maybe they'll
say hey this we need a constitutional
amendment so from this point forward
we're going to say no to this you know
excuse me voting moving forward and then
you get a constitutional amendment you
know what's really crazy about it
when the when the gop was passing the
rep the pennsylvania gop was passing act
77 which is no excuse mail in voting
they actually started the process to
amend the constitution and halfway
through
stopped changed some wording and then it
got passed signed off on by governor so
this is a bipartisan
approval most people didn't realize what
had happened wait
that doesn't sound like a bad thing on
its face at all if you were going to
pass something and then
you realized it was going to be
unconstitutional so you got to change
the constitution when you realize well
hold on if we reform some of this bill
no no no no
no no no no you said reform i said they
changed some of the words
okay so laws are the words that make the
laws let's
let's let's not play semantic games it's
not a semantic case well when you say
change some words
like i can change some words and make
anything anything else what do you mean
by that so let's let's let's not place
them into games
let's define it when the constitution
says absentee bouts require specific
excuses to be allowed
and the law they initially presented was
no excuse absentee they changed absentee
to mail
okay that's the that's it are there an
entirely different set of provisions
that come in under mail-in ballots
versus absentee is there a whole
different part of their state
legislature that has a different way of
dealing with
the same thing the exact same thing and
that's why the judge in the lower court
ruled
the plaintiffs will will will likely be
successful on the merits
and then the the higher court said we're
not ruling on the merits we don't know
it's just too late okay well sounds like
they should have brought it up
beforehand then they're going to the
supreme court okay and it'll be
interesting when it goes to the supreme
court so one of the one of the issues
that i have when people keep saying
affidavits after david's have a david's
on the first hand is it feels like
somebody's sliding down a mountain
grabbing
branches or whatever as he's going down
like initially we're grabbing all the
mail and ballots are voted fraud
then we were saying you know um we've
got the uh dominion voting machines are
made in venezuela and then somehow hugh
chavis is coming back to life to blah
blah blah
no no no stop stop stop first of all the
dominion stuff is nuts
in my opinion i know that's crazy i
can't believe
these machines existed for so long and
no one said anything about not your
election 2006 cnn reporting on it
what did they report they reported that
they were completely insecure and there
was a bunch of problems and all that
stuff
and one of the things specifically that
they reported is stuff like a lack of
paper trail or no ability to audit these
machines
which has been some of the stuff that
has been corrected and fixed in almost
every single state that allows these
machines to function hold on you said
hugo chavez came back to life
sure no one's argued that okay i'm just
hearing chavez's name a lot really
because
smartmatic there was a there's a
wikileaks release from 2010
this was this has been on the internet
for over a decade cablegate
where they say in 2010 hugo chavez
was providing you know resources to a
group of individuals in venezuela who
are the principal owners
and if you travel through all these
different shell companies you find it
originated in
venezuela that's where that hugo chavez
comes from sure i feel like the argument
that hugo chavez came back to life is an
attempt to
ignore what's actually being presented
well i'm attempting to make the people
sound insane because they are to assume
that there's some wider
play by some other country why why are
you doing that
you don't have to be ridiculous you
don't need to i think well because for
me because i do a lot of humor so i
think it's funny would people
invoke so much try to scare people into
thinking that some machines are stealing
our election
but to say like this narrative that
confuses the actual argument from people
wait what is the actual argument the
actual argument is that
going back uh you know a decade plus
going back 20 years
there was a series of companies that
were started with the express purpose
of being able to hide through audits
that votes were manipulated
there is a company smartmatic that was
involved in this and has ties to
venezuela as per diplomatic cables that
were like 10 years ago so we've known
about this for a long time why did the
dhs
and the department say that's
there's a difference between what these
people are actually arguing and coming
out and saying he was shadows returning
to the great so on
the level of raised dominion voting
machines if any of this was true it
would be the largest political news
story related to elections
in the past hundreds do you trust the
media to report something like this this
is like pulitzer
prize-winning related they won
pulitzer's for the russia gate stuff
sure there was a lot of good reporting
and a lot of credible indictments that
came out of that unlike the benghazi and
the email hearings
but regardless i'm just saying that like
this level of election fraud would be
like an unimaginable
what were the what were the uh what were
the indictments uh related to russia um
so one had to do with the internet
research agency which was funded by the
gremlin which had a whole bunch of
but those were foreigners not trump and
not trump correct yeah um yeah there
were no indictments related specifically
to trump's cabinet although we did get
some indictments kind of like arrest
yeah so the manafort stuff came out of
that um flynn got caught lying to the
fbi
um although daddy trump pardoned him um
cohen went down for
uh the new york related stuff and the
elections you know the crazy thing about
the manafort stuff is
you know they found out about that what
did they find out about it you know that
how they find out found out about
manafort
i read a lot of weird stuff to the
political report some guy's office and
they found a ledger that was like
written
on a piece of paper whatever manafort
for owning money and so they didn't
report to the state department but go
ahead
politico reported that ukrainian
operatives were trying to sabotage trump
and so they sent documents to a dnc
operative
and then she you know passed it along
saying here we got some dirt go after
them and then they did
so it was political it was you know
political so all of manafort's charges
were just 100
dollars they found out about a lot of
his documents because it was passed off
for political reasons
if i should be surprising anybody sure i
don't know how that absolves
i didn't say i did i said it's
interesting that you know we've got
ukraine
stepping up we've got this you know
political battle people are trying to go
after each other
yeah i'm sure people are trying to send
people dirt about other leaders all the
time
assange and wikileaks and they're doing
all of that for a long time for their
lip um we also as a result of all those
indictments found out a lot about how
the
um how the dnc was penetrated via the
spear fishing stuff by the guccifer 2.0
hacker and everything we yeah
a lot of them in the end as well some
people should not be
some people don't use computers and a
lot of people with import with access to
really important information
you know but uh but let's not yeah yeah
that'd be real go back to the voter
stuff
yeah the point is on the pia on the
pennsylvania point that i'm bringing up
is
we had a serious conundrum in terms of
voter observation
it is i think widely accepted that we
should have
observers making sure that people aren't
falsifying the vote count sure do you
agree
if the pennsylvania court just ruled
that's not the case should we change it
so that is the case
i would have to see the on the specific
ruling for that argument because
more often than not when people cite
these usually they're sure some key so
let's just say i personally i think you
should probably have people observing
the election i can't think of a reason
offhand why you wouldn't that doesn't
make sense to me but i would have to
read into why they made the ruling they
did so
check it out the issue would be then if
the the judge made this ruling on the
grounds the election code doesn't
specify distance
i mean then why wouldn't say trump 2024
just be like
we're cleared we got we got a ruling
from the court we know what we can do
now and you can't sue us
unless you're you have a syria unless
you have injury in fact therefore
when it comes time to election all
republicans bar all democrats and we
can't lose
we can write down whatever numbers we
want if you want so yeah go for it so
it's a serious threat to our election
integrity it could potentially be yeah
and if somebody were to bring it up in
that manner i'd believe them when they
said that but right now it just feels
like republicans doing anything they can
to try to flip the election results
i think yes 100 and i think the
democrats
they didn't i don't think they tried to
flip the results in 2016 for the most
part there were there was a whole lot of
that hillary can still win stuff and
hillary conceded the next day
but absolutely not even remotely similar
uh
it's remotely similar i would say it's
maybe like the way that antarctica is
remotely close to like please do you see
the videos of celebrities saying the
electoral college must
vote for hillary clinton do you think
there's a difference well i'm sorry they
didn't say that they didn't say that
there's
between celebrities saying something and
the president of the united states
trying to undermine the election
that's why i'm saying these aren't
remotely similar yes under mine see
that's that's that's framing
well it's when you say something in 2016
trump said
millions of illegals voted he started
that with no evidence that's undermining
the integrity of election
and then in 2020 he's saying that there
was widespread election fraud that
literally no
agency no other credible person has
backed up saved for
the melting head of giuliani like no one
else is backing up on this his own dhs
turned on him on this with his own
appointee his own attorney general the
sword and shield what did he say barr
came out and said that as of right now
there is no evidence of widespread
election fraud
um wait wait there's more to that quote
what else that would have changed the
outcome of the election would change the
outcome election okay
to date we have not seen evidence that
on a scale that would have changed what
else did he say too
what else he also said that they looked
into the dominion machines and based on
their analysis of it they didn't see any
evidence also that those machines were
fully voted i think the dominion stuff
is
is over the top look you got you got
brian kemp and brian uh was it with
brian kemp is the name right
and raffensberger okay are they both
brian was it brad ravensburg i'm mixing
their names up or something
but these are republicans i don't think
there's a grand conspiracy where members
of like
the trump supporting republican
georgians are like ah now our chance
but people really believe it yeah they
do i think for one
partially because a lot of people play
into it you do as well right how do i
plan to it
when you're tweeting i just straight up
agreed and said it was nuts sure i know
but a lot of the
it feels like a lot of your rhetoric
gives a lot of credence or credibility
to a lot of the lawsuits that challenge
you know like how the election is being
like i like the fact that you're willing
to say that you think that the elect do
you do you think that the election the
majority of the election was legit
that yeah maybe there were a few but you
think for the results stand
i think what people need to realize too
is you don't need widespread fraud alter
the outcome of an election
you know you would no you don't you you
need maybe one person in four key
districts
absolutely not or one person with a usb
stick
absolutely not that's not how these work
it is absolutely
i actually was in vegas at def con when
they hacked the voting machines i watch
them do it i don't know what voting
machines they hacked but
hacking hacking one machine or hacking a
series of machines is a lot different
than the step-by-step process that goes
through
tabulating results or putting them but
they all go in the machine right
sure but there's also paper trails
behind all these votes as well and they
didn't did
did they do a hard signature audit i
don't know if they did that they did
they they did a risk they have their
yeah their risk assessment audits
trump's but there is a paper trail
behind every single thing but now the
problem is saying well for some of the
ballots that were taken of the mail and
things they've been separated from they
destroyed the verify or whatever
that's a problem they destroyed so with
the
observers in pennsylvania they destroyed
the secrecy envelopes so now it's like
what do we do
they destroyed them before anybody could
could check to see if they were legit
why would they do that but you so you
believe the election is legitimate as it
stands but maybe there are some things
we could fix going forward because
that's a stat that's a stance i could
maybe
i would say as of right now i said this
uh and i got ragged on hard for it on
september 7th
uh i sat down like on the eighth i think
no no no it wasn't the eighth
it was the ninth i took a day off
because i was like everything's crazy uh
the the the simple solution is trump got
oceans 11.
that if the the cheating as as i would
frame it is
the mass changing of rules well before
the election using covet as a pretext
when act 77 was even passed in october
the democrats did everything in their
power
within the system to give themselves
advantages they were going door-to-door
they were doing democracy in the park
they were doing illegal uh democracy in
the park was illegal
uh the vote raffles that we just saw
emerged all these videos through all
these different swing states was also
illegal
there's no evidence as of right now
there are i should say there's not
enough
have you ever been charged over this
democracy in the park stuff or there was
uh
i would say not yet i don't know okay
but i will say there was one person so
far charged with 135 counts related to
basically getting infirm people to vote
and signing off documents for them
there's currently uh a case going to the
the
the uh i think the district attorney in
pennsylvania
where they found several thousand
ballots all filled out in the same
handwriting for joe biden
in the names of elderly people in
various nursing homes so
this stuff happened it exists can i say
that this is the
the reason why joe biden went i can't so
i'm not gonna i do not agree with trump
when he says
i lost due to a regulation in widespread
fraud i say well there's evidence of
fraud
uh to the scale that would have
generated a flipping of the election i
would say
no there was impropriety that would have
changed the outcome of the election
but what we're talking about with that
with trump's lawsuit in pennsylvania is
disqualifying 682 000 votes
because they weren't observed as they
were counted and as giuliani said mickey
mouse could have filled them out that
is not fraud that is them saying we
should disqualify these votes in an
attempt to win because they weren't
allowed to observe them
i think it's a problem that people
weren't allowed to observe them properly
i don't know that disenfranchising the
state
is the appropriate you know path forward
that's mostly a gribble shirt i would
say for
life pro tip for people in the future or
anybody um either playing video games
with friends or trying to run a country
do you have severe problems with the way
that rules are it's usually good to try
to change the rules before you lose
otherwise everybody's going to look at
you sideways wondering if you actually
care about the rules or if you're just
trying to get them changed to change but
they're not trying to change the rules
well in terms of like saying well in
terms of specifying the distance or in
terms of like having observers in a
certain area or whatever it sounds like
they want to refine these girls or
something i think i
i think that hasn't gone to the supreme
court yet uh however
there's a there's a trump supporting
lawyer a friend of mine named will
chamberlain he said
he's it's not going there sure the
supreme court he said it was it was it
was uh
on appeal so you saw that court case
where the trump appointee was like get
out of here
okay they appealed it and they uh that
case was them appealing
just to have the right to amend the
argument in the first place and they
said get out of here
so well if this is the same one that i'm
thinking the reason why they told them
to get out of there is because i think
that
this was a giuliani this was a trump
case right it was they'd amended this
case like five or six
times and i think giuliani showed up
they wanted to amend it for a second
time that was it
and so what i wish i remember exactly
what this was but i know that i watched
there was one because there was a legal
analysis video of one of these that
juliana got thrown out of court because
they they had moved different lawyers on
and off of this case so much and then
they'd pushed it right and they tried to
amend the case so many times
that eventually the lawyer was like hey
you know why they changed the joke like
get out
i know you're not going to say because
of the threats yeah the
the the the uh a bunch of high-profile
verified leftists uh the lincoln project
posted the phone numbers of lawyers
and then within a day they said please
judge let us leave the case
like that's that's i mean that's the
only reasonable
that's the only reason they did it the
judges quit the case after being
threatened and harassed so i've had
unfortunately a lot of bad uh
experiences with people higher education
that makes me wonder sometimes
but i would feel like it feels to me
that it would be pretty obvious
and if you're a lawyer you'd probably
understand this that if you are going to
be working on a public lawsuit
you're probably going to get a lot of
public backlash they weren't ready for
any of that
i'm not saying that's good if i would
say no posting phone numbers that's
pretty abhorrent
however it feels more like they probably
left because they saw the case was
meritless rather than just like oh we
got death threats so we decided to
walk away that's possible too fairly
improbable but that's possible too but
that's speculative
more so i would say if if we get the
lincoln project a bunch of news stories
were published saying you know
republican pac you know anti-trump
republican pac sure publishes private
information twitter forced the tweet
down
and then within a couple days the
lawyers put an official request to leave
the case
our only chain of events is this so i
think it's the simple solution is
they were threatened and harassed to the
point where they said we don't want to
be involved anymore sure i guess it's
just surprising that the lord would say
i can't believe my information went
public on one of the most public
lawsuits being followed the world right
now
that's very strange to me there's no
other there's no other issues and how
come all the other
lawyers you know are not getting
harassed or staying on why aren't they
are the other lawyers aren't getting
harassed at all they're hard to believe
as well i'm sure that any public name
that's on any of those filings probably
the lincoln project publishing your
phone number is probably very different
from just
being a law firm on one of the suits
possibly yeah
but so when you watch the um did you
watch the project veritas guy that they
originally had that was going to uh
that had signed the affidavit saying he
was told the backdate stuff or whatever
that okie was talking yeah did you ever
listen to the full interrogation of this
yeah when he retracted his
yeah yeah i did so one of my worries for
the affidavits that and then watching um
reading through some of the judge
testimonies a lot of these affidavits
are people um they're
being truthful they're signing what they
believe to be true but the problem is
their observations are just not
bad like they think they are did you
hear what the guy said after
well after o'keefe brought him on and
buttered him up someone was like no i
got mind controlled or whatever by the
interrogator
so if you listen to the interrogator
everything that they walked through was
like it was pretty obvious the guy's
claim was way farther than he ever could
have made
i disagree the guy literally walked
across the aisle to the desk he's like
hey if i'm
because because the guy had said when he
was across the office like i very
clearly could hear him saying like we
need to post it or back date some of the
ballots
and the guy's like hey can you hear me
over there and the guy like doesn't even
respond
and he's like hey hello and i said oh
yeah yeah i can hear you now he's like
okay so you think the guy made it up in
the first place
i don't think that he made it up i'm not
i don't think that he's that malicious
i think he probably heard a word or two
and then maybe extrapolated and then
i probably ran with it after that it's
what it seemed like based on that like
two hour interrogation
a guy hearing something and then being
like i can't believe that happened and
then telling someone
is probably more accurate than a federal
agent coming in and saying sit down
and he says what did he what did he say
i'm scaring you right now
like why did what did you hear that
stuff yeah of course
that's that's so what do you think
happens when some regular like kind of
dopey dude is sitting there and a
federal agent is kind of
drilling him you didn't hear it did you
you can't hear it can you
you're right don't worry everything is
for you we're scaring you right now
so it was a creepy it was a creepy
recording it it wasn't it was totally
fair
the guy had originally stated that he
had heard crystal clear like across the
the
across his whole office and he heard
something and he signed a sworn
affidavit under penalty of perjury sure
and so did the there are
plenty of people sign academics for a
lot of different things right sure sure
but uh witness testimony is evidence but
it's not definitive
when it came time for him to actually
talk to the guy he walked back
almost all of his strong claims that he
couldn't hear the guy talking across it
maybe he didn't hear 100 he was told to
back date things that like
and i listened to the entire interview
it sounded pretty fair to me if the guy
had accurately heard it because
initially he did feel a lot more
confident when the guy asked a few
questions he started to kind of like
falter
and the statement and i know o'keefe
likes to clip out like five seconds you
know like palestine saying like yeah i'm
putting a little bit of pressure on you
because
that's what you do when you watch the
full thing
it was it was it was not like
i used to work wait it was not what it
was not uh
a calm reasonable discussion trying to
finding mission unbelievably calm the
guy spent
half the discussion like remember like
the guy with the the um the guy being in
target was like oh yeah i wanted a law
enforce or i wanted to go to criminal
justice i went to school for it i think
i was like
oh yeah you know like that's so cool
like yeah you're probably smart you know
all of this like
seeing the police tactics the uh the the
investigator was playing good cop one
million percent the entirety it doesn't
mean he's not pressuring the guy and
playing upon putting memories in his
head he even said
we want to pressure you so that you can
you can make memories
and did you remember when he said that
right he said we want you
to you know when we pressure you this
way then you can form memories
i'm pretty sure exactly what he said was
that when we pressure you you're more
likely to remember what actually
happened is what he said
that under some pressure the truth will
come out or whatever it was ultimately i
think the argument is kind of pointless
on this one guys sure well
it it is just this one i noticed a
pattern for a lot of these affidavits
that what will happen is that somebody
will file an affidavit saying like oh
yeah like i saw election fraud and then
when it comes down to like well what did
you see and i was like well i was in
this room and i think i saw a thing and
like
the the actual claim is actually
way less than the super extrapolated
thing that ends up on the affidavit is
what it feels like to me
i don't i don't bite on my court cases
too i don't think the uh the affidavits
uh go particularly far witness testimony
is evidence
it's used in criminal court cases all
the time i think the the best evidence
we have so far is the voter integrity
project
are you familiar with matt brenner's
work so the statistician
if he was in front of michigan where he
tried to explain no he wasn't allowed to
testify in michigan i think oh okay then
that was a different data science i
think that was right he he yeah he went
out there
supposed to have him and he went out
there he's like i'm going to testify
there and then he's like i was not able
to testify
okay what he did was he i believe he
purchased
the publicly available data from several
swing states he then hired three call
centers
and he gave him a list of questions to
ask did you request an absentee ballot
did you send in an absentee ballot
things like that and he found in a bunch
of different circumstances
uh that was one of the things they did
they also cross referenced the national
change of address database with people
who voted
they found i think i could be getting
the number wrong was was it 20 000 in
georgia yeah
i think 20 000. 20 000 people in georgia
who had changed their addresses
voted in their new state and voted by
absentee in georgia
that's like he's got they've actually
published parts of the database you can
see the names
he actually he also found i think tens
of thousands of people who listed
commercial addresses with fake apartment
numbers
in nevada i think it's like 11 000 or so
that's
legitimate hard evidence so is that
going to show up in a court case
the fbi took it already so the fbi
proactively reached out to him and this
was
how long ago did this happen four days
three days
how long ago was bar statement or so the
fbi had looked into things and it didn't
look like there was
barr said to date we have yeah but what
was that today how long ago bar probably
have statement wasn't that just a couple
days ago yes
we haven't seen evidence uh on a scale
that would have altered the outcome of
the election
okay something that affect the fbi just
reached out
reached out to brainerd requesting uh
this was reported in a few outlets he
mentioned it we'll see we'll see if
anything
it comes of it but this is one of the
reasons why there's a big backlash
between
uh people on the right and what bar had
said and why barr then clarified
the next day we are actively
investigating and we'll take any
credible report
you know or whatever so matt brainard is
probably
the best evidence but again it's not
definitive proof that
there was an outcome you know changing
that coming election i'm not saying that
you know maybe the fbi did review his
data and they said
well these 20 000 are 5050 trump or
biden so it wouldn't have changed
anything
possibly the problem too is that like
and again i hate that i'm not maybe with
a specific
specific thing but i know in front of
michigan they would testify that like oh
well here's evidence of voter fraud as
well
um there were 120 percent of of the
people yeah or not voter turnout like of
the registered vote or whatever here
um like they they would use these rights
right right now but the reality of what
had happened was well you know some
people move the voter
registry isn't updated or some people
here but like this isn't evidence of
voter fraud it's just evidence that
there needed to be an update in like the
right
one of the biggest problems uh in
trump's argument
and a lot of conservatives bring this up
is when they're like you'll see a tweet
where they say
there's 7 836 dead people on the voter
registration in this place
and it's like yes because they died and
they haven't been purged
yeah are you saying they voted because
that's a different you know so i hear
that a lot from the from the right i'm
like that's irrelevant
exactly without proving that they voted
yeah yeah you if you have proof they
voted then all of a sudden we're like
whoa
and there have been some instances but i
think uh in one i think there were a
couple where like somebody sent in a
mail in battle and then died before the
election
i think i i was in like louisiana or
something i i misread something and
tweeted like whoa dead people voted and
then i
went back and i was like ah they voted
and then died yeah
but there were some instances that some
mainstream outlets found where there
were a couple dead people who
were found to have voted sure so the
issue there is
is there voter fraud yes and the
heritage foundation has a list of it
is it widespread to the scale that it
changed that come with the election
that's not been proven
sure that's the that's the best way i
can put it obviously the left will say
of course not the right will say of
course yes
the reality is there's evidence there's
crazy evidence but it's not been proven
and i don't think it will be to be
honest i don't i don't i don't think
uh and and you know a lot of
conservatives agree with this
that you have an apparatus that could
even investigate on this scale 150
million
votes to figure out who did or didn't
the
brainerd stuff the voter integrity
project is probably the scariest stuff
we have so far
there's a guy named nashon garrett he's
he's a
a college uh collegiate is that how you
say it
collegiate wrestler training for the
olympics he lived in arizona he moved to
tennessee
he got a phone call from one of the call
centers asking if he requested an
absentee ballot
he said no i voted in tennessee i moved
here a while ago to train for the
olympics
they said did you didn't request it you
did not submit one he says no i didn't
is it
somebody requested and submitted an
absentee ballot in arizona in your name
and so he then went public went on fox
news and said
that's not me i didn't do that that's
crazy
i'd like to see uh an investigation and
some prosecutions
and uh or at least at the very least
investigations maybe there's no
prosecutions because we don't know where
it leads to it leads to
but if you've got people changing their
addresses and then voting
if if if this database thing on the
national change of address database from
brainerd is correct
and he has 20 000 people in georgia who
changed their address but voted in two
different locations
either they voted twice or someone voted
in their name we got to investigate that
sure
especially if trump supporters are
outraged and demanding clarity
the crazy thing to me is that at a time
when this country is dramatically and
hyperpolarized
the democrats confident they're in their
win should be like please trump
take the resources you need to
investigate and compare signatures and
do what you need to do
so that we can then tell you we won
definitively instead
but they're doing that they're not
they're blocking it there's there's uh
they've been doing
all of these investigations or they've
had they've had all these court cases
and all these different states
you know the court cases are not
investigations the dnc is countersued
and the aclu is countersuited blocking
the trump lawsuits
so they're not cooperating and they're
arguing against it
you said that barr himself and the fbi
was it was following up you said that
list was turned into the fbi and these
investigations are working through these
things it's not like the investigations
are happening no no for sure i'm saying
the democrats should come out and be
like
yes absolutely please investigate i mean
i guess it depends
on what they believe the merits of the
case are that's so ridiculous that all
this is doing is just tearing the
country asunder because they're
constantly challenging everything a
little part of the election process
it can only do the opposite that's not
true though you can draw stuff like that
like this for years
no until they can't find any evidence of
anything and then biden wins the
entrepreneur
long did we have to listen to trump talk
about how obama was from kenya
like they could draw this out for so
long but there's like we haven't had
a process sure there might be but again
legal
processes can be
whether or not there's an investigation
there's going to be an inauguration sure
and and and the investigation can carry
on and fine let them draw it out sure
we went through three three and a half
years we were still technically going
through russiagate because
adam schiff won't drop it and here we
are
and we all kind of just roll with it and
the pulitzer prizes and all the awards
and then we
we realized it was all of these people
testifying
under oath they had no evidence it
didn't happen wait which what thing
didn't happen
so you had the likes of what was it like
brennan and clapper
you had people um er schiff they were
going on tv saying
yes it happened we have proof wait what
happened collusion
okay because i've heard it but then in
the skiff when they were doing the
closed door testimony they said oh no
that's not true i don't have any
evidence
and so that actually got released i
think in like october or something sure
the point
i'm not i'm not trying to rehash all
that i'm just saying if i can go through
all that i got no problem saying
either we we let the investigations
happen and maybe we find something
maybe we don't but so long as people
feel that in good faith we are
taking their complaints seriously we can
prevent destabilization
of what is already an extremely
hyperpolarized i can understand that you
must understand on the other end though
there is a little bit of frustration
with what feels like endless
investigations
into nothing related to things like
hillary clinton or benghazi these things
how many hours of court hearings how
many months did we get drips about
hillary's emails buttery emails over and
over and over and over again like
i'm gonna disagree because i honestly
think that if you want every single
american to be rightfully enfranchised
if they have the right to vote
then you more than anyone else you and
all of the democrats should 100 percent
want every possible investigation
because we want this to be true
free full and fair for every legal
citizen in the u.s
sure and i hope that they do with their
investigations i hope they're pulling
their cases in front of the courthouse
that's fine but there should be an
advantage and the way that all of this
is played out it really
does even the verbiage they use the the
it's never
when giuliani's talking it's never like
i want to ensure that this is a free and
fair election i want to assure that
everyone is kind of it's like we think
we can find enough votes here to change
the outcome of this state that's that's
oh they usually
straight up asked sidney powell one of
the
in relief in the kraken lawsuit was
declared trump the winner yeah like
they're literally asking explicitly like
this is supposed to be the part they're
not supposed to say out loud you're
supposed to keep that quiet you're
trying to
but like so i i'm not saying that like i
hope the investigations are blocked if
they have merit
but um i mean it would i would
understand why some people would feel a
bit salty that investigators get dragged
out forever but
i uh i know a lot of people who are
salty about the russia gate elections
you know
and i think that as a you know
with compromise comes one side rolling
their eyes while the other side shakes
their fists
and i mean better than lynn was
communicating with people in an
unauthorized manner before he went to
the white house
he literally lied about it lying i
thought it was unauthorized did he did
he lie about communicating or was it
unauthorized i believe that he lied
about it to the fbi that his
communication that
you know do you know the story okay
am i walking into a land mine which part
of uh what do you think that the uh do
you think flynn going to
prison or being charged with lying to
the fbi do you think was illegitimate
yes why because he was the acting
national security adviser who was
communicating with his russian
counterpart why did he lie to the fbi
about it
do you know the meeting wasn't a formal
investigation he was hanging out at the
white house and they asked him an
informal question and passing
and that was the grounds did you know
that they threatened his son to force a
guilty plea what
why did that did you know that why did
he lie to the fbi
if you right now lied to me or i did
what if what if you lied to ian
and you didn't know he might be so mad
do you think that flynn was talking to
somebody he had no idea
he didn't know he was under
investigation there was no legitimate
investigation and he was asked a passive
question by someone who had nothing to
do with him there was no legitimate
didn't the fbi and the uh the uh doj
both have or i'm sorry not the dj the
state
department both have a huge interest in
flynn because of his association
with kislyak i thought that was like a
big part that both of them had an issue
with
that the state department didn't want
him in the white house because they
weren't sure obviously he was
compromised
by the state department and then the fbi
obama didn't mind if he was not
because the fbi wanted to follow him up
for a further investigation so
you're talking politics not legitimate
claims against michael flynn
okay you're talking about michael flynn
who came out and this was a conversation
the other day with luke kowski
michael flynn came out and basically
talked about what the obama
administration had been doing with
supplying weapons to rebels obama got
mad fires him tells trump not to hire
this guy so trump says
i'm going to hire him then they started
having
these meetings this this was released in
i think it was the durham probe i'm not
entirely sure the notes that got
released show
that there was a meeting between like
sally yates james comey uh joe biden
barack obama
all having this big meeting in which
afterwards sally yates writes an email
to herself explaining what happened
and what did she explain what happened
in that meeting she went through
grueling detail about how obama ordered
them to make sure everything was on the
up and up
and done by the book in in terms of an
investigation of michael flynn
to some degree people people try to
claim that in that meeting
that i think they assert either obama or
or by i think
asserted that he brought up the logan
yes because there's not true there's a
there's
even in the in the even in the notes
that yet left yourself it was not true
that i never brought the logan act in
that particular meeting
so there's there's notes that say biden
logan act question mark
that's why it was asserted sure but i'm
not going to take sally
what's your evidence for that the the
there is no evidence for that that
nobody out nobody came out and said that
like oh yeah like biden was you know
this was brought up the the logan i was
brought up on his behalf or everything
i think anybody's ever talked about did
you know that notes released by the fbi
asked what should we do
uh what are we trying to do get him
fired or prosecute
okay why would the fbi be trying to get
trying to get a guy fired i think the
problem is that
and and this is something that gets
misconstrued about trump himself or
maybe it was bar himself misconstrued a
state department person's words in terms
of
what is our goal is to get him fired or
prosecute because there was a huge
conflict of interest between the fbi and
the state department over what to do
with flynn and this is where a lot of
the fighting between these two agents
came from the state department did want
did not want flint associated with the
white house at all they wanted him out
because they didn't have
his compromise on it the fbi didn't care
if he stayed there i shouldn't say
didn't care but they weren't as
concerned with that because they thought
that they could follow
flynn further up on an investigation so
there was a huge conflict of interest
there
we don't know do we want them to move
now do we want to continue to
investigate them that's a fair question
to ask there were two competing agencies
that had different goals did you know
they went after they threatened his son
i when you say threaten his son i don't
know like what like
if you don't plead guilty we are going
to prosecute your son did a son commit a
crime
i don't know exactly what the full deal
well that seems like really important
there because if a son committed a crime
it seems like that would be a pretty
important part of
threatening for look you're you're
getting somebody on a process crime
because in an informal meeting where he
was not being investigated he
said he didn't talk to kislyak don't you
think that's crazy that you could be
standing by a fbi agent and he could be
like
you ever talked to a russian ambassador
national security advisor would lie to a
member working the federal bureau of
investigation about contact with the
foreign agent yeah that does that seems
nice
in a formal meeting under investigation
he
has no obligation to tell anybody
anything in fact as national security
adviser why would he be giving away
his his advice and secrets to some some
fbi agent he doesn't know then why why
or i'm sorry he doesn't know like in the
sense why is he talking to him at all
about it then
so you're at a party you're at an
informal meeting at the white house
people are asking me the incoming
national security adviser about my
communication with foreign i probably
would say hey miss
you know what i don't think i'm going to
talk to you about that it seems really
inappropriate or maybe you're just like
no no no
because i don't want this guy to know
anything about i don't know who he is i
don't know what his deal is we're not an
informal investigation
he wasn't with a lawyer or anything like
that and they asked him a question and
that was the basis for prosecuting him
for lying to the fbi why did they why
did the judge
throw the book at him then what happened
isn't that strange that when the doj
said we want to drop this judge sullivan
did nothing for a month
my understanding is that the doj said
that they wanted to drop it under bar
and that
barr's reasoning for dropping that is
because he said that the state
department themselves
um were arguing over the fbi about
whether or not about how to deal with
flynn
and the state department had a person
and i believe it was her own words i
don't remember her name but she came out
and she said
actually barr used my statement because
i think the statement had to do with how
the state party was frustrated with how
the fbi was pursuing things but their
frustration wasn't that flynn was
innocent we don't know why the fbi is
bullying him their frustration was that
we don't want you to investigate flynn
we want him removed immediately
but the the so they were trying to
pressure the trump campaign into getting
rid of his national security
basically the because the state
department didn't want that guy in there
because he was compromised but the fbi
trump was the president sure trump was
the was the president uh
elect he became president it's his his
right as the dually elected president to
a point as an acting national security
adviser
whose job is to communicate with his
counterpart and i
understand that i'm just saying that
there is a reason why there was conflict
there and it wasn't just because flynn
was some innocent passerby
and the state department was trying to
exonerate him so when bart comes out and
he cites that particular statement sure
sure sure but that's that's irrelevant
to the question at hand
in an informal meeting where flynn was
not with his lawyer
or under you know formal investigation
they asked if he talked to kislyak and
he passively said no and that was it
what do you think about the uh what do
you think about the reports now that
trump is looking at potentially
preemptively pardoning himself or any of
his family members
do you believe in any of this sorry i
don't know i don't know i think it's
certainly within the realm of
possibility for something trump to do
but i don't trust a lot of these reports
that come from unnamed sources
you know ever since we've had that story
from huffington post people close to the
president say he has no one close to him
i'm just like these people are just
you know if if trump comes out and says
it
now believe it trump recently came out
at a party and said we're trying really
hard to stand for four years but if we
don't we'll see in 2024.
good enough for me when they come out
and say on unnamed individual claims i'm
like
sorry i'm just i got very little room
for these companies just to make these
claims
unless i know who the person is you know
especially after the fact
like we've seen many many people just
they hate the present to the point where
they'll say whatever they have to say
and there's certainly people who love
the president at the point we'll say
whatever whatever whatever i have to say
i want hard evidence when it comes to
fraud i want hard evidence when it comes
to the accusations against trump
when i look at the michael flynn
scenario it looks like barack obama
didn't like flynn
because flynn was not good to barack
obama so they said
we don't want you you know what the
reasoning for why the state department
thought it was compromised was
in a meeting he was talking to someone
and he and they uh i think it was yates
perhaps
they they uh he was asked you know who
do you think
or i'm sorry in a passive conversation
it comes up that he says i don't think
that russia is our biggest adversary i
think it's actually china
and that was like oh no he thinks he's
trying to defend russia or something
it's like well i i agree i think china
is a way bigger threat than russia is
and then all of a sudden he finds
himself being prosecuted for lying to
the fbi
for what now i'll tell you what he got
thrown into the bus by trump
and you know trump's team saying he
shouldn't and pence he shouldn't have
lied to us so it's it's his fault
and then later they came back and tried
to defend him trump's not a perfect guy
far from it and he made a ton of
mistakes he threw his own gun to the bus
and he should have defended him
but the fact that but when he seems to
have a habit of doing that he certainly
does he's a habit of hiring dumb people
too like then calling them amazing and
then throwing them under the bus oh i
love
this one he does so many different
sessions with cohen with yeah
that's yeah that's a that is that is the
trump administration
it's his job no he should have fired a
lot more people he didn't fire people
that's the problem
so look i think you know whether you
like
flynn or whatever when it comes to the
doj
saying we're gonna drop it and a judge
started prosecuting
that's scary man look i don't i don't i
don't i don't i'm i'm
uh rather uh anti-authority authority
i've never been a fan of the fbi going
back to the days of occupy wall street
where they wrecked them
all the time and it became increasingly
weird to me how many of the people i
knew at occupy became defenders of the
intelligence agencies
sure more broadly speaking
why do you think that in a federal
government where trump has exerted
quite a bit of control he's got a lot of
his own appointees like why does he
still run into so many problems with so
many of these agencies
why it doesn't seem like nobody in the
white house even the only people that he
puts there sometimes don't seem to be
taking his side on anything
he doesn't know how to work the system
he he does not know how government works
and he can't make it work i think you
know with people like trump who are
business people when you run a business
for the most part you're an
authoritarian
your business your rules you're the boss
you can fire and hire within certain
confines and certain laws why
is it that so when you say that i feel
that 100
but another important thing about being
a business owner whether you are a
supervisor a manager
a district manager or whatever or the
owner do you never ever ever ever ever
can pass the buck
you can't do it if you're supervising a
shift and your manager comes to you and
your manager is like what happened
on this shift you would never as a
supervisor it was that employee it was
that employee because
it would be your responsibility trump's
the boss every single time yeah
why is it yeah all the time trump will
not accept responsibility for anything
it's either the deep state is after him
the democrats are after him the fbi is
after him the doj is after him
even when he's going running through his
own appointees and a lot of these
institutions over and over and over
again
i agree trump's trump's got a habit of
when
there are certainly circumstances where
he has people to blame and there are
certainly circumstances where he should
just
be a good leader saying the buck stops
with me
i should have done better and if this
person failed is is irrelevant because
i'm the one who needs to steer this ship
for somebody that's not trump has been
so
ineffectual as a leader so then i guess
moving i disagree on that
what what why what do you think are some
of these like chief accomplishments i
guess under this administration i mean
the economy was
uh smashing in 2019 jim cramer the best
members of our lives
which was from 2013 onwards oh it was
dramatically different i mean barack
obama said you'll need a magic wand to
reach four percent growth and then when
trump did it he started laughing at him
i don't know what barack obama said all
i know is that everybody can look at the
economy from 2013 on we were smashing
all-time highs consistently
all right under under donald trump
growth was better unemployment was way
lower it was
good unemployment continued to fall
mainly as a result of like federal
reserve money i'm not a policy but
for sure and definite spending there's a
lot of bad things too yeah but uh jim
cramer the best numbers of our lives
i don't know i'm not like anything
kramer says by the economy seriously
he's entertainer on tv i don't know what
kramer is i'm just i'm from trump
economic policy it doesn't really seem
like he's done much in terms of being an
effective leader in terms of like
passing like awesome legislation
oh he's the president he doesn't do that
well or championing awesome he promised
a lot
dude the first two years under trump
with the republicans were complete and
total failure
i think the republican party is mostly
sure but again
one of the chief things that we elected
trump for was him talking about how he
can bring people together and get them
to work on things
seems like he's been more divisive than
ever first couple of years for trump
completely awful trump divisive he's
been quite a bit
the last few years there's uh mostly in
the past year there's been a couple
things
because i i said in january i will never
vote for this man then the riots
happened
and when riots went to got close to my
family
and i saw what the democrats were doing
it really made trump look good by
comparison in a lot of ways so that's
that was so you're a single issue voter
because riots happened
uh actually i've literally said that for
sure the uh
so i've got uh i've got family
who are incapable of defending
themselves and when the riots broke out
in chicago
and the leadership was it was it was
insane i mean one alderman was talking
to the mayor lightfoot
saying that she was directing the riders
to the neighborhoods and she was nuts he
was cussing at her and screaming
and i got i get calls from my friends
and family saying you know 60 miles west
of chicago the writers were showing up
and nothing was being done about it
do you don't think that under do you
think it's possible that under different
federal leadership
maybe the rights would have looked a
little different or do you think they
would have played out the exact same way
instead of a president that was
constantly deriding the movement and
constantly
that's irrelevant you don't think that
matters at all i know it doesn't matter
because i was at the start of black
lives matter
when when when these things erupted it
was under barack obama that i got to
witness the national guard pouring into
ferguson
sure i got the blm shots but the blm
protests and any rights of current obama
were a pittance compared to what
happened under trump these were the
largest
large largest scale riots maybe in the
history of the world maybe
so you're saying trump is responsible
for the rights but not the economy even
though the rights and the economy both
start under biden i mean
that's because trump can't say good
words and make the economy do certain
things why couldn't obama solve it why
didn't obama solve it during his term it
was 2011 when this started
by 2016 he did nothing to stop this
problem trump or obama couldn't do much
of anything
obama couldn't even get his own supreme
court pick through trump can't do much
of anything because he's getting blocked
left
and right he's loaded the federal
judiciary he sure did mcconnell did
trump sure trump controlled both halves
of government and was on the executive
branch
and now it's the supreme court how is it
like how is it let's give a man so much
and yet he claims to have so little at
the end of the day what more did he need
trump's not a republican
the republican party in 2016 when they
controlled the the upper and lower
chambers
they were established they were both
unified on some issues
for instance repeal and replace health
care why what happened with that
yeah there the republican party is trash
and trump doesn't know how to work this
and he didn't have the support he needed
so listen listen the point is
i'm not i'm not going to blindly defend
obama or trump
i think the responsibility uh uh with
the riots fell under trump and guess
what
trump had the dhs deputized state and
local police in portland
and started arresting the rioters and
giving them federal charges to the point
where they started running they started
posting blogs saying
like get out of your houses because the
fbi is coming to give you charge
comparable to the charges that were just
dropped to the state level
when obama was in charge and the riots
were happening he said if i had a son
he'd look like trayvon
and then for the next four years because
i covered this i was in i was in
ferguson for a year and a half back and
forth flying in and out as the riots
progressively got worse
and it was then when darren wilson got
acquitted i watched the whole street of
west florida go up in flames
with trump we had coveted lockdown which
was implemented for the most part by
democrat governors
and trump opposed it for the most part
republicans republican governors opposed
it
when the riots broke out trump said i'm
gonna shut it all down
and yet the riots under trump were like
50 times worse than the riots under
obama
yes because a combination of the
lockdowns and the pent-up rage going all
the way back into the obama
administration
any of that rage might have come from
the way that trump talks about any of
these issues definitely
sure sure but but what i'm talking about
is
when the riots happened there's a
combination of things it's not just the
riots it was you know
in the last several months trump was
like trying to pull trips out of
afghanistan i started
clapping i'm like do it do it bring it
on and then uh
the syria stuff too finding about
finding out how they lied i got the
defense one article outgoing syria envoy
admits hiding u.s troop numbers
to trick the american people into
keeping soldiers in the middle east
i was like we didn't need to trick them
trump wanted to do it the entire time as
well he's talked about running syrian
oil fields like you
know trump initially tried to pull all
our troops out and then there was a
revolt between the democrats and
republicans saying
you can't do this so then trump in
hilarious fashion whether it's good or
bad
said all right we're going to keep a
couple hundred soldiers in here to guard
the oil fields
and then all the anti-war progressives
just like started laughing and face
palming like this dude just blurts out
what the american like empire is doing
when he brags about selling weapons to
saudi arabia for their
their cons their war with yemen it's
like this dude is admitting
the war machine exists and it was it was
it was sure but there's also
the same guy that talks about killing
terrorists and their families and
everything too like
obama did mama literally did i i don't
think at the same level that trump has
been doing again the first
the first four years of trump's
administration have seen more bombings
than any other country we still have
wars going on in every single
country that we did when obama left
office you know trump is one of the
i think the first president what like
four decades who didn't start a new war
well that's because there's not many
countries left to go to whoa
i mean there literally are there of
course you know uh
but he didn't do it and that's great but
he's he's not pulling back he's
continued the wars we still have troops
in afghanistan iraq syria and
um with him trying to remove it like i
literally have the defense one article
they lied to him to keep the troops in
syria
that like i've never been more angry in
my life when i heard this i i will have
to read this article i'm very curious on
how the commander-in-chief just
unless he it's possible because he's
speaking to read the intelligence
reports
or they gave him they they lied to him
they gave him bunk information i don't
know how to put it
they they they because maybe they
couldn't fit it in like the crayola
crayon
there was no straight up intelligence we
were always playing shell games to not
make clear to our leadership how many
troops we had there
jeffrey said in an interview the actual
number of troops in northeast syria is a
lot more than
the roughly 200 troops trump initially
agreed to leave in 2019.
they lied to the american people to keep
us involved
in these these quagmires in the middle
east when trump was trying to end it
trump's administration has also been
involved in lying to the american people
for instance when he made it harder to
report
um the number of bombings that have gone
on when he's obscured i don't think
we've gotten a
report of the troops on the ground
release since february i think that they
stopped publishing those monthly reports
like
they've made it harder to get
information out of the administration
related to bombing just
this idea i mean like this may be a
particular thing that happened in syria
but the idea that trump is some peaceful
guy that just wants to get us out of all
the wars i don't think he's a peaceful
guy i think he's desperate for votes
sure and i'm like i'll take it when
trump says the american people hate the
wars and that's true
he says i'll get the troops out and then
the the the machine the establishment
the deep said what we're going to call
it
we must keep our troops in the oil
fields but he still
is engaging in all of the classic war
hockey behaviors if it would have been
hillary clinton or barack obama or
biden that would have killed suliyamani
i think the right would have erupted
like oh wow
of course you're totally corrupt
absolutely when we're still making these
multi
you know massive figure deals to saudi
arabia for bombs when we're still
involved in stuff in yemen i think that
people like
would still be yeah i i just i i don't
if i don't see anybody that like um
i'm not going to sit here and defend
obama's record on foreign policy because
i think there were definitely mistakes
probably one of the worst we've ever had
in the presidency potentially um however
uh this idea that somebody like i don't
like warhawks so i'm voting for trump
and his foreign policy is just that's
crazy to me
like how many troops out of the middle
east but that's not even what he did he
didn't he tried and
he tried several times while he was
trying to escalating tensions across
the entire world with so many other very
problematic like he almost supported a
coup
in in uh in venezuela i think when he
kept trying to recognize
uh we're not venezuelan i'm sorry in
bolivia when he kept trying to democrats
did that too yeah regardless they kept
it as well he
sure he warmed up he heaton are really
hot and heating uh he
uh troubled our relationship criticized
for the same thing sure
no you can't though but because we're
all in favor of when biden hasn't talked
about that but even if that was true
even
first of all bias published tons of
op-eds talking about how he wants to
give an approach to
uh foreign policy now we can say maybe
he's lying in all of that sure
however like so so we have a risk that
everything that biden has said on
foreign policy
might be a lie which is possible but we
know that trump is going to continue the
same disasters foreign policy that has
been
you know a staple of american voters for
the last 20 years of course is true
trump just purged the pentagon
leadership in order to force a
withdrawal from afghanistan
well we'll see if it happens because
he's been talking about withdrawal from
afghanistan since the day he took office
and they were refusing and they were
lying to him
i just he's the this is the one area
trump is the commander-in-chief if he
can do anything it's moving troops
around
if he had the political will to do it it
would be done i will take
an incompetent attempt at pulling our
troops out several times
over the legacy of the obama biden
administration
with everything they did extrajudicial
assassinations
the prosecution of more journalists and
whistleblowers under the espionage
espionage and all other presidents
combined
getting us involved and how do you feel
about why if this is so important to you
um firstly trump shouldn't hard and
assange snowden yeah why he has
absolutely any effort to do that at all
i know and he should and trump has also
been constantly battling the media as
well saying he's gonna open up libel
lawsuits he's gonna start threatening
them with with uh
uh suing them he's gonna publish mean
things about them he's right he's right
that we need to
uh overturn times v sullivan completely
think we have to
you know you know times sullivan is i
know very well so i'm very important to
what i do as a content creator it
established the uh
um the malice standard i believe or the
actual actual malice for uh
defamation it is one of the most
important protections of a public figure
uh in the united states
it allows the media to say whatever they
want about you
yeah and then events it prevents a
chilling effect from being created on
the media where they can't publish an
article about somebody because if
something comes out and it turns out
that that's incorrect
then they could be sued for it no yes
it's it's
times v sullivan it was the actual
malice standard meaning you had to
know you have to knowingly publish false
information about somebody
the reason why that standard is so
important is because right now
let's say that it comes out that um
let's say that somebody's doing an
investigation an investigation on it it
turns out they think that i've killed
like three or four people they've got a
decent amount of evidence blah blah blah
let's say that they published that and
it turns out that i'd ordered somebody
else to do it or it wasn't exactly that
well now i can sue them
for defamation but what what happens
then to me the organization said well
now i never want to report on a public
figure because if i'm wrong i'm gonna
get sued for it i'll have to agree with
you then i'll say we need reform we
certainly do what reform
so right now you have look at covington
right the the arguments for why
uh nicholas sandman they were allowed to
defame him and be wrong was because he
was an involuntary public figure which
which gave them the times of
the sullivan standard they settled in
fact a lot of the a lot of the cases
the right will tell you a celebration
these 250 million dollar lawsuits were
settled they won
they won probably some people said
nuisance fee maybe a little bit more
meaning
it was cheaper to just pay them out not
deal with it sure but a lot of the
challenges that were brought forward
were dismissed because
involuntary public figure we need a
better standard than this
look i g you're i think you're right i
think i should walk back what i said
because i probably was wrong in that
initial statement because
the assumption is in good faith if i
read a news article from defense one
that says
jim jeffrey did x and i then report that
that shouldn't be i should be able to be
sued for that if it turns out defense
one was incorrect sure
but that's not what we're seeing now
what we're seeing now is like the
today show published outright lies about
me and masked it with
with framing device language and what am
i supposed to do to go up against
nbc universal when they put my face on
the today show
and claimed i was pushing conspiracy
theories which was just total bs
i can't do anything about it sure i i
don't know specifically which conspiracy
theories that they claimed
they claimed that because i reported on
the
foxbus article about seth rich i was
pushing a conspiracy theory
that seth rich leaked uh documents to
wikileaks which then got picked up by
other outlets who claimed
i was claiming that seth rich was
murdered because he leaked did they just
all start lying and playing this game of
telephone i can't do anything to stop
sure 50 000 websites all riding garbage
it's impossible that is frustrating i
can't acknowledge that as somebody
that's also been maligned publicly but
from we were talking a little bit before
the show for a bunch of insane stuff
that people talking about me
um it does suck but it's one of those
things um
i don't think i want to get into
citizens united one of those rulings not
a fan of that
sure it's one of those rulings that's
rough but the other side of it
i think looks worse can we have some
kind of reform i don't think
i don't know it's hard because the
problem is that so the reason why that
actual mileage standard exists is to
avoid
what's called a chilling effect right
and the idea is that like people are
going to stop publishing things about
powerful public figures if they feel
like they can just get sued for
publishing something they don't like to
read right now right so if i want to sue
you for defamation i need to be able to
prove
like that you knowingly public which is
almost an impossible standard to me
which is the problem yeah but the
problem is that um
so the flight is the solution for you oh
yeah okay go ahead you should be able to
sue
and if you can prove that what they
publish was false they must issue a
retraction
you can do that but uh doesn't exist
right well i'll take a uh
a hot take here that i'm sure the
majority of your audience's screen most
media outlets will
retract stories that are completely
totally apparently false it's not true
i i could be wrong but i feel like if
you would actually email anybody that
published a certain story i worked for
these companies
sure and i i've been in the slack chats
with these conversations you know what
they say
just wait for it to go away i was in i
was in a meeting were you in slight
chats for for what breitbart in the
daily caller or
because abc news abc and cnn these guys
abc
news that's why you know i worked for
for abc news and univision correct sure
and i was in the slack chats where they
said
wait for it to go away don't don't don't
talk about it we don't want to get
called out for what we do
it's i guess it's just interesting
because on any story that i read that's
like more than a week old you'll usually
always see that they are updating
articles or they are clarifying
information did you know do you know do
you know that stealth edits are so
frequent that an mit project was born
called news diffs to track
how often news articles from every major
publication surreptitiously change the
content of their articles
what is it supposed to when when news if
linear times issues a statement right
and they say betsy kitty
is you know a white cat okay and then it
turns out she's actually both white and
black
okay they would say correction update
editor's note a previous version that's
article set x sure they don't do that
99 of the time it's called stealth
editing
and a website was created called
newsdisk to show you everything they've
done
and there are some seriously messed up
things you can track where news outlets
publish overt lies the story goes viral
and then a day later completely changed
the article destroying all the evidence
that ever existed
well things can get archived now i'm
very interested in seeing articles like
that i guess i just can't think of
anything often i can give you a specific
example where
dave weigel of the washington post
published a completely fictitious story
about kim.com hacking seth rich's gmail
account to plant evidence that he was
the leaker
and then when he got you know i'll just
put it this way to be very careful of
litigation six months later the entire
story was changed to become hypothetical
does it write in the article that they
did did they reflect it accurately in
the text saying that like we've
never said they updated it they never
said they i'll look into it after i just
don't and
it's up on uh i i it's something i've
cited over and over again from
news diffs news.org let me see if i can
i'd have to uh find this specific
article but this was this was a really
really big story i tried for two years
and actually got two retractions from
politico and the daily beast
i tracked them down and i got two two
journalists at each of those outlets
to retract their versions of that story
because the washington post fabricated
the whole thing
happens all the time there wasn't there
was an instance where are you familiar
with blair white
yes do you think blair white is a white
nationalist um
probably not just no not overtly she's
pretty conservative
conservatives haven't followed her
recently so i don't know 100
the verge wrote a hit piece accusing
blair of being a whole bunch of things
she isn't
and when she tweeted i'd like a
retraction they doubled down and added a
whole bunch of out of context bs
like you've been victim to a lot of the
same stuff sure so you you get it
yeah these outlets have no intention of
correcting if they don't have to yeah i
guess when i'm thinking of like
retractions or whatever i'm thinking of
like more like a reporting of a matter
of fact so the um
the kim.com thing is interesting um i
don't know if i would ever push somebody
for a retraction on like uh
you know like you called me a white
nationalist because i imagine somebody
could make that claim about me and i
would say like well i don't think that's
true and they could probably publish
like a paragraph of like well you said
this or this or this or this and it's
like okay well this is more a matter of
interpretation i guess or argument
because some people might think you're a
white nationalist if you ever do like a
particular thing or say a particular
thing
um i guess i'm more interested in like
matters of fact or statements effect
when it comes to like retractions
um rather than like the author said that
this person has this political ideology
which is like a very fluid whatever
thing
that's crazy that's meaningless too it's
really the accusing someone of having an
ideology
well the problem is that a lot of this
stuff becomes so vague like so for
instance like people will call you a
white nationalist if you have like blue
lives matter on your profile
here's my favorite boston globe wrote
that uh this one guy
was a white nationalist and when i
reached out to him and said
whoa whoa i didn't realize this dude was
a white nationalist
i was like is there something he
specifically said because this guy's
only ever talked about like trump and
america and stuff and he said
he's a nationalist right i was like yeah
is he a white guy right okay so he's a
white nationalist
and i was like come on which yes
yes and that was boston globe uh the
problem with news this
i think it's no longer being uh
supported oh no yeah it's from 2012
from 2012 i worked for uh uh vice
i was a founding member of ice news i
worked for fusion which was abc news
univision i worked out of the abc
building in new york
i was like i was told in uh timeout
i was told by the president time out
what that the website timed out it
didn't
uh i'm trying to load the uh articles i
was told uh
in a matter of speaking to lie on more
than one occasion that if there is a
certain bit of news reporting
that's true but will be offensive to our
audience we don't report it
we side with the audience that's what i
was told to do can you give me like a
not a specific example but like what's
like a general example of that what do
you mean by that let's say there's two
guys in the street
proud boy and antifa and antifa walks up
and punches the proud boy in the face if
i reported that antifa punched a proud
boy in the face it would be offensive to
our audience we don't report it
we have to side with the audience which
means when the proud boy got back up and
punched antifa back
that's what we report proud boy attacks
antifa we ignore the previous context
there was a video that went viral from
one of these progressive news outlets
where there was a woman at a trump rally
and she punched a trump supporter in the
face and then got pepper sprayed
they did this clever edit where you see
the crowd and you see her yelling and
then there's a white flash
and then you see her being pepper
sprayed they they did a white flash to
cover up the fact that she punched a guy
in the face
and then was it was sprayed in
self-defense which was i think pepper
spray is much more measured when some
like than
punching someone in the face depending
on but yeah sure right right so these
kinds of things
happen all the time it's basically why
after i left fusion
i tried quitting within a year when i
was like this is ridiculous i don't want
to work for this garbage
they wouldn't let me under contract and
when i left i actually went around all
these big
companies i started working at vice
before they had the vice news vertical
like the dedicated youtube channel yeah
and i had to negotiate with them for
like six months to actually do it they
didn't want to do on the ground field
reporting live or anything like that
eventually they agreed because there
were people like rocco castoro
who's working with me now and some other
people advice who are like listen to
this dude he's doing amazing stuff with
mobile live streaming
they agreed they created this the uh
this you know this news outlet
and then all of these digital media
companies wanted to hire me and were
offering me ridiculous money
i ended up working for abc it was it was
gold
and then golden handcuffs this at first
they said we want to do real news then
they said
no we don't we want to make money
basically so we're going to become a
progressive news outlet
then all the reporting i did which was
conflict crisis and very middle of the
road
gone i tried quitting they wouldn't let
me when i left i basically had every
company saying
come in come have a meeting with us i
got told by a couple of these companies
tell me what you want to do and we will
give you a budget you can do it
and then i saw the people working there
i saw the things they were producing and
i said
what the happened to these people and so
i said no i started making youtube
videos
that's it media is you
you see what happened with barry weiss
in the new york times no
she she was a opinion opinion editor i
think and she quit saying that it's
basically become
awoke fest where it's like write what we
want or else they
they they force the resignation of one
of the opinion editors because tom
cotton wrote that op-ed saying send in
the troops when it came to the riots
okay
that's that's where news is going
they're not gonna they're gonna stealth
at it they're not going to do
corrections and they're ideologically
driven
moral just the gist of my story do you
think that this problem
exists in alternative media or do you
think they're freer from that than
mainstream media
i think alternative media has similar
but slightly different problems
the the main problem which does exist in
independent channels that are
corporations is the editorial guidelines
of you must report x
so at uh the new york times for instance
they had a mandate we're going to focus
on trump
when it was looking like the trump term
was coming to an end they said we're
going to shift now to oh no i'm sorry it
was russiagate
the new york times had um i'm forgetting
the names of dean
barquette bearcat or whatever he said
we're going to focus on russia
once the russia gate was coming to an
end he said okay now it's going to be
trump is racist that's the main driving
force
which means that if you had someone who
had evidence to present that was
contrary to that they were being
mandated at a top-down level not to
report that stuff or not to focus on it
at the very least
that's a problem on youtube however you
exist and i exist
and there's echo chambers for sure
because people like getting their
confirmation bias
but imagine going to one website where
you can hear you
and me at the same time doesn't exist on
breitbart doesn't exist on msnbc
so independent social media or i should
say youtube is
way better than the existing media
infrastructure for sure i guess the
problem that i have with a lot of
alternative media so this would include
people like you or me
or project veritas or any of these other
types of like youtube or online entities
is
it feels like there is no accountability
if you get something wrong
it feels like there is more regardless
of any of the problems that exist in
mainstream media of which i'm sure there
are a plethora
it feels like at least there's some
accountability where if somebody messes
up and it's made public
somebody's going to get fired or
something bad is going to happen as a
result to it
it also feels like a lot of these
companies have a much higher vested
interest in not reporting something
completely factually incorrectly because
if they do they would get a massive
trouble for it and it would hurt their
reputation and the bottom line
whereas it feels like an alternative
media it feels like the goal is to just
report report report report
you can get as much wrong as you want
but as long as you're serving like a
particular ideological narrative it
feels like that ideological drive is
much more prevalent in alternative media
than it is in mainstream media where at
least there's some accountability
together i disagree
uh when i worked for uh well
not not vice at the time but vice
definitely now one of the things i
started seeing
especially working at the abc building
and uh at the univision building both
i worked at both buildings at different
periods completely ideologically driven
they told us outright our audience is
young progressive and that's our goal
that's who we're targeting so side with
them that's it that's your mandate
so when i came to them and said okay
well i don't want to do that they said
well then you can't
you know work with us uh aside from the
fact that they were super racist too
which
you know one of the reasons i don't like
the critical race theory stuff the
critical theory stuff
but that was basically if you're
progressive you're good if you're not
we're not gonna report it so they
basically
is the craziest thing i worked for this
major you know uh
massive media conglomerate and i was
producing content on my youtube channel
with their money and they were like just
put our logo on it
okay because they didn't want to run my
stuff on their channels even though my
content got more views than
anything they produced and when they did
produce stuff and i told them like i can
help you identify the content that is
good
that will go viral funny jokes short
films they didn't like it because
one of the things that got promoted is a
funny funny story i'll try to keep it
simple because i don't want to get
people fired from their jobs or anything
like that
but there was a there's a segment called
open mic massacre
which was produced by fusion where it's
a
cartoon gag on people like like social
justice activists shutting down comedy
clubs or like shutting down comedians
it's a comedian who no matter what jokes
he make makes he gets attacked by the
audience and then protesters show up
it was one of the biggest videos they
ever had and there was a revolt in the
company
at the editorial level they were like
how dare you it's offensive we refuse
and they were like okay we're so sorry
we'll never do this kind of stuff again
and then they then they came to me and
said
you were right it went viral people
loved it we gained a ton of subs but the
employees are furious so you know we
can't do this anymore and i was like
okay i'm gonna be i'm gonna go over
there i'm gonna go to japan i went to
fukushima i did my own thing
i tried quitting within like uh it was
like 13
i've been a year and a month so i went i
met with the president i said cut me
lose bro i don't want your money i don't
need it
and he was like wait wait wait you know
just you know let's have a meeting let's
talk about it
and they really wanted me to just play
ball one day i woke up forty thousand
dollars in my bank
in my bank account and i laughed and i
was like i'm not gonna do what you want
me to do i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
play this game and then finally my
contract ended and they're like have a
nice day
the new york times is now seeing it with
the with with barry weiss's resignation
there was a big story that came out in
the new yorker about slack leaks
slack messages from people who were
basically saying whose side are you on
now's our chance to make all this great
change happen so
what's basically happened is the new
york times is becoming ideologically
driven
now this is you know an nb i believe
they were fun they're funded by nbc
and they're you're familiar with now
this news yeah i've seen there they
tried hiring me
as their first as a third hire too they
tried to hire me i went and had a
meeting with him in new york
refused to do it their president at
vidcon i think this was in 20 it was
2017 maybe
2016. said we have we have brought on
anti-trump activists 2017 at the highest
level
to help us produce our content
completely
ideologically driven not fact-based and
when you say there's no accountability
for people in independent media
i i pulled up a couple stories i don't
want to name these people
but there's two people from buzzfeed in
particular
one guy from buzzfeed was a plagiarist
who got fired and now is trucking along
just fine with all his fans they don't
care
another guy who was caught spying he
went to the financial times he got
caught spying on on uh
zoom meetings and he got hired right
away by another company
there's no accountability for these
people i have seen people i would be
curious to hear how the second guy got
rehired or there wasn't any type of
public outrage for it
but anytime you can find an example of
somebody doing something you know stupid
in a mainstream
like there are people that get fired
over stuff i know that happened during
the russian reporter for instance i
think cnn chop two guys that got like uh
like a couple minor details wrong
related to some election related stuff
in 2016 i think um
but uh the uh the idea that there is any
accountability in alternative media
though
however bad it must be or or you claim
it is in mainstream media it seems like
it's a million times worse in
alternative media like you don't watch
people just make
blatantly untrue claims over and over
and over again on any of these channels
yeah you can i used to blog a lot for
minds and
you can write an article and then have
it get massive traction because it's
really you know popular for whatever
reason and then
once it has 100 million or 10 a million
views you go and you edit the article
and no one knows
and you can change that's the title of
the article you can put the images
change the images
change the entire body of text no
there's no oversight
we have stealth editing and that's so
they imagine that gets abused so there
was an instance at fusion where the new
york times altered an article from
a straightforward news piece about ellen
powell it was
ellen power resigns as ceo in a
statement she said x y and z
that was it it became the third and
fifth high on two different subreddits
the third and fifth highest upvoted of
all time on reddit for any piece of
content
the number three number five the next
day the new york times
stealth edited the whole article turning
it into an op-ed about feminism
in silicon valley saying uh feminist
zero silicon valley bros too
you know the the end of feminism you
know whatever and it was this like
opinion analysis piece about how it was
so unfortunate that she was forced to
resign due to misogyny and stuff
not at all what the original article was
that was a violation of reddit's rules
and it was serious in terms of internet
culture because it was the most one of
the biggest piece of content and one of
the biggest websites in the world
when i went to the managing editor of
fusion
and said hey like i was it was a slack
meeting you know the slack chat we got
all these different editors and i was
like we got a huge story going on right
now reddit's pulling
its third and fifth biggest story ever
about its own ceo which is like a
conflict of interest
because the new york times stealth
edited the entire article turning into
not bad and they said we do that same
thing
and i was like what well yeah don't
report that
are you doing a story don't do a story
as a managing editor don't do a story on
that because we do it too
i gotta end up getting a private message
from the managing editor who said hey
don't don't report that okay don't don't
make a big deal out of it we do the
exact same thing and i was like
if we make changes shouldn't we just
make a new article if it's a new article
shouldn't we put update this article
previously said this or whatever
no no no no we we do that because we we
you know it helps us make money
the link what do you think um what do
you think going forward what do you
think of the wastewater mainstream media
companies accountable what do you think
is like the way forward for that then if
you believe that's a huge problem
i don't think there's a way to i think
social media has incentivized
rapid rage bait content anger uh
i mean you look at like even the
conversations around the fact that you
were going to come here
is people thinking that we were going to
be punching each other in the face
and they're going to make clips saying
you destroyed me or i destroyed you it's
going to be the stupidest thing ever
when i think we have a pretty good
conversation so far
people want there to be some kind of uh
tribal rage bait now i'll i'll i'll
say this all the time and i'll
completely admit i'm i'm biased you look
at i've got a couple different channels
and you can clearly see my my slants and
my leanings and
don't like the democrats for a lot of
reasons we've gone into and
i actually think that's totally fine for
an individual to have an opinion i think
the way your opinion on your content is
100 acceptable and it's cool i think the
fact that kyle kalinski david pakman
uh the young turks along with
conservatives have your opinions
we get things wrong we all do we're all
biased criticize us 100 percent
but aside from the young turks they're
an organization so i'll
i'll remove them from this you don't
have a boss telling you what opinions
you should have
or what you should report on kind of but
sure you do
well to um for better for worse we're
all a little bit
enslaved to the larger corporate culture
right obviously depending on what we
publish we can get
to to an extent right like it's not the
same as having like an editorial manager
or having like a boss literally saying
like we're writing these stories or
whatever for sure right like here's the
mission today i want you to write about
x
and then you might get someone saying
whoa that's not true but i don't want to
lose my job so i'll write it anyway
yeah that it's not to that level yet
right so there is something better in
youtube the problem is we do have an
editorial department and it's the
youtube community guidelines in the
youtube uh
you know uh what do they call it the
review board or whatever these people do
and demonetization you know like so so
actually this is something that happened
to you this is like
that's this is insane i've defended kyle
written house a million and one times
i don't get demonetized for it like we
we make money on the show
through ads talking about kyra retinas
you got stripped from the twitch partner
program over it
sure do you want to talk about that like
exactly what happened with that
um yeah i made a really spicy comment
relating to
defending property from rioters and
people were very upset about that so
long story short to which stripped of
your income that's your editorial
guideline yeah they basically that's
what i was saying earlier right where
when you're saying yeah well we don't
have bosses like kind of
but it depends on who tells you stuff
and so that's true too like you know the
only reason i survive on youtube is
because my opinions are acceptable
sure and there are a lot of people who
have unacceptable opinions who don't
survive so we have our bosses
you know it's not like we're printing
our own newsletters and then mailing
them to people that's
that's safe i guess having our website
is safe so you know well no
but it's not okay
have you experimented with decentralized
or like mesh networks at all
um the problem is the more exotic you
get with your distribution the harder it
is to get advertising dollars so
nobody on bitshoot is making any money
that's the challenge
or torrenting their files i mean people
do actually but it's through
user donations tips yeah it's going to
be a lot yeah you know people make a lot
of money through these crypto video
networks
but that's to me is just a lot of money
too is there might be a few that are
making a ton but
most of them probably like library
andreas is just going on about d live
and stuff
do you live they have a crypto no
library has like a crypto token of mines
has a cryptocurrencies
d-live has their token and then steam it
honestly crypto
and like direct user subscriptions i
think is the future bypassing
advertisers on a mesh network
possible i don't know a lot a lot of
people are making
a lot of money doing uh like patreon
style stuff
but i'll tell you there there there is
an inherent problem in all of this
is that people will choose to just watch
me or just watch you
and a lot of people will say i don't
like him or i don't like destiny
and then they're only going to get their
opinions from one person instead of
potentially an organization with an
editorial department and different
opinions in the op-ed section so sure
that's why i like you know i invite
people on who i disagree with
and then i get punished for it it's it's
it's
you know it really comes down to
building an audience around uh people
who
appreciate hearing a different opinion
or a disagreement
that's why like a lot of people get mad
that i'll often
let an opposing view chinese talk a lot
there's a few periods where i just sat
back and you explained everything you
felt and it's like
you know that's your opinion i can't
tell you your opinions are wrong it's
your opinion
there are instances where i can bring on
someone like enrique tario the proud
boys
and everyone will cheer me on for
letting him talk then i'll bring on
someone like vosh and
people will get mad at me saying don't
let him speak
but my goal is like look if people don't
want to hear
you know ideas they don't like then i
guess you can't come to this channel
because i i want to continue bringing on
people who have
you know dissenting views from me or
different opinions because it's a
problem
that if people only watch just my one
channel where it's just me talking or
they only watch
you know any leftist channel then we're
polarizing
what i'm curious what responsibility do
you feel you have to your audience to
disseminate messages that you
agree with so let's say for instance so
your
um your youtube channels got a lot of
views i think over 50 million a month
so between at least so let's there's
three channels oh i didn't even know
about the third one so
yeah so there's there's this there's tim
cass and tim cass news tim cass news
uh at its peak uh got 50 i think 55 or
so million
and then tim cass got 20 and then tim
casserole got like 26. gotcha
the election's over views are going down
sure
so let's say that you have somebody that
comes on and i'm
i'm from what i know of you you don't
seem to be a white nationalist or
anything like that
let's say you break the opposite yeah so
let's say you bring somebody on and that
person has those types of views and you
platform that person
you feel like they profit or they grow
from the exposure that they get on your
show do you feel like you have any
responsibility in terms of like
messaging or in terms of
growing that person's platform or what
do you feel no i mean i'm growing your
platform to an extent
there's probably a lot of people who are
discovering you and thinking i might
disagree but i'll hear what he has to
say and stuff like that
i can't i can't control that more
importantly though
it's uh i don't bring on random nobodies
like i'm not gonna find some just like
neo-nazi lurking in the corner and be
like come to my platform and build a
career off this
sure usually it's like enrique tario uh
he's he's
uh i guess he just i don't know what
people call they call him afro cuban or
whatever he's black
he's the chairman of the proud boys he
was in the news i mean joe biden
mentioned the proud boys i'm like we
should bring him in just for reference
on this do you think that the pratt boys
is like a white nationalist leaning
organization
okay okay i think there there are people
who are white nationalists probably
associated with the proud boys but the
proud boys have disavowed
and i think what enrique said was if
they find out someone is they'll boot
them they'll boot them out
and recently the proud boys did a joint
thing with black lives matter it's like
it was kind of surprising they uh i
think it was in salt lake city
black lives matter organizer came out
with proud boys and they issued a joint
message of like what they agree upon
even though they really disagree on most
things
they find what's the problem i stand for
exactly the proud boys are western
chauvinists so they believe
west is best that's like really the gist
of it they say west
what do we mean by that uh america
american values traditional christian
conservative kind of issues uh
nationalism but they're they're actually
fairly classically liberal
um okay you can look i haven't dug too
much of the broadway stuff just
generally because i just don't care that
much but a lot of times i hear people
talk about like
western values usually is like a kind of
a dog whistle for
white issues or identitarian stuff
oftentimes
but there's an i think there's an
overlap white nationalists of course
agree with a lot of those things but the
proud boys don't agree with the white
nationalists
there were people who are white
nationalists in the proud boys and then
the proud boys booted them out
i think the proud boys are worthy of a
ton of criticism i've criticized them
quite a bit
we had enrique on we we talked about a
lot of people were like they said i was
harder on him and alex jones than i was
on vosh and i'm like
vash and i were like yelling like
raising our voices at each other i don't
know like four hours
yeah and it was like four hours you know
so but uh
if somebody is is is relevant in some
capacity we bring them on
a lot of people want me to bring on some
america first type individuals
and i'm like i'm i will but like i'm not
banning people for myself just got to be
relevant i don't want to just randomly
grab somebody and be like
here you go you know what i mean sure uh
you're
i i would actually say you're not
controversial of course they're
i would like there's no grand uh uh
you there's articles about you getting
banned there are people on the left
saying how dare you defend this guy
you know twitch get kind of punished you
and stuff sure there's a fraction of
there's a faction of people who are like
this guy's controversial
but for the most part i think you're
just like you know another personality
i don't think either of us are
particularly controversial we're just
internet people with opinions who do our
shows
enrique taro is controversial they're
not trying to be disrespectful he is
he's the chairman of the proud boys
they're brought up in a presidential
debate sure people have strong opinions
about him
you know so yeah man
i get to talk about dmt a lot
i'll talk about it's craziest stuff as i
can but if it gets like two like youtube
century is crazy tim will be like ah let
me drop the hammer on this
no what are you talking about it's a
good vibe if i talk about the federal
reserve or if i want to go into
no no no no no no i'm not i'm not i have
no concern about youtube coming after
you
i disagree oh personal oh
when black lives matter were riot when
the writers were out you said it was the
federal reserve and i'm like
these people are not we were talking
about riots
and why they were angry and useful class
issue you said it was the federal
reserve and i was like
they're not writing over the federal
reserve do they don't even know how it
works or what it is we talk about a
little that it's a
more of a class i think we were talking
about that earlier tonight too that's is
really a classic
is a race issue but then the class issue
is derived from ancient racism
combination of factors long story short
is there anything else we should hit on
or we should go to super chats
we're a little we're about half an hour
over yeah no big deal for me we got a
ridiculous amount of super chats oh
wait actually hold on i'm curious so i
will ask because you asked me why i
supported biden yeah what so what are
what are some positives i guess going
forward for why you would support trump
i know assuming the election is over
but like if you had voted for him all
right for 2020. why would you support
him over a nobody over a biden
presidency
critical race theory ben specifically
targeting uh it wasn't overtly critical
race theory it was
specific trainings having to do with
segregation based on race which was a
violation of title seven in the 1964
critical race there yeah what else so uh
trump's repeated attempts to withdraw
troops
from afghanistan which is continue to do
even after losing the
the election and uh look i said earlier
this year i wouldn't vote for the guy i
didn't care i didn't vote for him in
2016.
i said earlier this year that what would
get me to vote for him is if he
issued an executive order
decriminalizing or at the very least
ordering the dea not to prosecute
marijuana-related defenses okay
pardoning non-violent drug offenders
with a review because some people pled
down and they pleaded down
and uh appointing tulsi as national
security adviser yang as economic
advisor
withdrawing from afghanistan he's my guy
that's a pretty tall order sure
none of these things happen to be fair
right like fair in the sense like that
would ever happen or well like none of
these things he didn't do any of these
of course of course like it was like the
wish list of like
i'm not going to go over i think the
media lies about him i don't think he's
nearly as bad as
like you ever say that segment where
msnbc the woman said that he's talking
about exterminating latinos
like that's the level of like lunacy a
lot of the russiagate stuff was so
infuriating the ukraine gate stuff was
infuriating
so often i find myself as in one of
these positions where for a long time it
was like stop making me defend the guy
because i was like ragging on him quite
a bit in the first few years about
foreign policy for sure
for broader policy things related to say
because you said you were a fan of
universal healthcare i think you brought
that up i think you think that
climate change is probably real climate
change is a big problem right yeah
definitely
so for like broader things like this or
for more assistance i don't know how you
feel about like
general redistribution or welfare like
maybe like free school or something um
not a free college not a fan of free
college mostly because uh
the system as it stands today doesn't
work so uh i would say
i am in favor of it it's a difficult
position i'm in favor of uh
universal health care in some capacity
i'm not in favor of banning private
health care
that's right it's like a risk it's like
you know a restriction you line up with
biden perfectly there yeah yeah
uh i am for people getting universal
education after we dismantle and reform
and rebuild the education system sure
okay because it's completely broken sure
uh i think
uh i think progressive tax system is a
good thing i think
we need to make sure that we do what we
can to protect
the working-class individuals from the
vulturous predatory elites
and the wealthy top 10 billionaires and
all that stuff
it feels like broadly speaking feels
like you align more with like the
democratic
foundation or platform than you do with
the republican one what it used to be
you don't think that any uh or do you
just think that biden is lying on all of
his proposals
absolutely i voted for barack obama in
2008 with a smile on my face i was so
excited okay george w bush all the
protests i was marching in them
watching these music videos and
everyone's saying war is bad bushes
hitler and all this stuff and they were
like barack obama
he's going to make sure we have health
care he's going to help the poor he's
going to fix these problems he's going
to bring our troops back man you got to
vote for him and i was so excited and i
walked in and i was like this is so cool
these people
like we found a cause i can't believe it
barack obama broke
through it was going to be hillary
clinton and then this guy comes out of
nowhere he's like a regular guy from
chicago
he's from chicago do you think that we
did get some like universally
amazing things under obama so for
instance the aca definitely wasn't
perfect
but definitely it screwed me really
really bad all of a sudden
i was having questions with like uh the
the the environment the individual
mandate so regardless of
sure so regardless of your personal i
guess effect by do you think that
overall do you think that the aca was a
step in the right direction or do you
think it was a mistake
not like that i think it was like 13
million more it's nuanced right like the
the uh
the uh um pre-existing condition stuff
yeah excellent must exist and i'm glad
that we're at a point now where even
trump is saying and putting an executive
order
forcing companies to pay out instead of
trying to drop people because they make
a claim and stuff like that yeah yeah
i do i can't stand these insurance
companies i think we need we need
dramatic reform across the board on so
much stuff
uh it feels like from the democratic
platform based on what obama did with
the aca and was trying to do the ac it
feels like that's more a step in the
right direction than republicans that
are just completely trying to dismantle
all form of government intervention and
healthcare but for me like most people
we we have opinions where we weigh
certain things more than we weigh others
sure so that's healthcare what about
like not for me
healthcare wasn't one of those issues
young strapping viral lead it didn't
really mean that much to me sure but
when they said i had to pay a fine
because i couldn't afford health care
then i i made enough money to where i
had i i should have bought health care
but i couldn't
i ended up homeless i have uh uh
i'll be vague with this but someone who
is very close to me in my life
has been forced to pay was forced to
force to pay the fee
and was like essentially destitute
because
it was like piling up other taxes i
think they ended up owing money gotcha
that's interesting i
don't know obviously their exact
financial position but there were huge
exemptions made for people that were
even above the poverty line it would
scale off i think depending on how much
were made but it's possible that
living in a city making a certain amount
of money not being able to afford your
rent and food at the same time
because maybe under federal poverty or
not under federal poverty but for a city
you might be sure and so what happened
was
their tax bill that they have a debt to
the irs for the but trump got rid of it
i don't know what happened but that was
like
so for so for generally speaking on
things like health care
it seems like we kind of align more on
the democratic platform than the
republican one
what are the republicans doing trying to
take it all apart they
failing well they got rid of the mandate
which means that it's going to continue
i like collapse probably
you know i tried to go to the doctor
earlier this year and i couldn't because
of the aca
and uh i was literally told the
insurance you have
bars you from coming to our facility and
i said it's fine i'll pay cash they said
no you don't understand
you can't come here wait how no joke i
don't
i have no idea weird i never i i don't
have insurance and i've never had
problems getting into any hospital ever
you don't have insurance i don't have
insurance because i do have insurance
they said under the aca
because you have insurance you are not
allowed to come to this facility even if
you pay cash
i called like three different uh um like
uh just like
general physician facilities or whatever
and they all told me the same thing
sorry figure out where it is so i went
to urgent care and i was able to pay
cash
that's interesting not a fan of that
yeah but like even
because unfortunately i can't speak your
personal stories you may have had like
bad
personal experiences with anything
related to healthcare system but i mean
like it did ensure like over time
but the problem is what the aca was
basically it was like this ridiculous
fake compromise where instead of
actually creating a system that would
i i think there was good intentions
behind it the idea was like how do we
get to a universal healthcare standpoint
or at least a public option
right and so it was okay well what if we
make everyone buy insurance and then
they pay a fee if they don't and all
that did was make sure the massive
insurance companies who still don't care
about you were able to keep ripping you
off
well so kind of so they there were
provisions under the aca that made it
for instance
like you're um the total amount of money
that you take in like a certain percent
has to be paid out in the form of claims
you can't have like 50 percent of your
costs you're going to administrative
costs like there were a lot of good
things that were made to bring
those companies into line um i guess i'm
just when i look at like the aca
in a lot of ways sucked but in some ways
the ac was amazing or like again
it insured a lot more people but costs
continued to rise in healthcare
for some people that were on the border
of not qualifying for those like poverty
line provisions and not making that much
like the working poor
you got absolutely destroyed by the aca
and the mandate for sure um so it
definitely should have went farther but
it just it feels like when i look at the
difference between like a republican
having office performer years or a
democrat
it feels like going farther is so much
more likely under a democratic
administration than a republican one in
the end i'd rather have
nothing then broken i guess so i'd
rather
be in a situation where i'm responsible
for myself than whatever mangled garbage
we ended up how do you say that to
somebody that has like a type 1 diabetic
someone who threw no fault of their own
has like
it's either they have a pre-existing
condition if they don't have some sort
of like i'm not voting for other people
okay i mean but it's the reality i don't
know like
like you mentioned my anecdotes you
can't speak to them i can't speak to
other people and i don't know i don't
have those experiences
health care is not the biggest issue for
me and it wasn't thing i ever really
paid attention to it didn't affect me
okay sure i'm sorry i'm just curious
foreign policy on the other hand
was i come from a family of uh many
military veterans
i've had uh in-laws and direct family
in the military and so foreign policy
always mattered to me
even before that uh my dad my dad was
a former marine my grandpa was served he
was in world war ii
foreign policy mattered a whole lot i
grew up in chicago hated the wars
hated the waste of money thought that we
were spending money overseas doing
nation building and this is like i'm a
teenager now
iraq afghanistan's in full swing obama
comes along it was a lie it was a
complete lie
so for me the issues were always around
uh like foreign policy was a big issue
most people don't care
they don't care at all but i was
concerned about war conflict and i
and and that played into i started
covering conflict crisis
civil unrest i went to a bunch of
foreign countries that's always been in
the front of my mind
so barack obama i don't care if
he got you health care you know why
because he blew up kids
he he blew up an american citizen for i
believe it was four
he was arrested arresting whistleblowers
when it comes to foreign policy do you
give obama any credit for things like
flying relations with cuba or like the
iranian nuclear deal like steps towards
normalizing relationships like iran do
you think that any of that was important
uh
i would say to the extent that i know of
them yeah probably
i think the the what he ended up doing
with iran wasn't a net positive
i think it was it was an attempt because
it didn't result in the net
we still have nothing changed well even
even
unchanged because now we've rolled back
the deal of course but before before
trump we still
had uh intense conflict sanctions it
wasn't
moving well we were in the process of
easing sanctions right like like people
talk about the boat loads of cash right
we unfroze a lot of the assets that we
were holding
um and and i think we were taking steps
towards like depending on how many years
have gone by like
using a lot of the sanctions there there
was a lot going on in that direction
with obama pertaining to iran and it was
conflict cutter turkey pipeline which
you brought up earlier on
there was a a report i don't know if
this actually went public maybe i'm uh
i'm going to leak some information that
i probably should because the store was
never published but
iran was smuggling in gold through
turkish airlines there was a whole bunch
of
worker rounds that were being granted to
them that's not necessarily
surprising but i mean like that's also
just kind of the nature of the middle
east
we have our ally turkey that was like
the reason why isis was making so much
money is because they were just driving
those trucks
north right into turkey and just selling
the oil and driving on back so
and then also you know we talked about
like yemen like it would be nice it's
like okay well we're done here
and then all of the gulf states will
look at us like excuse me what do you
mean you've done here like
hello where you're most important like
group cluster of alice in middle east
not not to excuse obama but just to like
it sucks the all of the middle east and
even to some extent and i would even say
publicly like i'm not going to blame
trump for what's going on in the middle
east either i will be critical of some
of his actions
whether it's the turks talking about
running syrian oil fields or anything
oh yeah another abandoning the curds to
the turks um that like that stuff is bad
but um i i guess for me like my my two
the reason why i bring up health care
for politics because
my two favorite accomplishments under
obama was i think that the aca was
historic
what we ended up getting the compromise
kind of sucked like undoubtedly but it
was historic in terms of moving that
direction and finally joining the rest
of the oecd countries with having some
sort of public health care
um and then working to normalize
relationships with iran was unbelievable
if that would have been something that
would have continued into the future
like thawing relations in that part of
the world and getting the gulf states to
just calm down with
that conflict like i'm not convinced
obama was was was doing that
and i think in the past few months trump
has these historic peace agreements
between
arabic nations and israel and it's
massive
it is yeah you know you know it was you
know what really kind of offended me and
it's very
like i don't take offense to many things
but it was when trump crossed into the
dm
across the dmz into north korea to me
that was like i was welling up i was
just like
wow because but all that was horrible it
was amazing it was one of the most
beautiful things worst things that's
ever happened
i'm korean
because because donald trump with no
security
with no security crossed into north
korea and a tremendous
sign of good faith giving me hope that
there was actually trust enough where
the president theoretically
or straight up risked his life they
could have just
that you know that the north korean
soldiers grab south korean soldiers and
pull them into north korea
trump freely walked into the country
with no security shook hand smiled and
walked back and i was
that was huge to me that's great but at
the end of the day all we did was we had
a few friendly conversations with kim
they continued working on their nuclear
program we made some concessions to them
absolutely nothing happened like it and
it set back like
work in that part i disagree okay well i
mean japan and south korea disagree
i mean i mean for a variety of reasons
but
south korea uh my understanding has been
working towards an agreement with north
korea that's been improving for quite so
they have been yeah
i thought it was incredible to see the
president of the united states make that
move
i guess it was just sad that like for a
guy that talks about making deals so
much and for an iranian deal that
we had gotten concessions out of that
he'd completely dismantled
we went and we talked to north korea we
got zero concessions out of them and
they expanded all of their training
programs and everything
they did they did they did bad in a lot
of ways and they they played trump but
uh
i think that was tremendous i think it's
the kind of thing that needs to happen
uh whether or not it would have
ultimately you know resulted in uh
restoration you know peace in the
peninsula or whatever it's hard to say
but i thought it was a step in the right
direction
so i mean listen man the president of
the united states walking into north
korea with no security is a big deal
yeah i guess i don't really care but
yeah
there's uh uh i didn't really accomplish
much like maybe symbolically it was nice
but um
i i guess um aside from foreign policy
and health care so you don't care much
about health care foreign policies
i hear about health care um let me
clarify yeah i go i think
when i say you don't care about how i
mean it's not like a key voting issue
for you you're not it's not going to
make or break your vote
i think we should have universal basic
level care
if you get you know sick you can rush to
the hospital i'll give you timothy what
you need
you break your hand you go to the doctor
they can set your broken hand if you get
more serious rare genetic disorders that
are very difficult
you know to require more resources
that's where there
there's you know private insurance is
going to kick in to a certain degree
i think we can provide that but it's
going to be so limited and difficult to
get
i think we need some sort of not
necessarily i wouldn't even call it a
public option
it's a hybrid system of there are a lot
of people who
you know kids you see the story they get
the flu they die or diabetics they can't
get insulin
that's the kind of stuff that should be
easily taken care of yeah for sure but
when someone's got like a rare genetic
disorder yeah i don't think anybody is
they are i've had the arguments they
should sure there might be a biden for
the administration that
is coming in the public option is the
most photo which is a multi-pair system
so you still have all your private
health care if you want through your
work or union or whatever and then we
have a public option hopefully for
people that can't afford it problem is
getting there
what getting what do you mean like like
legislatively or like administration
everything everything and
and i don't think it's a good reason not
to try i think uh
with the with this system even bernie
sanders has acknowledged millions of
jobs will be lost in the health care
industry
um potentially yeah it's a dif it's a
problem sure but jobs are never a good
reason to keep any particular thing like
dismantling the military-industrial
complex would cost a lot of private jobs
as well of course right
boeing lockheed martin raytheon like
these
yeah so i mean like there's always going
to be jobs right that's why i'm saying
it's like a good reason to ignore it i'm
saying it's something we have to
overcome for sure
so i don't i don't see uh
a good reason other than like the
argument here from conservatives and
and i respect it is prices would be
cheaper
if we just had free competition in the
marketplace with healthcare
free of the regulations and all that
stuff and to accept i agree
but the problem is i don't like uh i
don't know eileen left
it uh morally and ethically on the issue
so i like the idea that
just because someone works at mcdonald's
doesn't mean they shouldn't be provided
the care to like fix their broken hand
or take care of their kids got the flu
because they can't afford you know
market rates agree
granted the conservatives argue the
market rates would be cheap enough for
them if it was complete and totally free
i don't completely agree i kind of agree
but i
still doesn't seem to work that way any
other part of the world but well i mean
most of the countries have already
instituted some kind of national
healthcare system and it's due to
longstanding like europe
has a lot to do with world war ii and
stuff like that sure i think the market
would price itself
in the sense that if they can't get
customers to pay the bills they'd have
to figure out a way to improve it but
kind of so market forces wouldn't
exactly work that way i oh no i
i right i'm saying like so for instance
like if i could do some surgery and i
could sell it to ten people for a
hundred dollars or just one person for a
thousand dollars it might make sense to
just do the one person ignore them
right but market forces are really good
at setting prices and everything in the
most efficient way to allocate capital
but
when healthcare we don't want to just
allocate capitalism we want to take care
of our citizens
i'm totally for the mixed economy uh i
think the current system is great that's
why i don't like the far left the
socialist stuff
sure like bernie sanders banned private
healthcare i'm like that's crazy yeah
that plan was insane yeah yeah you don't
do that
uh i think the challenge is getting to
this position and uh i also believe in
individual like freedom of the
individual which case as a more
libertarian-leaning person
if you want to implement the system it's
done through cooperation
you have to convince the people we're
going to do the right thing and we're
going to make it work
very difficult task to do and that's the
problem ultimately i think it's the
weakness of
not being an authoritarian who just
imposes it upon people for the good of
the people like i know it's better for
you so we're doing it
in some cases it may be but i don't
think it would i don't think we're going
to be happier living under one person
who thinks they know better than us or a
handful of people
well that's kind of what i mean like if
they impose it on us i mean that's
we kind of voted for it right not
necessarily uh this is the challenge
and i think it's one of the reasons i
love this country it's a republic which
means there's minority
strength that you know you can get a
president who didn't win the popular
vote that's a good thing
because you don't want just the majority
to constantly push a majority opinion
sure but if we're doing something that's
making it through like the house the
senate
and the president assigning it to law
there's a good chance that a majority of
the american people are supporting this
highly unlikely otherwise yeah i'm down
for it and there's always going to be
some minority of the country that's
going to be bullied around
which is because nobody's 100 in favor
of anything so i i think it's an issue
right i agree with you so that's why i
think one of the one of the problems we
have right now is when uh
not to i can't get into the specifics
but you know harry reid did away with
the was it
the filibuster in 2013 allowing for
trump to get three supreme court
justices in with a simple majority
sure this is something this had been
fought with even under bush i think
people have gone back and forth arguing
whether or not the filibuster should
yeah
the problem well you used to need i
guess you needed two thirds to get a
supreme court justice in
uh and then harry reid changed it to 51
simple majority kind yeah for
confirmation
we need wait for what for senate uh
supreme court confirmation
was it supreme court i thought these
were for lower federal judiciary picks
uh my understanding is that's how trump
got three justices in
with 51 votes i think that was only done
under um
for um at the yeah or wait never mind
yeah under the last year of obama yes
mcconnell said you'll regret this yeah
mcconnell was the one that changed it
for the supreme court picks but that had
no no harry reid
are you sure yeah because the democrats
were in the majority and mitch mcconnell
said you will regret this sooner than
you think
i wasn't aware that that was for that i
don't think that was for supreme court
related stuff though that was for lower
federal picks
was is my understanding mcconnell was
the one who first triggered that for
a supreme court nominee under for
merrick garland in the last year of
obama's presidency
perhaps but i know that um uh roll call
says if you don't like the supreme court
blame harry reid
yeah because but that was because of the
threatening of the nuclear option for
earlier
and lower court picks it hadn't been
triggered yet for the supreme court it's
a minor
but um yeah right well but but arguably
those threats
and then funding the filibuster for the
lower court pixel is what led mcconnell
to do it for the supreme court picks
five
i think we it's the best thing in the
world would be needing two-thirds
majority for approval of legislation
it would force the senate
forcing uh the majority to cooperate and
negotiate with the minority
you wouldn't get uh ridiculous far left
or far right or whatever
you'd get them saying we want to pass
this okay well you got to get us to
agree with you and that's good because
it
keeps us so one of the problems we've
had is how polarized and uncompromising
it feels a lot of congress is right now
i think it's better to have no movement
forward than rapid erratic
back and forth you know what i mean yeah
i kind of agree the only problem is that
what happens then is that all of our
movement comes from either executive
actions or the supreme court
which yup which is a problem too yeah um
okay i'm just curious
so for one other issue because so health
care um foreign policy what what's like
a third issue
that you would like and besides the
critical race theory like what's another
thing that like oh like i would support
trump because of this particular thing
um hmm it's tough question for me it had
a lot to do with the riots
absolutely the critical race theory is
huge that may have overtaken
um you know like i said earlier i wasn't
gonna vote for the guy
but i think critical race theory played
a huge role because that's deeply
impacted my life
not just in the sense that there's like
this theory and people believe it but
the practical application of
directly impacted the safety and
well-being of my family and my
experience and the stories i grew up
hate it 100 not the fact that the theory
exists i hate the practical application
so when trump says
you know we're issuing an executive
order probably would have done them well
to read the theory a bit more
i was happy i said wow that's that's
great i don't like this stuff good i'm
glad
biden said he's going to overturn that
and bring it all back that to me is a
nightmare
the democrats were trying to repeal the
civil rights provision in their
constitution with prop 16 in california
i understand that california is one of
the only one of the few states
especially has won
but it's still shocking to me that they
were the democrats all
signed on both like state level and
federal level were like yep we want to
repeal this civil rights provision
guaranteeing you can't discriminate on
the basis of race because we want to and
i'm like
my understanding is that what starts in
california makes its way to the rest of
the country i would not be surprised if
democrats in a few years vote to repeal
the
1964 civil rights act sure yes
uh yeah i guess we'll see
you know why though right um why they
want the right to discriminate on the
basis of race
sure but i feel like i'm almost positive
um i looked this up once for
so i think the supreme court has already
ruled that it is okay to discriminate
against even protected classes as long
as there's a
like a business necessary reason to do
so um so i like uh i looked this up
so hot what acting acting and uh like
why can we have all female gems
you're discriminating against a gender
right just like a predictive class yeah
and the reason is because
actually but they're losing i'm pretty
sure are they because my understanding
is the reason why those did exist was
because the supreme court ruled that in
some cases like if it's business
necessary you can have like an
all-female dream like that's an okay
thing to do it may be for gems but i do
know that there is a bunch of guys who
go around suing ladies night bars
or like lady bars interesting i haven't
heard of that
i do know that they want to do it i
think one of the important parts of that
supreme court case was that um
you are not allowed to have like other
vital stuff going
on in that business that would lead to
that discrimination being negative so
for instance if you had an all-female
gem that's fine
but if that all-female gems started to
host like meetings related to some
business activity well that's not okay
because now you'd be discriminating
against men going i don't know if like
the ladies bar issue is running into
that or whatever but
i just i don't like discrimination
positive or negative
yeah but so anyway long story short that
is a big issue for me i don't like it
uh when trump started coming out against
the riots
i was shocked to see the democrats
supporting it uh either passively or
directly like
defund the police up to me is absolutely
insane sure and i've been ragging on i
reckon cops
frequently like the cops in staten
island who are barring this guy from you
know from
opening his bar to the public even
though he's not running the business
he's just letting him have free drinks
they're violating the first amendment of
the constitution the right to peaceably
assemble it doesn't say for what reason
so the fact that these cops are like i
don't care i'm gonna do it i rag on them
all the time i still think to fund the
places nuts
and now we're seeing crime skyrocketing
and you know a bunch of different places
i'll tell you one of the big issues for
me though was
the the midterm betrayal in my opinion
the moderate democrats who won 31
districts
flipping control the house to the
democrats yeah they said they were gonna
they
they ran on kitchen table issues the
economy healthcare etc they said that
they weren't going to play pelosi's game
and be anti-trump culture warriors
and then they did and they came in and
they said impeachment
and that was the name of the game that
was the big story that's what carried
through
and almost nobody stood up to them i
mean i think the big problem with that
was that
those seem to be the only games that
would gain any traction i think the
problems of the house
under those two years of pelosi the
house passed like record amounts of
legislation
literally absolutely nothing could make
it through the senate so at the end of
the day
i mean like impeachment over whether or
not i'm guessing you probably don't
think the ukraine stops legitimate but
whether or not it was like that was
literally the only stuff they could
actually get through or have any
meaningful impact on in the house
because yeah the european stuff is not
legitimate
okay the ukraine stuff you said all
right did you say iran stuff
ukraine oh yeah okay um that's a whole
other conversation i don't know i know
um but like i mean like they were
passing legislation through the house
but
that's all they can do i think i think a
big issue with like the conversation i
had with vosh and even with you is
different sources of information one of
the things i brought up before
for those are listening before we went
live was like you can find a source that
confirms your bias
and it's like really hard to break
through this and figure out you can do
that yeah
i feel like you can go through
credibility but obviously most people
never will
i i could reinforce whatever opinion you
want to on the internet i pull up
uh it's true yeah uh you know who ryan
long is the comedian
no i don't he he did a bit where he's
like he just basically says
if you like black lives matter you can
say that they're doing good or you can
see their benny like just goes through
all the articles that are like
and these are legitimate new york times
washington post telegraph official times
where they just say contradictory things
and you're laughing seeing like a
different headline every single day it's
the stupidest thing ever
makes it impossible to track what's
going on i'll tell you even with these
lawsuits
like trump wins one then loses one then
appeals one then loses the appeal but
appeals again
and when i say something like i was
talking to someone and i said oh did you
hear trump appealed oh he lost the
appeal no no he appealed again
wait no no i just read today that's like
i don't know which one is which we don't
know where he's at
so so anyway when i look at trump i see
uh not that bad i don't think he's uh uh
i think in terms of foreign policy he's
better
he's he's what did luke say he's less of
a stinky a-hole
than all the other presidents in our
lifetime considering
not starting new wars being the big
factor i haven't followed it too closely
but do you know who's currently being
accused of killing the iranian nuclear
scientist
who trump no i'm asking you i don't i
don't actually know it's real
yeah yeah i wasn't sure if that was with
i've heard people say israel i don't
know if that was like a u.s backing or
assistance right now yeah i don't like
any of that
uh i don't like any of that but uh i
think under
uh i i i kind of the challenge is i'm
watching what trump is doing
right now with the riots that was big
what he's doing with critical race
theory and what he's doing with
at least trying to effectively withdraw
our troops from the middle east
okay i know we get with biden i lived
through eight years of it
so i'm not to vote for that not only
that like i think what biden is is
selling you is snake oil
i know the left says same thing about
trump i think a lot of well no i think i
think trump would continue to do the
things he's doing now i just think
they're all really bad but
like getting our troops out of the
middle east he hasn't gotten our troops
out of the middle east but trying to
he continued trying to do it but he's
escalated tensions all over the world
over the country he did it with bolivia
he did it with venezuela he's done with
cuba he's done with iran and
under and with obama biden they
literally entered a bunch of these
countries
well they entered a bunch of syria kind
of libya
sure and you know
i don't know a lot of things nuts do you
know who sydney blumenthal
is uh talk to me about her he uh
sydney's a guy he's a clinton advisor
from like the 90s and
a really good friend of hillary's and
stuff and so like 10 000 of the emails
that hillary had received was from
sydney
and he had a company called global
ospreys osprey global solutions which
was the arms manufacturing company
so he would email hillary and be like
hey when you get us into iran we want to
set up osprey global solutions to fund
these
this new pro-america government and
hillary be like okay sid and then she'd
pass the email to her advisor and then
she advised obama to take us into libya
basically
he's a he's a you know what would you
call him a gun runner
and a really good friend okay hold on
because my libyan knowledge is not that
expensive but my understanding is that
the u.n had accused and had proof that
in libya gaddafi was like literally
using chemical weapons and stuff against
other people they were like human rights
trust i mean i mean trump is the
government
right like what do you mean trust the
government like trump's barely the
government but i mean like when there's
enough like global
wait do you think that assad ever used
chemical weapons in syria definitely
okay you don't think there are any human
rights violations i didn't say you
didn't i'm just wondering like
when they come and say things you just
like do you just trust them i mean like
when they're not
like a lot of these bodies are like
comprised of like multiple countries and
whatnot i guess it's possible that there
could be
some top-down um behind the scenes
stuff going on i'm just saying i mean
like a lot of these issues come down to
who you trust
i don't i i was unaware i didn't think
it was that contested that there were
human rights abuses going on under
gaddafi
okay there there are people who think
the the like dude the progressive
anti-war leftists
yeah i'm aware of that i don't yeah
they're like it's all made up it's not
real every single bad thing around the
world is the cia and everybody else
exactly exactly yeah no so i i say that
trust in the government thing not as a
digger
you know like when when the us
government comes out and says we did a
thing
it's like i i would say i don't um
but there's occam's razor i guess you
know what i mean sure i would i would
just put it this way i don't trust the
government but i'd support the u.s over
a different country right exactly
exactly sure yeah okay
what was i gonna say oh yeah hillary
clinton man that's the other big problem
with the
with the biden administration he's
bringing back a lot of these same people
and these are just some of the worst
people
imaginable it's true trump did the same
thing which is why i didn't vote for him
john bolton
wow what a mistake the only real reason
i voted for him was like hey maybe he'll
keep trying to get our troops out of the
middle east i'll just vote for it you
know what i mean
i'm not i'm not a maga hat wearing guy
not a flag waving guy
i do think like i said trump is better
than president all the other presidents
of my lifetime for the fact that he
didn't start any new wars
sure i guess no no no no biden has
written a lot about what he wants to do
with middle east related stuff but i'm
not going to be about it it's going to
be going to be kamala harris sure but
it's
that stuff is so difficult because
i mean like love him or hate him love or
hate all the wars
we can't really just leave everything
right agreed
yeah the vacuums and everything created
are it makes it like everything is like
very rough
isis comes back yeah isis or um you know
the
taliban in afghanistan and everything
and but uh
like there's like so many i was just
studying iraq after we went into iraq
basically they first they fired 50
000 civil servants that had worked for
saddam
and this was all these unemployed people
across the country and then they
disbanded the entire iraqi military
and then isis got created the huge
problem with the the
coalition government i think we said in
iraq and i still have no idea why this
happened was when we kicked everybody
out of the government that was part of
that government that part of the
auth party is we literally said no none
of the people that were ever involved in
any of these positions can ever hold
like public office or whatever
and the amount of tomfoolery that went
on in that government and how crazy
everything became with how
horrible the government put together the
guy that we put in there the maliki guy
there's just so much mismanagement from
that um
but regardless of how all of that went
down i'm just i'm not envious of being
somebody that has to figure out how we
leave the middle east now
because it's so rough in terms of like
because if you just pull everything out
a lot of vacuums are created we've got
other allies in the region that get
irritated
um like you know israel or the gulf
states don't want to see like a united
uh you know like uh syria iraq iran like
this united front of people and it seems
like we've already kind of lost iraq in
terms of like being an ally like it's a
rough
i'm not saying i don't support boys
everywhere but i understand the
um even for trump i understand the
position i just feel like we can't stay
there what's up with our troops in
pakistan
luke mentioned that last night i don't
know anything about it oh i don't know
but was about to break out between uh
you know china india pakistan so uss
troops in pakistan to observe
i don't know i don't know i mean i know
uh the uss troops and paramilitary
groups all over the world in places you
don't know about
we just had breaking news about a cia
guy dying in somalia and some secret oh
yeah
i'm sure we have a lot of people in a
lot of places i think uh
i was like do you know sean parnell's no
he's running for congress republican he
said
he doesn't think we can just pull out
all our troops because that's how you
get isis you create this vacuum and then
someone comes in
but he does think that we can dramatic
we can reduce it quite a bit and have a
way drawn down presence and just kind of
main help maintain i think our problem
ever since bush um is we just don't have
like a cohesive mission
and when you don't really have a clear
objective then like this the the one
thing that we need to stop doing is
having wars on things
like a war on poverty a war on drugs a
war on terrorism like that these things
are going to exist throughout
the entirety of the world and when
you're when your objectives are so vague
you don't really know what you're
like when do we get off yeah you know
what you know you know i made a video
praising the green new deal before they
announced the green new deal
why because the idea initially was
government investment in
green technologies and energy energy
that would
bolster the economy make us energy
independent and environmentally friendly
that sounds great doesn't it that would
be awesome if that's what the green new
deal actually was
exactly it's not they want to change
dramatically change the economy they've
got social justice 20
of all companies sold to the workers
federal jobs guaranteed there's a lot of
other stuff
into that yeah exactly and that's that's
that's that's another reason i just
bring that up because it's like
you know it's funny i guess i'm
classified as right
for opposing the critical critical
theory stuff and supporting trump
primarily on the on the war stuff and
the critical race theory stuff
but unlike most other things i say it
all the time in like almost all my
videos
it's the weirdest thing but i understand
when these people make these these
these super cuts of me to insult me they
purposely dodge the stuff where i've
like
ranted about flint's water crisis sure
over and over again i'm pretty sure that
we took a totality of youtube content
you're probably being more critical of
the left than the right though
i'm critical of the critical race theory
left stuff sure yeah but when i say
things like
i understand why people are upset with
police and police brutality and i
did an hour-long documentary on it but
uh
i guess the issue is like when i've
criticized mcconnell and the republicans
it's because they're establishment crony
politicians who just want to be in
office
to get their paycheck and do nothing and
then that's what they do they do what do
they do they obstruct
they block and they're appointing
federal judges i mean that's doing
something i mean to their credit
republicans have done an amazing job in
the senate blocking if you're a
republican you should be happy with that
with mcconnell and the republicans in
the senate they did a great point all
those judges
you got three supreme court picks they
have pointed all the judges um yeah
they've been doing a knockout job if
you're a republican yeah
man everything's just so crazy and
broken right now
you know regarding pulling troops that
you reminded me when you brought up sean
parnell and pulling out troops creating
a power vacuum
that what we did with the iraqi
government once our troops were in
by disbanding their civil servants was
we created a power vacuum without
pulling our troops out
so pulling troops out is not the only
way to create a power vacuum that can
cause something like isis we can leave
our troops there and still cause that to
happen
yeah depending on how much you disrupt
things yeah we got to go to super chats
yeah go for it because we were supposed
to do it a long time ago we kind of just
kept going and just
we're basically chilling and having a
conversation an hour later one hour
later
well it's been 40 40 minutes uh how how
are you okay with very spicy questions
where people are mad at you yeah of
course
it's life online well here's the first
one that comes up mr obvious says
destiny said on camera that he lets his
girlfriend sleep with other men is that
true or was that just a meme
open relationships are pure cockery um i
like open relationships so
for me personally um and i understand
everybody has their own thing
i don't think i could ever be in a spot
in my life where i only want to have
sex with one person for the rest of my
life that is a hard sell for me
um so so what you're really saying is
that your girlfriend lets you sleep with
other women
well yeah and i know obviously well but
it's equal framing works sure
right right but that's never how it's
framed because it's funny because like
sometimes like
she'll complain that like she feels like
um and maybe like i get around too much
or it's not fair to her but then when
people like frame it in my relationship
it's that i'm literally sitting at home
while she's bringing home
like these massive bbc's that are just
railing her and blah blah blah i'm just
like crying in the corner whatever and
it's like okay
um different people from different
communities have very different ideas of
like how my personal life is very funny
you know what project their insecurities
under me you know jeffrey miller nope
uh he's he's like an intellectual dark
web personality okay
so you probably you know assume some
things about his personality in that
context but uh i think he's real big
into polyamory
so yeah that's technically what our
relationship yeah yeah yeah yeah
have you um no i don't want to derail
too much did you hear sam harris
recently on the idw and all that
no what did he say oh you just he kind
of disavowed a lot of it but i don't
want
to
realize it yeah he's he's like really
hardcore anti-trump in a weird way
like by all means
there are a few people on the internet
that were i think legitimately
like centrist um but they built up very
conservative audiences like your
audience i think is very conservative
yeah even they're not correct
okay if i go and look at any and i did
this before i came because it's because
you look at like any of the top comments
on like
all of your past videos the comments are
very different comments are driven by
controversy
so this this this this stream we have is
one of the like one of the highest
super chats we've done because of the
controversy the comments of course yeah
i agree with that yeah
but but okay so i okay so i don't know
if i can
we're not gonna argue over but like um
there are some people that play a center
role but they end up building like very
right-leaning audiences and whenever
they clash with them they run into a
huge problem so sam harris example do
you know thunderfoot
yeah that was a guy that was there were
a lot of like this is like the gamer
thing a lot of people came out and
they're like oh i'm a centrist they're
probably more right than not but
thunderfoot legitimately i think had
like his principled stance something
that anytime he would say anything
negative about trump he would get
slaughtered by his audience i will i
will say it probably is uh dependent
upon
um where you are like to call someone
conservative or liberals
is like it's extremely subjective i kind
of i look at the fan bases i guess when
i think of like what kind of person is
this person
because usually the fan base can be
pretty telling like what kind of people
do they attract
so we did a survey and uh i would say
that if you were to combine
the groups between left and right left
slightly out ranks right of my audience
but they're like moderates sure they're
not leftist they're not hardcore
they're not even traditional liberals
they're just like it's hard doing left
and right because some people are very
like single issue
like there might be a lot of people that
are literally just when it comes to the
critical race theory i
imagine cause you talk about it quite a
bit like that's like their one issue so
they might consider that they think
yeah and and foreign policy stuff so
initially i was like bolton wow trump i
can't believe he's doing this stuff it's
so dumb
but the media certainly lies about him
way too much some of this stuff is
ridiculous
unfortunately which makes it really hard
yeah there's a lot of dumb stories do
you remember the fish food one
yeah with with shinzo abe yeah just it's
it's it's exactly stupid stuff
one of my favorite things about trump
being out of office one of the happiest
reasons why he's gone
and i'm so looking forward to him he's
not going yes well
i'm looking forward to moving past the
like all the snl the dumb skits and the
dumb jokes and all that like i mean dude
you know i legitimately hate trump more
than a lot of people but even i'm tired
of like all the like okay you know you
know what i'm excited for is uh
the media just falling apart their
ratings were in the gutter before trump
trump saved them
and even twitter i think there's always
things in the media that they can
criticize i don't think they're going
anywhere jon stewart yeah a lot of
people ask us with stewart they're like
oh well after bush is gone like
isn't the media gonna have nothing to do
he's like hmm they'll always carry on at
some point but he's retired
i disagree what we saw before trump
was apocalyptic shane smith the ceo of
vice said we're we're going to see a
bloodbath in digital in the next
you know year or so but then trump got
elected or then i'm sorry before that
could have happened trump started
campaigning
and then all of a sudden ratings on tv
started skyrocketing
cnn's rating started governing fox news
youtube viewership everything started
going
nuts around trump if trump you know uh
if
if this is the end he doesn't run 2024
if he doesn't stay in public light if he
doesn't pull off some triple helmer or
whatever
twitter was bleeding users before trump
started you know
before he got elected media companies
were downsizing and laying people off
over like endlessly even in the past few
years without trump
yeah i guess we'll see what happens
trump-ism i guess they're going to talk
about whatever maybe yeah we'll see what
i'm going for all right let's read let's
read some more of these super chats
a lot of people who don't like you
joanna davidoff says guy came out of his
basement to get on tim's show
question uh nice been living on my own
for the past like 15. i just read that
one seriously
the projection is real go ahead all
right let's see luke durkin says destiny
if trans men equals men then men equals
trans men correct
no he says there's a category error
right so
um if uh if uh if green beans equal
vegetables do vegetables equal green
beans
so like if you want to broaden the
category of men to include trans men
just because all trans men would be in
the category of men doesn't mean that
all men are in the category of trans men
it's like a subset of the other
whether or not you agree with trans
issues or whatever like yeah it's yeah
it doesn't logically follow he says
same for women so we are we all trans
youtube blocking me hence the use of
he yeah okay so i think you clarified
that sure shoddy viceroy says here's
something crazy how about the government
stops dipping their grubby hands out of
my pockets
you lock me down i lose my job i lose my
house and then i end up on the streets
because the government decided my rights
are
uh sidestepped because of a disease
that's horrible there should be more
stimulus
you know what though i think i think one
thing i definitely should say is
people don't want to be dependent on the
government they don't want a reliance i
think that's true of almost everybody
yeah
i don't so what if people just said no
we don't want to do that wait you don't
what
no i i think it's true of almost
everybody that nobody wants to be
relying on stimulus like people like to
work and feel like they're
yeah yeah yeah for sure so then the
natural recourse i guess would be for
people to say protect the vulnerable but
open the economy so i can work
i think people in australia new zealand
and south korea all like to work too and
they somehow manage to
lock down for a little bit keep the
virus under control open up go back to
they don't have the same constitution we
do though that's
that's crazy that's a legal we're
talking legal versus philosophical
argument right
philosophically i think that it's okay
to take a break for two months and get
everything under control and then go
back to work um legally i don't know if
there are grounds for it i know people
have fought a lot over how much the
president can do in terms of enforcing
lockdowns yeah they bring up stuff we
did
under the spanish flu and how much the
government did there i i don't know the
legal arguments there
i think even a lot of legal people don't
know the arguments they're not sure what
do you think about universal basic
income
um i'm a big like um
i have some like fundamental principles
i think everybody in society
ought to have the access and the
opportunity to do whatever they want in
a happy healthy manner
um if ubi is the way to get there then
cool
um i know they were running a few ubi
experiments in canada i'm not a fan
although you're not you're not a fan or
i'm not a fan i'm not a fan of ubi oh
i if uvi is one of those things that
works really well if we like do this
like in a state or whatever it's like
wow this actually like enabled so many
people
then yeah go for it um but if not then
yeah i don't have a strong opinion on my
way either
i don't like unemployment insurance
because if you get a job you lose it so
there's an incentive to not get a job to
continue to collect your unemployment
yeah there's a guy on a twitter
med medlock i don't know if you're right
he fights we fight with this guy on
twitter but there's um
there's an interesting argument to be
made about like marginal tax marginal
tax rates basically
that when you have these programs for
poor people
what happens is is that as they earn
more money
in a roundabout way they're kind of sort
of getting penalized for it and
increasing matters because the
welfare that they're receiving is like
dropping off which is an interesting
argument i don't know if i believe it
but basically the idea is that like if
you get unemployment insurance you're in
a way punished for working because as
you start to work you're really not
making as much money right and then ubi
it wouldn't taper off you'd always
continue to get it yeah that's better
that's that's what i like it's one of
those things where i'd have to see how
it plays out
all right trucker and taurus says lock
everything down how do you get food
it doesn't just appear on the shelf i am
a part of the supply chain for that
we would be forced to be slaves working
while y'all get to sit home
nah man you're already slaves working
i'm sorry it's a capitalist economy
you want to eat and have food and uh
also like a home you're already slaves
to the economy so
i guess in the in the sense that we we
did it or we could do it we did
have a complete total lockdown for two
months absolutely not not in the united
states
why not because because most restaurants
are still seating people indoors most
places where it's still
oh you mean in the country yeah wait
what were you talking about just like we
we had the lockdown in like new york for
instance it didn't work um
my understanding is that the the states
in the northeast i'd have to look at the
coronavirus but the states in the
northeast that did lock down
did a really good job of bringing in
infections are controlled it all came
back well
as you relax the restrictions it comes
back of course yeah so that means we're
just going to lock down forever
um it means that you have to be more
careful about the measures that you take
in terms of like
opening and closing and like the
responsible like things so new york new
york locked down hardcore
and they did and they brought the
infection right down hardcore and then
they
started to reopen and it just came right
back sure so then so you you have to
work on tapering on and off
basically the goal is you have to make
it it's a ton that's untenable man it's
not untenable the goal is to make it so
that you don't
overflow your hospital usually for the
most part the united states hasn't done
so far well so i'm not saying that you
lock it down and the virus has gone
forever right even in australia it came
back and victoria they had a huge spike
right
so we just locked down for two months
open for two months locked up for two
months i i think the goal would be
to have it like it doesn't feel like in
the united states we have a good sliding
scale of like
lockdown level one two three four like
we're locked down now
and then it's like okay well we're kind
of open like i think florida georgia
some southern states have done this
where it's like okay hold on guys
and then it's like ah it's good just
everything's open again i think that if
you have like the more measured like
we can do this and this and this and you
slowly expand it cases rise you close
you open we're waiting for the vaccine
like i think that's kind of how you have
to play it
ideally we haven't hit the point yet in
the united states where hospitals are
like overflowing that much i think a
couple counties in texas
complained about it it's been specific
hospitals yes and there's a lot of empty
i know that california has been
projecting that over christmas if cases
continue to rise away where we might get
overflowing um that's like the
doom yeah hopefully not but that's like
the doomsday scenario that we're trying
to avoid
um and so far we've skirted that
although economically suffered a ton of
harm for it i i guess the retrospective
on this will be very interesting
prakar jay says lol destiny got tim to
admit trump equals incompetent
i don't think that person watches any of
my videos like
there's a reason why the the trump
forums they called me a bald cook and
they make fun of me
because i've never been like
trump waving a maga flag i've been
saying things like i think he's not that
bad i think there's a bunch of things
he's done that's way better
i think joe biden i i got a really
negative joe biden thing because of the
obama administration all that stuff
but uh yeah like we in the conversation
i was talking about his lawsuit
i talked about it earlier that uh i got
i got ragged on pretty hard for
criticizing sydney powell and now look
what's happening they're criticizing
sidney powell
people don't watch my content you know
and then they come in here and they
haven't have an assumption about me i'm
sure you get the exact same thing
sure bug pop says common cheap and
well-known promising drugs was
reassuring
consider placebo and no sibo effects
some people with terminal cancer
prognosis die before cancer becomes
fatal
no sibo highly correlates with high
stress i'm not sure what that was
i think he's trying to say that trump
lying about the threat of the
coronavirus was better for the
overhealth of the country which can be
true but that's only if you're doing
work in the background
so for instance if we're telling a
cancer patient maybe we're being a
little bit optimistic that doesn't mean
we halt all treatment and halt all
cancer research
i might be a little bit nicer to you
about the outcome of your chemotherapy
but it doesn't mean i'm going to stop
giving you the drug
sajon the great says i was literally
watching the videos on election night of
the booting
the boarding of the tabulation rooms etc
destiny is regurgitating nonsense
so there were videos uh from a bunch of
different states like
i watched a ton of live election
coverage that night i just
like you said it yourself i agree with
you it's really hard to watch one video
and figure out what's going on like
there's so much like
one video is posted and then and i and i
have to be careful because like
i don't want to be eating you know my
there's an expression for this but like
i don't want to like be
totally wrong where like two days later
it's like you retweeted this video
didn't you know that this happened two
months ago or like this was like a four
year old video i was like oh shoot well
i didn't know right
some people with that people got some
people with that with the uh um look at
how horrible
these uh uh immigration camps are
whatever it's like yeah that's like oh
well these pictures are under obama's
administration
there's a video of a guy getting
arrested and then everyone said it was a
covet arrest but it had nothing to do
with cove it was three years ago
yeah so yeah so i i try like it's you
can paint whatever picture you want with
a 20-second clip
on twitter and i saw this with uh with
the written house stuff oh my goodness
there's
so many different things based on some
videos and it's like okay
oh we got you here marty says this guy
contradicted himself the moment he
admitted he's very wealthy wealthy in
the beginning
lockdowns hurt the middle class
government supports the poor 1200
is not going to save the middle class
families from losing everything he'll be
okay
i don't deny that at all the trump
administration has been great for me
this election is awesome
this election is a win-win for me
because i saved my
well they are now but that's not but i
still get to gloat over trump people but
if trump would have won
i'm probably saving more on my taxes
than the average trump voter earns so
it's a win-win for me i mean like if you
want to keep voting in a guy that's not
gonna help you and it's gonna get more
money people like me i'm okay with that
um at the end of the day none of this
lifetime stuff hurts anybody in in my
position of course not online content
we are like perfectly positioned to get
richer off of this conflict
but when i vote i try to keep in mind
like the general well-being of the
population
that's what they're saying what do you
mean like i said i feel the exact same
way
i think joe biden's gonna be bad for
everybody oh sure well i'm just saying
this guy was trying to make an argument
that i'm better off under the um
lockdown of course
oh yeah yeah absolutely i think there
should be more stimulus though a single
1200
check is a joke totally i agree uh i
don't like the idea of endless stimulus
though i think
i don't either sure i i think if we did
the lockdown then we got a productive
vulnerable and open it back up
unemployment insurance is an endless
stimulus
well no those are usually captain a
certain number i think they extend
yeah unemployment extended it a long
time ago but that that's that's it's
that's no there's no money that's not
not a lot of money it's
but there will always be people
receiving it yeah sure but we're talking
about like
it's talking about paying every citizen
not to work for extended periods of time
yeah
a little bit farther than unemployment
insurance i think we got
to take a middle road approach i suppose
we did the lockdowns we tried it okay
now
we do now we slowly reopen we take
social distancing measures we wear masks
we protect the vulnerable and we get the
economy back in
in in high gear now we'll see i mean the
mortality
the mortality rate's 99.9 for people
uh our survival rate i'm sorry
the survival rate for people under 70 is
like 99.9 percent for
really high yeah complications but the
people that go to the icu that's the
thing that this has always been the
scare to be clear
um every young person can be infected
and like you're probably not gonna die
the the the scary part is just that like
of the five percent or ten percent of
people that are infected that need to go
to the icu if those beds run out then
you run into like your death rate will
skype
the comorbidities that concern me well
that's that's
it's comorbidities that basically are
like the those are the rickety bridge
and then the co-op
you know is this just inevitable anyway
from the obesity epidemic
well i would say partly i mean
comorbidities are bad but if anything
that's even more of a reason to be safe
about things right like we have
comorbidities in this country that are
going to
make you more there's got to be a
compromise where at a certain point we
say okay we tried we did the lockdowns
now we got to get back to work
yeah of course poverty yeah or we've got
uh our stimulus
story clark says on your show you've had
self-made entrepreneurs dignified family
men then there's this guy
this is why the majority of people know
there's about to be a civil war this guy
is an embarrassment we all need to get
ready for a fight day by day
that's where it's going you're an
entrepreneur right uh yeah
it was i think i was i was in the f if i
wasn't the first i was in the first
group of people to
quit their job and do online streaming
full-time if i wasn't the first one i
was in the group of the first people so
i was going to say something before when
you mentioned that my audience was
mostly conservative uh i think the
biggest bracket is actually like
libertarian types
there's probably that kind of
conservatives there's probably an
overlap but i think
they're do you know about the jonathan
heights research in uh world foundations
no what about it so there's originally
there were five not that now they say
they're six they added liberty because
they found libertarians have one moral
foundation
liberty but it's uh i'm probably gonna
miss them there's
uh um you know was it care fairness
sanctity authority and what is it
loyalty
i think so yeah and liberty i think
something like that and
uh liberals operate on two care and
fairness they don't really register with
the other
other four and libertarians operate
solely on liberty
so there's a big difference between like
libertarians and servers probably
overlap on certain
issues but that's the big difference we
i did an event we did a survey and we
found
that uh the like the biggest share was
probably like moderate libertarian types
okay a lot of trump supporters though
like like like 30 or so but then like
the bigger
you know was outside of it let's see
andrew bishop says i'm in australia and
i know that people were
i know p i know that people were kicked
out and not let into some pa's voting
stations
to observe did he say he's in australia
yeah okay
known this since the election wow answer
that's horrible
buffalo bill says how about the pa court
changing voter law not the legislature
well oh that was the supreme court
ruling on uh what was that on
on the deadlines or whatever i don't
think yeah i think that was the one case
that they won right where they
said that like this you didn't have the
authority to do this if that's what he's
referring to i don't remember the
specific case
i know there was one where somebody
tried to change a deadline that they
didn't have the authority to do it
wasn't over whether they
should or shouldn't but it was they
didn't have the authority to do that
particular thing tommy allen says has he
read the great reset plan it's awful
you'd have to be uneducated to think
it's good
lockdowns aside did you read the great
reset at all what is the great reset
plan uh
the idea of making stuff more like green
friendly we probably
probably would have been more fair if we
actually pulled up and read through a
lot of it but it's very much like
a 10-point plan the pro the thing that i
the problem that i have with a lot of
grandiose stuff like that
is that um you can phrase a lot of that
to sound good but
these could be like very different
depending on how you implement them
so like if somebody for instance says
like we have a plan to make like
buildings more energy efficient
like one way to do that could be federal
funds that like
you know reinforce or or change the
structure of buildings such as the more
energy efficient or it could be like a
seven thousand dollar tax on like every
you know thing you can say like there's
like three different ways
mass conscription you know yeah sure
yeah the national guard
the only reason why i don't usually like
like vague broad plans of like this is
how we're going to go green and it's
like okay well show me like what you
actually want to do like i don't care
what your mission is i like andrew yang
because of that
he was very transparent because he had
one thing it was one thousand dollars
didn't he have like a huge uh government
i know that he talked a lot about like
automation and stuff but the one point
that he hammered home all the time was
the ubi yeah he got pigeonholed
yeah we have a super chat they say that
you push [ __ ] is that true
manga mango do you push [ __ ] that's
very offensive mango
i'm kidding it's a skateboard confused
it's uh someone said
tim don't worry this guy pushes [ __ ]
what is [ __ ] oh so
uh in skateboarding when [ __ ] is when
you take your front foot off the board
and push
instead of your back foot off the board
backwards no it's not goofy
it's called [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah so
uh goofy is when your right foot
is pointed forward regular is when your
left foot is forward
mango is when in either position you
take your front foot off
so you essentially have the full end of
the boat with no foot on it
it's like very improper and people are
making a joke about it dude last night
they were all over me i had to
write a reading i thought it was funny
wow all right so that there's a uh there
are a lot of super chats where they
don't like you
i'm not going to read all of them but as
many as you want i don't care it's fine
i i just want to get to more substantive
points where you know people are just
saying things like you know whatever
uh let's see courtney gray says
destiny you are not bringing anyone over
to your views vinegar versus honey if
you want to change people's minds then
lose the snark and add homonym
i don't think i snarked or at home that
much in this conversation i thought it
was okay
yeah i think there are definitely ones
where i do more and there are definitely
ones where i try to be more compromising
um it really just depends on the
audience depends on the setting with
this audience i notice i don't want to
be too general but when i start to
dump on trump if i just start to insult
him people get really angry at the other
stuff i say in the conversation
if i don't trash trump something that's
true i've noticed it a trend
because i a lot of people that watch
this show seem to love him
well you look at the comments i look at
the comments yeah i'm talking about the
text
comments yep that's why a lot of the
comments are making fun of me quite a
bit as well
especially now let's see
dom d says love the show well like like
i mentioned on the on the trump forum
they're posting memes about me making
fun of me you know what i mean because i
didn't get on board with the voter fraud
stuff like to a hardcore degree
like my it was really funny there's uh
uh that transparency tube thing does the
tracking of who supports and opposes
trump's view
on uh on voter fraud and they had me
listed for the most part as supporting
his view and i was like whoa like
that's not true and so i told him like
you guys did you actually watch my
videos and then they changed them to
other like neither opposing or
supporting i'm like there you go okay
because i've i just said there's
evidence here's the evidence is it proof
no but we need to investigate that's not
you know same position
let's see dom d says love the show i
know this is a big ask but i would love
to be on your show
it's the most exciting time terrifying
time for our country and i'd love to
hash it out
i message you on parlor tim please reach
out also would like to help with future
projects
well i guess the issue is we always try
to have guests that are
without being rude or anything just just
relevant to the cert like to
you know to something going on i think
in your instance
for one i think people were tweeting you
at me and then i think you tweeted at me
or whatever
but also we literally are going through
this election period right now i thought
it'd be good to bring on
uh we also we're going to be having a
progressive political candidate coming
on at some point
so this will be really interesting
conversation this is the kind of stuff i
think is particularly relevant
for uh what's going on right now in the
future i'll probably have a rock star of
some sort on or you know we'll see what
happens
whatever walking tour says not trusting
either tim
or destiny makes this better wish tim
had been better he could have been the
best but our gen uh
the best of our gen but sold out licking
trump
yeah well then you know there you go hot
super chats tonight
spicy oh yeah i love it my tongue's
bernard kim says tim occam's razor
destiny it's complicated
some people are saying uh sorry sorry
tim tapping out only so much lib
tardness a man can take in one night
it is exhausting to witness um no no no
like um cognitive dissonance when you
see things that oppose your worldview it
actually requires glucose
to process it it seems like it is
healthy and strengthens your mind to
listen to conversations like this
correct
you by all means please hate both of us
all three of us all four just don't
trust i like that comment don't trust
anyone here listen to it
and then do your own research to figure
out if it's right
i need it mw says tim having a
conversation doesn't mean bend over and
let him run a train on you
well uh if is what i was saying like
if you have an opinion and you're like
in my opinion trump didn't do a good job
what am i supposed to say well your
opinion is wrong
you can't say that you have an opinion
okay you know whatever like
what am i gonna you know what it's if
you argue that like
we're talking about michael flynn for
instance okay that's where it's like
well hold on let's talk about the facts
but if you don't like what trump has
done
when when i had vashon it was like by
what metric do we gauge trump's job on
the chronovirus because
it's one president in one country and
like this confident happened in the
united states a different time and
countries are all different so it's
either you like trump and you think he's
doing a bad job and here's why or you
are you like trump you think he's a good
job here's why or you hate him and he's
a bad job here's why or
there's a middle ground of some sort
whatever
md lego says this conversation is a
prime example of why civil strife is
inevitable
neither side will concede even when
presented contrary facts are proven
wrong
just deflect onto other and finger point
that's not true i i in one instead
actually you're right on that i should
walk that back
on time sp sullivan and we actually have
been very calm in our disagreements this
is a this is an excellent indication of
there doesn't have to be any kind of
conflict chatting yeah i know i find it
like
friends hanging out but we just happen
to have cameras on
and that's the kind of viewpoints that's
all yeah i think we probably have a
couple of i think of core like
philosophical disagreements over
yeah how to run things which probably is
where a lot of our larger so for
instance when you say you vote for
yourself enough for other people
that would probably be like a core
philosophical agreement we'd have to
hash out to truly like it's actually
more nuanced than just to say it like
that yeah i'm sure because the foreign
positive clearly isn't for me
sure of course but what i mean to say is
like i can't vote based on what other
people are thinking i don't know
i can't vote for someone else yeah when
i yeah when i see a policy
i only know how it makes me feel and
what i think and when it affects other
people i take issue with it
sure the healthcare stuff is like
grandiose and confusing a lot of ways
yeah i understand dropping bombs on
foreign countries i think is kind of
easier to understand you know
sure i used to see like full um
universal health care
and then i started thinking maybe we
should only cover like uh
acute we talk about it but not chronic
health because i feel like people are
poisoning themselves of food and then
they go to the hospital and i got
why would i pay for someone else's poor
dietary choices but then there's things
like type 1 diabetes where like
genetic disorders that are chronic so
maybe certain types of chronic
it's unfortunately with healthcare
unfortunately it'd be nice if there was
like a merit-based way of covering
certain people but you kind of have to
just do it all because it's really hard
even with like type 2 diabetes some
people are prone to it some people
aren't with the same exact diet and
lifestyle like
i got we got a super chat i think we
definitely gotta read it says uh tribe
and clan says great to hear destiny
making excuses for violent rioters
because orange mad said something
disagree with
no humanity with this guy trump
derangement at its finest
i thought that was interesting because
you got booted from the partner program
on twitch for defending i've
taken heat from both ends of this so my
stance is so incredibly clear on this
and i repeat it one more time
if you want to write i support your
ability to riot to the ends of the earth
if it's against public institutions
riding against private individuals is
that's just larceny and burglary and
theft and vandalism i don't ever ever
support that one million percent
um but i people on the right tell me
that i'm pro
riding against everybody people on the
left tell me i'm pro uh hit squads
i don't know but like like my
interesting position i i think it's
super easy it's i've always had the same
position on some defense if you want to
defend your property that is your right
like it's one of the most important
things
one of the most fundamental things is
property rights and the ability to
defend the stuff that you own you train
hours of your life
um you trade hours of your life to
acquire this stuff you can defend that
but
um you know if you want to go writing
it's like a police station these are
public institutions funded by public
money they represent the government um
it's a way more powerful message than
just like blowing up car dealership
i don't like the rioting i think protest
whatever the problem i have is just
like violence against other people yeah
it's it's a challenge though because at
a certain point
like when i had vashan he mentioned is
political violence ever acceptable
like what about the jews rising up
against the nazis i'm like for sure i
get it you know what i mean like yes
there is a point at which you have to
fight back and defend yourself there's
also that we also have to acknowledge
that political violence has to be a
last option or near the lesser because
otherwise you're in
you get it it's always very weird areas
very quickly you know like could i be
violent against republicans for like
immigration
policy if you are somebody that's
impacted like there's like a lot of
stuff and i think you can justify some
of these but it gets really weird if you
start saying everyone should act on it
because then we're basically all killing
each other all the time for everything
you know mitch stu says everyone drink
when destiny says he's the
commander-in-chief
a deflection from trump being one man
facing american bureaucracy
that one man is the head of our military
aka the commander-in-chief so
what what we'll drink today check it out
happy little tree says as a fan of tim
poole and of destiny since the root days
this might have been one of the best
podcasts in a while thanks both of you
for doing this
cool what's that make sure i read the
what's the root this one's on so
starcraft 2 team i was on
oh wow what's your race uh i'd say like
half cuban half european
no no no you're starcraft i'm sorry oh
you're zerg
vanessa stuller says i want this elite
shill to go to flint and tell them that
trade agreements are good for them
tell them their poverty is good so other
countries can come out of poverty
uh what does it say first one ce he said
this it was obvious
once he said this it was obvious he is a
cnn shill okay i mean like you can say
the same i want you to go to other
countries like in southeast asia that
have been like
gaining so much economic power because
of the liberalization of trade between
them and other countries until they're
global poor
that like you guys don't matter you
shouldn't have access to this stuff like
go away like we're not going to trade
with you anymore like suffer in your own
countries i mean like you can play that
all day
it's a nationalist versus
internationalist view it's a dumb person
versus an actual economic point of view
the reality is
is that trade agreement that's the snark
trade agreements increase
wealth for everybody broadly but some
people are negatively impacted and those
people have not been taken care of
that's the problem if we do trade
agreements we should do them but we need
to take care of the people that get
negatively impacted by them we don't do
a good job of doing that
slightly customs says the very beginning
of covet 19 trump held a live interview
with every single governor in the united
states
and discussed what they needed and who
to contact both in private and public
sector
and took suggestions to improve he
actually did get praise from cuomo
and newsom and one other democrat i
think too i can't remember which one
maybe murphy they said that he was doing
a
great job in helping him out and it was
tremendous yeah in regards to some
specific things i believe coimon was
specifically talking about getting
equipment from the federal government in
terms of ppe and like ventilators and
stuff i think he did say like yeah this
was good that they were able to
uh supplies with that jeremy landry says
destiny i disagree with a lot
i disagree with a lot of what you said
tonight but thank you so much for coming
onto this show and exposing me to your
arguments yes indeed
so it's all about man expose myself any
way you want me to
no don't say that final
why kazer says i love ian he's the best
even if i disagree sometimes he's a
solid genuine dude
yeah that's great i gotta read the
positive ones too because they're
constantly like you won't
suck because it's like brainwashing pep
everybody up there
yeah man thanks dude neon noir says tim
poole don't you dare skip this destiny
you're a beta male 1
good one i had to read it he told me
that too okay tommy
you have to i mean you can't yeah uh
la lauren says nice to see destiny on
your show tim best two worst shows on
youtube are america first
steve franson tim cass destiny stephen
crowder david pakman foss shapiro tyt
oh best of worst type where was i on
that list uh
you're actually you're actually right
next to me so third or fourth
fourth and i'm in third behind somebody
who's first place was nick fuentes
show yeah yeah yeah so it shows you wow
but
that person holds you in uh decent to
steam you know great look at that mix i
like that america first and shapiro
jeez all right let's see what a broad
media consumption you kind of look like
sheamus coughlin do you know
he does freedom tunes i don't know not
really i don't look like shamus
tommy allen says you want a ussf uh
officer to come on and chat about
anything not against the ucmj especially
conspiracies i'd wreck
ian wait wait tell me that again whoa
whoa whoa what
the gauntlet's been thrown a ussf
officer to come on and chat about
anything not against the ucmj i don't
know these things
i wish i knew what those letters stood
for google it look it up
all right all right we'll take uh we'll
take one more and then it's like 11
40. so we really went long irishman says
if there was no government intervention
in healthcare
it would be cheap and easy like
mcdonald's because there was the
cheapest and best in the world in 1950s
before insurance insurance is the
problem
jesus christ educate yourselves think i
i
i brought that up that was the argument
right so here's something from a
from a computer programmer perspective
okay from somebody that's absolutely not
a programmer okay any time you go to
make a new project the number one
question you always ask yourself
and anybody that i know there are a lot
of programs the first thing you ask is
has this been done before
because you do not reinvent the wheel on
anything business owners will do this
anybody that's starting any kind of
business what you do is you find out
okay well what works
and then hey if this works copy it
because if i'm going to pay somebody
hours to work or something i'm going to
pay you to do something that somebody's
already done for me why would i do that
when it comes to healthcare every single
other oecd country in the world has some
form of at least multi-payer system
except for like i think like switzerland
they're like one other country that
doesn't one really small country
or like luxembourg or i don't know but
like everybody else does this it seems
to work exceedingly well for most people
if you look at how much money we spend
we spend so much more than everybody
else and we don't have outcomes to show
for it it's horrible
um like i just like we can try to
theorize like
we talked about health care system or
whatever but like why not we do it we do
have better
technology better access better
treatments the only technology yes
access no
we the reason we don't have universal
health care is because the insurance
industries are predatory and they're
bribing politicians it is simplistic but
it's also occam's razor
so obviously the resistance that's
generated in europe they had people
dying in the streets after world war ii
and had no choice in the u.s we've built
a complete
function of like uh 22 percent or
whatever of our like twenty two thousand
dollars for an emergency room i know
it's very
probably after world war ii we also tied
health care to our jobs and that was a
stupid really really horrible thing as
well yeah
so anybody that's had a friend i had a
friend growing up that worked at
mcdonald's and he was a slave to them
forever because he was a type 1 diabetic
and he can't leave because of the
pre-existing what are they like it's
like
neo-feudalism essentially basically yeah
because they're that i can't character
them i can't leave yeah
you know and that's why i think uh
epipens and insulin two really good
examples of things that should be should
be cheaper and that's why i think base
level coverage
i'd be totally down for there's man you
know
you know ultimately comes down to things
like healthcare is it's a massive
massive system with millions of jobs
tied into it yeah the nhs on the uk is
huge yeah
yeah yeah it's it's not so easy to be
like can we jump this entire system and
move it over to like a national system
so for me i usually just sit back and
say like i can't answer these questions
for you that's one of the reasons why i
like things like for instance like a
medicare or medicaid expansion because
we take something that already works
most people seem to like quite a bit and
then you just open that up to more and
more people
or give them the opportunity to join and
then turn that into some form of
problems i don't like i don't like the
progressives abolishing private
healthcare no that's the dumbest thing
in the world but they lost on that
hard yeah they fought for that during
the primary season and they lost heart
even though they're all crying about it
on twitter because nobody does that
the the okay let me be very very very
very very clear the medical
um the the health insurance program that
bernie sanders was suggesting
would have been the most extreme health
care plan in any country in the world it
was not what europe does it wasn't what
canada does
it was the borrowing of private
insurance even from things like dental
and medical
nobody in the world does that it would
it would have been yeah the most
left-leaning plant possible
those crazy far leftists huh yeah anyway
he did the big ask so that he could get
a little sure he did sure he did well
yeah maybe the election so yeah good job
there
uh destiny thanks for coming on hanging
out this has been fun yeah we we
we we always go extra long when there's
like more uh
you know i guess uh adversarial elements
to an extent not like i think we're
screaming each other
like that but uh thanks for hanging out
do you want to mention your your now
uh partner your band channel uh follow
my channel on twitch.tv
destiny or i am youtube.com destiny
pretty easy to find
wow you have youtube comments like
destiny yeah and i have instagram.com
wow i'm sure uh the destiny video game
is probably shaking their fist at you
oh snap it was easier for them to just
call themselves destiny the game on
everything yeah yeah every now and then
somebody will stumble into the oh
because i have also the subreddit
reddit.com
destination you'll come in and be like
hey i need help getting through like the
hunter's crucible pretty sure it's like
you've had it for a while right like
nine years or something so i'm pretty
sure that's how i found out about you in
the first place
because i was playing destiny and i'm
like what is this guy what is i'm trying
to figure out how to beat you know
a quick horrible story um on my website
if you go to destiny
you can subscribe directly to me um
because that's the way the future is
what is it destiny.ggg destiny.gg yes
um i had a i woke up one day and i went
downstairs i had like 20 people that
messaged me
and they were like dude you need to help
this guy like he's in here trouble see
what's going on
and i go into my chat and some guy is
throwing a temperature he's got a purple
name
meaning he did the max level
subscription he's like 40 a month
and what had happened was this guy came
into my chat and he was asking questions
like
how do i get through this like dungeon
or raid everybody in the chat started
telling me if you want official tips
from bungie you have to do the maximum
level subscription and you
didn't know everyone in chat was making
fun of me for it because this guy just
paid like 40 bucks or whatever yeah
that's funny
oh man uh friends we will be back
tomorrow at 8 p.m
and and i don't normally announce a
guess but it's going to be luke again
and we're going to have
we're going to have time just because i
know he's here he's not going anywhere
so uh make sure to follow me on twitter
instagram parlor at tim cast
check out my other channels
youtube.comcast and
youtube.comtimcatsnews
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8pm we're also on all the
different podcast platforms so check us
out on itunes spotify etc
and don't forget to follow the other
people who are in the room we got ian
yes follow me
follow me everywhere uh let's to the
ends of the earth world of
world that's a warcraft three art uh
arthas said that to malganas oh that's
sad uh yeah you can follow me anywhere
and everywhere to the ends of the earth
at ian crossland
and of course you can follow at
sourpatch lids you can if you want to
sour pitch lids
l-y-d-s and we will be back tomorrow
night thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all then bye guys
you